>> IT IS GREAT TO HAVE A LITTLE
AFTERNOON BASEBALL AS WE HAVE
THE ST. LOUIS CARDINALS GETTING
SET TO TAKE ON THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS.
IT IS THE MLB PREVIEW OF THE
WEEK -- PREGAME SHOW OF THE
WEEK.
CORBIN BURNES IS FACING JACK
FLAHERTY, WHO HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUS.
THAT GAME IS COMING UP.
THIS IS A HUGE GET FOR US.
>> BIG GET.
>> THEY TALK ABOUT BOOKING
AGENTS, YOU'VE GOT MARK DEROSA
TO DO THE SHOW?
YOU JUST KNOCKED OUT THREE HOURS
OF MLB CENTRAL.
>> DON'T GIVE ME CREDIT WHERE IT
IS NOT DUE.
WE DUMBED IT DOWN TO TWO HOURS
TODAY.
I KNEW THIS WAS IN MY SCHEDULE.
[LAUGHTER]
WE WILL FIGURE THIS OUT.
I'M DIALED IN FOR THIS PITCHING
MATCHUP.
MY DAD ALWAYS SAID THE GAME
BEGINS AND ENDS ON THE MOUND AND
WE HAVE TWO OF THE BEST IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE GOING AT IT.
ADNAN: ADNAN VIRK ALONGSIDE MARK
DEROSA.
IN CASE YOU MISSED IT, THE
HIGHLIGHTS FROM LAST NIGHT.
>> TYLER O'NEILL.
0-2 TONIGHT.
A HIGH FLY BALL OUT TO DEEP
RIGHT.
IT MAY GO.
GONE!
THE GAME IS TIED.
>> TO RIGHT CENTER.
IT IS HEADED FOR THE GAP.
IT IS DOWN.
TRAVIS SHAW, GO-AHEAD DOUBLE IN
THE EIGHTH.
>> HE WAS ROCKING AND ROLLING.
>> DEEP.
GET OUT OF HERE!
GONE!
ADNAN: BREW CREW COMES UP WITH A
VICTORY AS WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
N.L. CENTRAL STANDINGS.
EVEN THE BUCS GOT OFF TO A
DECENT START.
ONLY 6.5 GAMES SEPARATE FIRST TO
LAST.
THE CARDINALS AND BREWERS LOOK
GOOD.
ST. LOUIS HAS BEEN ON A REAL
RUN.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT HAS BEEN GREAT
FOR THEM.
MILWAUKEE, STARTING PITCHING HAS
BEEN RIDICULOUS.
AS DERO SAID, THE PITCHING
REALLY IS WHERE THE FOCUS IS.
CORBIN BURNES HAS YET TO THROW A
WALK THIS SEASON.
MARK: I WONDER IF HE IS GOING TO
BE THINKING ABOUT THAT.
IT STARTS WEARING ON YOU LIKE A
HITTING STREAK.
ADNAN: HE IS THREE AWAY FROM
BREAKING KENLEY JANSEN'S RECORD.
YOU HAD TO THINK, THREE MORE,
LET'S GO.
MARK: I CAN REMEMBER WHEN GREG
MADDUX WAS GOING ON A STREAK
LIKE THIS IN BOBBY COX CAME OUT
ON THE RIGHT MOVE WAS TO
INTENTIONALLY WALK A GUY TO
BREAK UP THE STREAK.
HE GOES, ARE YOU OK WITH IT?
PEACE LIKE, PUT HIM ON.
ADNAN: I WOULD HAVE BEEN SELFISH
AND SAID NO.
[LAUGHTER]
UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCE.
GET BACK IN THE DUGOUT.
BURNS AND FLAHERTY.
HE HAS BOUNCED BACK.
CORBIN BURNES IS NOW ELITE
LEVEL.
MARK: HE IS THROWING STUFF WE
HAVE NEVER SEEN.
JACK FLAHERTY, YOU LOOK AT
CERTAIN PLAYERS AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC SHORTENED SEASON.
IT AFFECTED JACK FLAHERTY.
WE CAN DIVE INTO THE BREAKDOWN
RIGHT NOW.
I THINK IT WENT ABOUT THE WAY HE
WAS ATTACKING LEFT-HANDED
HITTERS.
IN 2019, YOU COULD ARGUE HE WAS
THE BEST PITCHER IN THE GAME.
HE HAD A SECOND HALF LIKE JAKE
ARRIETA HAD IN 2015 AND 2016,
THE STUFF OF LEGENDS WHERE
EVERYTHING IS PERFECTLY PLACED.
2020, IT KIND OF GOT SIDEWAYS
FOR HIM.
THE FIRST START WAS AROUND JULY
24, JULY 26.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE DID NOT
START AGAINST UNTIL AUGUST 19.
I HAD A CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT HIM
-- TALK TO HIM ABOUT HOW HE
PREPARES TO GET READY.
>> THERE ARE DIFFERENT BREATHING
TECHNIQUES THAT GO ON BEFORE I
GET OUT THERE.
THEN THERE IS JUST THAT DIGGING
DEEP AND FINDING THAT ENERGY.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW HOW TO
EXPLAIN IT.
BEING ABLE TO FIND THAT MINDSET
AND THAT MODE THAT WORKS FOR
YOU.
EVERY PLAYER AND EVERY PITCHER
IS DIFFERENT.
I'M RIGHT HERE AND THAT IS THE
WAY I HAVE TO GO ABOUT IT.
MARK: CAN WE PAUSE THIS REAL
QUICK?
I THINK CHRISTIAN YELICH TOOK IT
ON THE CHIN.
JAVIER BAEZ TOOK IT ON THE CHIN.
CERTAIN GUYS, CREATURE OF HABIT,
THAT 60 GAME SEASON REALLY
AFFECTED CERTAIN GUYS.
I THINK THAT AFFECTED HIM.
BUT THE WAY HE ATTACKED
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS IN 2019 AND
2021, VERY SIMILAR.
IN 2020, HE WAS THROWING HIS
HEATERS, IF I COULD GET IN HERE
REAL WAKE.
CARLOS PENA TALKS ABOUT
TUNNELING, BUT WHAT IS IT?
YOU WANT TO THROW THE HEATER UP
TOP, BUT YOU WANT TO GIVE THE
ILLUSION OF ANOTHER HEATER
THROWING THE BREAKING STUFF OFF
OF IT IN THE SAME TUNNEL.
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED HITTERS, HE
WAS LIVING DOWN IN THE ZONE WITH
EVERYTHING.
NONE OF THEM HAD TO RESPECT
ANYTHING FROM BELT UP.
HARD OR SOFT.
THEY COULD SET THEIR SIGHTS DOWN
AND AS LONG AS THEY DID NOT
SWING AT HIS SLIDER IN THE DIRT,
THEY WERE MORE EFFECTIVE.
LEFTIES GAVE HIM A LITTLE BIT
MORE TROUBLE.
HE IS BACK TO WORK IN THE
NORTH-SOUTH MENTALITY.
RUN IT.
YOU CAN'T COVER ALL THIS.
YOU CAN'T COVER 17 INCHES AND
COVER 96.
IT DISAPPEARS AT 80.
THIS NEXT ONE IS AWESOME.
HEATER IN, 95.
WE ARE GOING TO THROW SLIDER
RIGHT OFF THAT.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY UNHITTABLE.
AGAIN, BIG CITY RIGHT HERE, MATT
ADAMS, DOES NOT LOOK RIGHT IN
THAT COLORADO UNI.
HE NEEDS TO GET BACK TO ST.
LOUIS.
[LAUGHTER]
SOMETHING THAT KIND OF JUMPED
OUT WITH OUR RESEARCHER TO THE
STARS BREAKING IT DOWN.
HE IS ON TOP OF HIS GAME.
LAST THREE SEASONS, BASICALLY
BACK TO 2019.
.591 O.P.S.
YOU SEE IN 2020, THAT IS --
THROW THAT OUT.
ADNAN: OUR RESEARCHERS ARE
GREAT.
JACK FLAHERTY, THIS YEAR .562.
A 200 POINT DIFFERENTIAL IS
PRETTY INSANE.
MATH IS NOT EVEN OUR STRONG
SUIT.
GREAT STUFF FROM DERO.
PULL QUESTION.
REAL SIMPLE.
WHO IS GOING TO WIN THE GAME?
BREAKING DOWN THE GREATNESS OF
FLAHERTY.
BURNES HAS BEEN RIDICULOUS.
MAKING HIS FIRST START SINCE
APRIL 26.
HE THREW INTO A NET AND WORKED
ON HIS WIFE'S PELLETS IN --
PELETON DURING LOCKDOWN.
STILL TO COME, WE'VE GOT SOME
GREAT INTERVIEWS LINED UP.
MILWAUKEE BREWERS' LORENZO CAIN.
HE SCORED FROM SECOND ON A SAC
FLY.
WE ARE GOING TO ASK HIM ABOUT
AT YOUTUBE OR,
MLB THE SHOW, GIANT PHILLIES
FAN, THOSE GUYS AND MORE COMING
UP NEXT.
>> CAIN BACK IN.
LAST APPEARED IN A CONTEST ON
APRIL 13.
SWING AND A HIGH DRIVE.
CENTER FIELD.
WELCOME BACK, LORENZO CAIN.
>> THAT IS A RETURN.
>> THERE IS A BASE HIT BACK UP
THE MIDDLE.
>> AROUND THIRD ON HIS WAY TO
THE PLATE.
THE THROW IS CLOSE.
SAYING HE GOT HIM.
HE IS OUT.
THERE WE GO.
>> SERVES ONE IN THE EAR.
TYRONE TAYLOR WITH A SLIDING
CATCH FOR OUT NUMBER ONE.
>> 1-0 PITCH TO HAUSER.
SENDS THIS ONE INTO THE AIR.
RACING BACK IS COOPER.
HE HAS DONE IT AGAIN!
ADRIAN HOUSER GOES DEEP!
HALF OF COAST IN NO AGAIN!
>> ADRIAN HOUSER, LIGHTNING
STRIKES TWICE.
>> SEE HOW SHARP JOSH HADER WILL
BE AFTER SITTING FOR A WEEK.
A SWING AND A MISS.
THERE YOU GO.
>> THERE IS STRIKEOUT NUMBER
400.
FASTEST IN MAJOR LEAGUE HISTORY.
JOSH HADER.
♪
ADNAN: WELCOME BACK TO THE
PREGAME BY STATE ARM -- STATE
FARM.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT DEFENSIVE RUN
LEADERS, MOOKIE BETTS THE HEAD
OF THE CLASS, BUT RIGHT THERE IS
LORENZO CAIN, AARON JUDGE, KEVIN
KIERMAIER, HARRISON BADER.
YESTERDAY, ONE OF THE CRAZIEST
PLAYS, BADER AND CENTER FIELD
AND YOU SCORED ON A SAC FLY.
HOW WERE YOU ABLE TO DO THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, JUST INITIALLY I
SAW HIM GO BACK ON THE BALL, SO
I WAS READY TO TAG.
THEN I SAW HIM SLIP SO I WAS
UNSURE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
HE EVENTUALLY MADE THE CATCH.
I WAS ABLE TO GET BACK, TAG,
NEXT THING I'M HUSTLING ALL THE
WAY THROUGH.
ADNAN: IT IS AMAZING TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT.
HOW FIRED UP OR YOUR TEAMMATES,
EVERYONE IN THE DUGOUT?
>> EVERYONE WAS FIRED UP.
WE TRY TO ADD ANY KIND OF BOOST
TO THIS TEAM BECAUSE THINGS HAVE
NOT BEEN GOING THE WAY WE WANT
IT.
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP GRINDING
OUT THERE AND HOPEFULLY THINGS
START TO CHANGE.
ADNAN: IT MAKES ME THINK ABOUT
THAT GREAT RUN FROM FIRST BASE
IN 2015.
YOU REMEMBER THAT?
>> O YEAH.
I LIKE TO HUSTLE ANOTHER BASES.
I TRY TO MAKE IT TOUGH ON THE
THIRD BASE COACH WHETHER TO
DECIDE TO WAVE ME OR HOLD ME UP.
I'M ALWAYS PUTTING PRESSURE ON
MY THIRD BASE COACH.
I'M ALWAYS TRYING TO SCORE A
RUN.
ADNAN: THOSE ARE AMAZING IMAGES.
THE FACT THAT YOU TURN 35 AND
YOU ARE STILL FAST, I CAN
APPLAUD YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
REST OF THE SLOW POKES OUT HERE.
I THINK WE ALL KNEW HOW GOOD
BRANDON WOODRUFF IS, BUT CORBIN
BURNES HAS GONE TO THE NEXT
LEVEL.
WHAT HAS BEEN THE DIFFERENCE?
>> FOR ME, HE IS THROWING ALL
HIS PITCHES.
CUTTERS.
96, 97, 98.
HE IS FUN TO PLAY BEHIND.
OUR ENTIRE PITCHING STAFF HAS
BEEN LIGHTS OUT.
AS A GROUP, THIS PITCHING STAFF,
THIS BULLPEN, THOSE GUYS HAVE
BEEN DOING A GREAT JOB ALL YEAR
LONG. AS A DEFENDER IT IS FUN TO
PLAY BEHIND HIM AND YOU ALWAYS
WANT TO MAKE LEAS FOR THOSE
GUYS.
ADNAN: HE HAS NOT ALLOWED A
WALK.
HOW CRAZY IS THAT PINPOINT
CONTROL?
>> IT IS VERY IMPRESSIVE.
WOULD HE IS DOING IS VERY
IMPRESSIVE.
IT IS JUST FUN TO WATCH RIGHT
NOW.
YOU KIND OF FEEL BAD FOR THE
HITTERS SOMETIMES, BUT HE IS
DEFINITELY LIGHTS OUT,
DOMINATING THE GAME RIGHT NOW.
I THINK HE CAN DEFINITELY KEEP
THIS GOING FOR A LONG TIME.
ADNAN: OFFENSIVELY, IT HAS BEEN
A GRIND.
YOU ARE MISSING CHRISTIAN
YELICH.
HOW CRITICAL IS IT TO GETTING
HIM BACK IN THE LINEUP?
>> YOU KNOW, HAVING YELICH IN
THE LINEUP IS ALWAYS A GOOD
THING.
HE IS BATTLING HIS TAIL OFF TO
GET BACK IN THE LINEUP.
HE IS WORKING EVERY DAY IN THE
TRAINING ROOM TO GET HIS BACK
RIGHT.
WE DEFINITELY MISS HIM OUT
THERE.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE'VE GOT TO
GO OUT AND BATTLE AS A TEAM.
WE'VE GOT TO CONTINUE TO PULL
FOR EACH OTHER, STAY TOGETHER.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
HOPEFULLY, THINGS START TO
CHANGE.
ADNAN: YOU OFTEN SEE TURNOVER IN
THE GAME, BUT IN THE N.L.
CENTRAL, EVERY TIME IT IS A
TIGHT RACE THE LAST FIVE YEARS,
YOU FEEL LIKE ANYBODY CAN WIN,
AND THE SEPARATION IS VERY FEW
GAMES.
ANY IDEA WHY YOUR DIVISION IS SO
TIGHTLY CONTESTED EVERY YEAR?
>> I DON'T KNOW, JUST THE
DIVISION AS A WHOLE, JUST
PLAYING EACH OTHER.
EVERYBODY IS VERY COMPETITIVE.
I THINK THE PITCHING IS LIGHTS
OUT NOWADAYS.
I THINK IT IS GETTING TOUGHER
AND TOUGHER.
IN OUR DIVISION FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM, IT IS JUST A BATTLE.
EVERYONE IS VERY COMPETITIVE.
READY TO COMPETE EACH DAY.
I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE THAT
WAY THE REST OF THIS YEAR.
HOPEFULLY, WE COME OUT ON TOP.
ADNAN: BEEN WATCHING AND
ENJOYING YOUR CAREER FOR MANY
YEARS.
WHICH PUN DO YOU PREFER?
CITIZEN CAIN?
A ROSEBUD?
CAIN IS ABLE?
RAISING CAIN?
WHICH ONE DO YOU LIKE THE MOST?
>> WHILE.
I HAVE HEARD ALL OF THEM.
I GUESS I LIKE CAIN IS ABLE.
GO OUT THERE AND GET THE JOB
DONE.
ALL PARTS OF THE FIELD.
DEFENSIVE.
SWINGING THE BAT.
I LIKE CAI IS ABLEN -- CAIN IS
ABLE.
ADNAN: MY SISTER-IN-LAW IS FROM
WISCONSIN, CLOSE TO MILWAUKEE.
I LOVE THE FISH FRY.
I GET TO MILWAUKEE WHEN I CAN.
I UNDERSTAND YOU ARE A BIG
DALLAS COWBOYS FAN.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT HOW THEY
DID IN THE DRAFT?
>> MAN, I THINK THEY HAD A GREAT
DRAFT.
THEY ADDRESSED A LOT OF NEEDS.
CORNERBACK, LINEBACKER.
MICAH PARSONS IS GOING TO BE A
BEAST.
I THINK WE DID A GREAT JOB AND
I'M DEFINITELY EXCITED TO ROUTE
MY COWBOYS ON.
I WILL DEFINITELY GET TO A FEW
GAMES AND I'M EXCITED FOR THE
SEASON TO START.
ADNAN: LET'S HOPE DAK PRESCOTT'S
HELP DESK HEALTHY FOR YOUR --
PRESCOTT IS HEALTHY FOR YOUR
SAKE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE TIME.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
♪
ADNAN: TIME NOW FOR CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT, SOMEBODY WHO LOVES
THE GAME LIKE NO ONE'S BUSINESS
AND THIS WEEK IT IS FINN MACCO
NNELL.
LIVE COMMENTARY AND GAMEPLAY FOR
A VARIETY OF SPORTS VIDEO GAMES.
HIS FAVORITE MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL MOMENT CELEBRATING THE
LATE, GREAT ROY HALLADAY.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH FINN
FOR THE WIN?
>> IT PROBABLY CAME UP WHEN I
WAS ABOUT PROBABLY 15, I THINK.
PRETTY DEFAULT NAME, BUT IT
RHYMES, SO I DECIDED TO STICK
WITH IT.
ADNAN: I THINK IT IS KEY WHEN
YOU'RE USING SODA VACUUM, YOU
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IT IS.
I THINK YOU ARE FORTUNATE THE
WAY THAT WE HAVE LEANED INTO
THESE ACRONYMS AND SUCH,
EVERYONE IS WELL AWARE OF WHAT
THAT MEANS.
>> THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO
STILL HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT
MEANS, BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
IT BECAUSE LUCKILY IT IS AN
APPROPRIATE ACRONYM.
ADNAN: LET'S DIVE INTO YOUR
FANDOM FOR THE PHILLIES.
ROY HALLADAY.
BEING FROM TORONTO, I LOVED
WATCHING ROY HALLADAY FOR MANY
YEARS.
IT FELT LIKE IT WAS A DIFFERENT
AUDIENCE WHO GOT TO APPRECIATE
HOW GREAT DOC WAS.
A NO-HITTER, YOU GOT TO MEET HIM
AFTER THE GAME?
>> IT WAS SUCH A SURREAL GAME
FOR SURE.
WE ACTUALLY WERE SITTING IN
RIGHT FIELD 200 LEVEL RIGHT
ABOVE THE SIGNS.
I REMEMBER WHAT WAS CRAZY IS
THAT I HAD A FOOTBALL GAME THAT
DAY AND IT GOT CANCELED, SO WE
GOT TO STICK AROUND AND SEE THAT
MOMENT, BUT THE BEST MOMENT OF
THE GAME WAS THAT SWINGING BUNT
FROM BRANDON PHILLIPS.
YOU COULD HAVE HEARD A PIN DROP
DURING THAT AT BAT WHEN THE BALL
WAS PUT IN PLAY.
THEN THE WHOLE PLACE JUST
ERUPTED.
I GOT TO MEET HIM AFTER THE
GAME.
BACK WHEN I WAS IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
MY DAD AND I USED TO STAY AFTER
AND TRY TO GET AUTOGRAPHS AFTER
THE GAME.
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET TO
MEET HIM AND GET HIM TO SIGN A
WARM UP BALL HE TOSSED ME IN THE
BULLPEN BEFORE HEADING OUT
THERE.
WE ACTUALLY ENDED UP STAYING
THERE PROBABLY I THINK WE GOT
HOME AROUND 1:00 A.M. THAT
NIGHT.
ADNAN: AMAZING STORY.
DOC AND INTENSE GUY, BUT CLEARLY
A GREAT PLAYER AND I'M GLAD YOU
GOT TO HAVE THAT MOMENT WITH
HIM.
WHEN DID YOU FIRST BECOME A
DIEHARD PHILLIES FAN?
>> I WENT TO MY FIRST GAME IN
2006.
I CAN'T QUITE REMEMBER WHO THE
TEAM WAS THEY TOOK ON.
I REMEMBER I WAS NEVER REALLY A
SPORTS GUY UP UNTIL I WENT TO MY
FIRST BASEBALL GAME AND THEN I
FELL IN LOVE WITH THE GAME,
STARTED LIKING HOCKEY AND
FOOTBALL, BUT NOTHING IS GOING
TO TOP BASEBALL FOR SURE.
I HAVE BEEN GOING TO BASEBALL
GAMES EVER SINCE.
ADNAN: WHAT WAS IT THAT YOU
THINK ENTRANCED YOU SO MUCH?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT IS JUST COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
APART FROM EVERY OTHER SPORT OUT
THERE.
AT LEAST THE BIG FOUR JUST SEEMS
TO BE GOING BACK AND FORTH, BUT
BASEBALL IS SUCH A DIFFERENT
BALLGAME.
IN MY OPINION, IT TAKES A LOT
MORE SKILL AND THERE ARE SO MANY
MORE SKILLS THAT YOU NEED TO
HAVE TO PLAY THE GAME.
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT SHOOTING A
POCK OR BEING ABLE TO STOP A
PUCK OR THROW A BALL OR CATCH A
BALL.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO THROW,
CATCH, HIT A BALL, PITCH.
ADNAN: THAT IS WELL SAID.
, B NETWORK THE SHOW IS FOR THE
THINKING FAN, IT IS THE SPORT
FOR THE THINKING FAN.
WHAT ARE YOUR IMPRESSIONS OF THE
PHILLIES SO FAR?
>> INCONSISTENT TO PUT IT INTO
ONE TERM.
THAT WHOLE DIVISION IS ACTUALLY
FUNNY BECAUSE THEY SHOULD START
CALLING IT WHAT THEY WERE
CALLING THE NFC EAST LAST YEAR
FOR FOOTBALL.
THE N.L. EAST.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE MOST
HYPED DIVISION THIS YEAR AND IT
HAS BEEN KIND OF DISAPPOINTING,
SO I DON'T KNOW WHO IS GOING TO
END UP ON TOP.
I THINK IT IS A TOSSUP.
I DON'T KNOW SO MUCH ABOUT THE
MARLINS, BUT I THINK ALL FIVE
COULD STILL POSSIBLY GET IT.
IT IS STILL EARLY IN THE SEASON,
BUT DEFINITELY A TOSSUP.
ADNAN: YOUR PERCEPTION IS
ACCURATE.
I FELT THE SAME WAY.
IT HAS BEEN A LOT OF MEDIOCRITY.
THAT SEEMS TO BE LEAGUE WIDE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
HITTERS AT THE PLATE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF BATTERS
HITTING .230 THIS SEASON?
>> IT IS WEIRD, BUT ANOTHER ODD
THING ABOUT BATTING AVERAGES, I
FEEL LIKE IT IS BECOMING A
PRETTY OBSOLETE STAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE TALKING
O.P.S. RIGHT NOW.
I'M OLD-SCHOOL, I'M NOT A BIG
FAN OF THAT.
I STILL JUDGE A BETTER WAY MORE
BASED ON HIS BATTING AVERAGE
THEN O.P.S.
I'M MORE OF AN OLD-SCHOOL GUY.
BUT YEAH, I DEFINITELY DON'T
LIKE SEEING GUYS HITTING LOWER,
ESPECIALLY IF THEY ARE NOT
PUTTING A LOT OF BALLS OVER THE
FENCE.
Q WHEN A GUY IS HITTING .235
RIGHT NOW ABOVE AVERAGE, THAT
DOES NOT FEEL RIGHT.
>> YOU BETTER BE HITTING AT
LEAST 40 DINGERS.
ADNAN: EXACTLY.
LET'S GET TO YOUR YOUTUBE PAGE.
YOU ARE A GUY WHO CARES A LOT
ABOUT BEING ACTIVE WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA.
WHAT WAS ALL THE EFFORT YOU PUT
INTO PUTTING TOGETHER YOUR
YOUTUBE PAGE?
>> I PROBABLY STARTED MY CHANNEL
BACK WHEN I WAS 15, 16.
I STARTED MAKING IT.
I MADE PRETTY AMATEUR VIDEOS,
CHEAP RECORDING SOFTWARE I HAD.
THEN I GOT SERIOUS WITH IT FOR
THE END OF 2015, I STARTED DOING
NHL, THEN I STARTED DOING MLB.
THAT HAS BEEN BY FAR TO RECORD.
I STARTED DOING THE L.A.
UPLOADS, STREAMING ALMOST EVERY
DAY.
I HAVE A LOT OF FUN WITH IT.
ADNAN: I'VE NOTICED WITH MLB THE
SHOW, YOU LIKE TO CREATE YOUR
OWN CHARACTER.
DORSAL FINN IS YOUR GUY.
WHO DO YOU MODEL YOUR GAME
AFTER?
>> I REALLY JUST LIKE TO DO MY
OWN THING.
THERE IS NOT REALLY ANYONE I TRY
TO BE LIKE.
I TRIED TO BE THE BEST AT THAT
POSITION OR THE BEST IN THE
LEAGUE.
THIS YEAR, I'M DOING A TWO-WAY
PLAYER, SO THAT IS A NEWER
FEATURE IN THE GAME.
I TRIED TO BE THE BEST PITCHER
AND THE BEST HITTER OUT OF
EVERYONE IN THE LEAGUE.
ADNAN: LAST ONE, ANYONE CALL YOU
HUCK
/ANYONE THINK HUCKLEBERRY FINN?
>> I PROBABLY GET EVERYTHING
OTHER THAN FINN.
FINNEGAN, DORSAL, FINLEY.
ADNAN: WHEN WE TALK AGAIN, I'M
CALLING YOU HUCK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
APPRECIATE IT.
ADNAN: GREAT STUFF FROM MY MAN
HUCK FINN.
CORBIN BURNES HAS BEEN LIGHTS
OUT, LEADS THE MAJORS WITH A TH-
WHIFF RATE THIS SEASON.
WHEN WE COME BACK, WE WILL PUT
DERO ON THE SPOT.
♪
>> YANKS SIT DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD
LINE.
WILL IT STAY FAIR?
IT IS HOOKING AND IT IS CAUGHT
UP AGAINST THE WALL!
WHAT I CATCH!
WHAT A CATCH!
JUSTIN WILLIAMS.
HE SMOKES IT.
1-0, CARDINALS.
HE ALMOST BROKE THE SIGN IN LEFT
FIELD.
YOU COULD HEAR THAT UP HERE.
>> THIS IS GOING TO GO FROM
QUESTIONABLE FOUL BALL TO
SOUVENIR.
>> ARENADO.
WAY BACK.
AT THE WALL.
MY MAN CALLED IT.
HE CALLED IT AND WE ARE TIED.
NOLAN HAS TIED IT UP 5-5.
>> GOOD TIME FOR A HOMER.
>> ARE YOU CALLING IT?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT.
>> WHY NOT?
OK.
>> GOLDSCHMIDT WITH A HOME RUN.
LONG ONE INTO LEFT.
TWO RUN HOMER.
>> SAYS IT!
>> SWING AND A HIGH FLY BALL
INTO DEEP LEFT FIELD.
FLAHERTY HAS JUST HIT A HOME
RUN!
THIS FIRST MAJOR LEAGUE HOME
RUN.
ADNAN: ALL RIGHT, GETTING SET
FOR THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
PREGAME SHOW.
JACK FLAHERTY GET SET TO TAKE ON
CORBIN BURNES.
ALL RIGHT , GETTING SET FOR
SOMEPICS TO CLICK.
ADNAN VIRK ALONGSIDE MARK
DEROSA.
WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT JACK
FLAHERTY.
TIME FOR PICKS TO CLICK.
THE QUESTION BECOMES THIS, WHEN
YOU THINK OF A CY YOUNG FAVORITE
THIS YEAR, WHO IS YOUR FAVORITE
TO WIN THE CY YOUNG?
CLARITY IS IN THE CONVERSATION.
IS HE THE GUY FOR YOU? MARK: IT
IS GERRIT COLE AFTER WATCHING
HIM LAST NIGHT.
IT IS JACOB DEGROM AS LONG AS HE
IS HEALTHY, BUT WHAT JACK
FLAHERTY HAS DONE, HE CANNOT BE
DENIED.
CORBIN BURNES ,+450 ON THE ODDS.
ADNAN: I LIKE BRANDON WOODRUFF.
MARK: I LIKE THAT AS WELL.
WALKER BUEHLER.
+2000.
I LIKE THE MONEY ON FLAHERTY.
ADNAN: I LIKE WHERE YOUR HEAD IS
THAT.
THOSE ARE YOUR ODDS.
DEGROM HEAVY FAVORITE.
, BAUER BURNES, BAUER.
WHO IS YOUR FAVORITE TO WIN THE
N.L. PENNANT?
THE DODGERS FELL APART.
MARK: I HATE PREDICTIONS.
ADNAN: I THINK BECAUSE ON
CENTRAL THEY WILL BRING IT BACK.
MARK: THEN AFTER EXPLORATORY
SURGERY, I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BRAVES.
I TELL YOU WHO IS JUMPING OUT AT
ME AND I KNOW THEY ARE HOT RIGHT
NOW, THE NEW YORK METS.
ADNAN: THE METROPOLITANS.
MARK: AS LONG AS JACOB DEGROM
COMES BACK, THEY HAVE EVERY
WEAPON TO GET IT DONE AND BE THE
TEAM NO ONE IS GOING TO WANT TO
PLAY.
IT IS STILL EARLY.
ADNAN: THE KING OF THE WALK-OFF
FIELDER'S CHOICE.
[LAUGHTER]
TAIJUAN WALKER, GREAT SIGNING.
TWO YEARS, $20 MILLION.
HE HAS BEEN GREAT.
STROMAN, AS WELL.
HOW ABOUT OVER-UNDER, TOTAL RUNS
SCORED IN TODAY'S GAME?
MINUS 6.5.
MARK: IT SCREAMS THAT IT SHOULD
BE 3-2 BALLGAME.
ADNAN: IT IS NEVER THAT.
MARK: PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT IS GOING
TO THE SLIDE AT SOME POINT IN
THIS GAME ON A TWO-SEAMER.
MILLER PARK -- NOW AMERICAN
FAMILY FIELD IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST BALLPARKS TO HIT IN
FROM AN OFFENSIVE PLAYER.
I KNOW IT IS A DAY GAME, AS LONG
AS THEY'VE GOT THE PANELS OPEN
AND THE CHANNELS DON'T GET TO
SKEWY, YOU WILL SEE SOMETHING GO
OUT OF THIS YARD.
ADNAN: INTERESTING HOW THE PARK
PLAYS.
WHERE DID YOU ALWAYS HIT WELL?
DODGER STADIUM? MARK: I LOVE TO
MINUTE MAID.
THE N.L. CENTRAL HAS SOME BAM
BOXES AND IT.
CINCINNATI.
MILLER -- AMERICAN FAMILY FIELD.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BETTER ONES.
ADNAN: WHENEVER IT FEELS A
CERTAIN WAY, GO THE OTHER WAY.
MARK: THEY LOVED PLAYING
COLORADO.
I HAD TROUBLE BREATHING AT
ALTITUDE.
I HAD A JAMMER IN 2008, ALMOST
DID NOT MAKE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
ADNAN: THAT ALTITUDE WILL GET
YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK: TURBULENCE GOING INTO THAT
PLACE IS A NIGHTMARE.
ADNAN: NOT GREAT.
WHO IS GOING TO WIN TODAY'S
GAME?
CARDINALS, 63%.
ONE THING ABOUT THAT FAN BASE,
THEY ARE ACTIVE.
MARK: WHEN I LOOK AT THE N.L.
CENTRAL, WHO DO YOU TRUST?
I TRUST THE NAMES ON THE ROSTER
OF THE ST. LOUIS CARDINALS.
MAYBE NOT TODAY, I GO BREW CREW
FOR THE STEAL TODAY WITH BURNES
ON THE MOUND, BUT I THINK WHEN
THE DUST SETTLES, ST. LOUIS WILL
WIN THE DIVISION.
ADNAN: GOLDSCHMIDT, ALL-TIME
O.P.S. THAT AMERICAN FAMILY
FIELD.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
LINEUPS.
LET'S SEE HOW IT IS LOOKING.
REALLY TOP-HEAVY FOR THE
CARDINALS.
THE BREWERS, KOLTEN WONG IS ONLY
2-11 HIS FIRST THREE GAMES
AGAINST HIS FORMER TEAM.
THEY'VE GOT TO GET YELICH BACK.
MARK: THAT SCARES ME.
THE BACK IS ALWAYS A TRICKY
THING.
THEY'VE GOT TO GET THE 40 HOMER
VERSION OF CHRISTIAN YELICH
BACK.
ADNAN: SPEAKING OF,
THIS --
THAT IS A GOOD SIGN.
MARK: THAT IS A GOOD SIGN.
THE FACT THAT HE CAME BACK ONE
DAY, IT SCARED THE HECK OUT OF
ME.
THE SITUATION WITH MIKE SOROKA.
FOR HIM TO WALK IN AND SAY
SOMETHING IS NOT RIGHT,
SOMETHING IS NOT RIGHT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
INJURY AND A PAIN THAT YOU CAN
MAYBE WORK THROUGH.
ADNAN: BUT THAT DIVISION ALWAYS
FEELS LIKE THREE GAMES SEPARATE
FOUR TEAMS.
MARK: IN CINCINNATI SEEMS TO BE
SITTING AT .500 AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY CAN'T FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO REALLY GO.
THEY ARE CERTAINLY TALENTED AND
CAN MASH.
I KEEP COMING BACK TO ST. LOUIS
BECAUSE I TRUST THEIR LINEUP.
I THINK TOMMY EDMAN AT THE TOP,
DYLAN CARLSON IS THE PROSPECT
EVERYONE IS WAITING TO JUST
EXPLODE.
ADNAN: 4.5 GAMES SEPARATING THE
TOP TEAMS.
WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT CARDINAL
NATION, IT RUBS THEM THE WRONG
WAY, BEST FANS IN THE GAME.
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKE?
MARK: JUST RESPECTED THE
BALLGAME.
RESPECTED GUYS WHO HUSTLED AND
PLAYED HARD AND PLAYED THE GAME
FUNDAMENTALLY SOUND THE RIGHT
WAY.
LISTEN, I SAY THIS ALL THE TIME.
IT IS JUST A GLORIFIED LITTLE
LEAGUE.
[LAUGHTER]
WE STILL KNOW WHO THE BEST
PLAYERS ARE.
ALBERT PUJOLS IN 2009, I WANT
HIM TO GO BIG MAC LAND.
LET US FILL IN THE CRACKS AND DO
THE HIT AND RUNS.
THE GAME HAS CHANGED AND GUYS
HAVE LOST THEIR WAY A LITTLE BIT
WITH THE SHIFT.
ADNAN: MATT HOLLIDAY IS ON THE
CALL TODAY.
PLESAC AND SCOTT BRAUN AND
HOLIDAY.
I WANT TO SAVE THE BEST FOR
LAST.
YOUR BOY RO FLO NOW HAS MURCH.
MARK: THAT'S A PROBLEM.
IT IS GETTING AWAY FROM HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
HE PROBABLY GOT 100% COTTON,
THEY SHRINK, NEXT THING YOU KNOW
THEY ARE IN A GARAGE.
ADNAN: LIKE THE QUALITY OF THE
SHIRTS.
WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE?
YOU PLAYED.
YOU DON'T HAVE IT.
MARK: I HAVE AN 11-YEAR-OLD SON
THAT DOES TWO THINGS.
HE PLAYS BASEBALL AND VIDEO
GAMES AND THAT IS WHAT HE LOVES
TO DO.
AND RO FLO --
ADNAN: IS HIS HERO.
MARK: SOMETIMES I WONDER IF THEY
ARE IN CAHOOTS UNTIL 2:00 IN THE
MORNING STREAMING OR SOMETHING.
[LAUGHTER]
ADNAN: DERO HAS A JERSEY ON THE
BACK.
RO FLO HAS HIS NAME ON THE
FRONT.
SHEHADI HERE NEXT.
THANKS TO MARK DEROSA CHIPPING
IN HERE.
>> HERE IS THE PITCH.
>> DRIVES THAT.
>> WHAT A PLAY.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> OH MY!
>> ONE OF THE PRIME PITCHING
MATCHUPS IN ALL OF BASEBALL IS
GOING DOWN IN THE MIDWEST TODAY.
TWO FLAMETHROWERS WITH A DAYTIME
DUEL IN BRUISE CITY -- BREW
CITY.
THE ENTIRE PLANET HAS EYES ON
THE N.L. CENTRAL.
THIS IS THE GAME OF THE WEEK,
LIVE ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY
STATE FARM IN WISCONSIN.
AND WE ARE LIVE INSIDE THE
STUDIOS TO CALL THE ACTION.
SCOTT BRAUN ALONG WITH FORMER
MILWAUKEE BREWER AND THREE TIME
ALL-STAR DAN PLESAC.
IS THERE ANYTHING LIKE DAYTIME
ACTION IN MILWAUKEE?
A LITTLE TAILGATE ACTION.
>>'S LITTLE TAILGATE, AND A
MARQUEE PITCHING AT CHUBB.
CORBIN BURNES, WHO HAS NOT
WALKED A SINGLE HITTER ALL
SEASON LONG.
SCOTT: 49 STRIKEOUTS, ZERO
WALKS.
ALL ON YOUTUBE.
OVER 20 EXCLUSIVE GAMES ON
YOUTUBE THIS SEASON.
IT IS FREE FOR EVERYONE EVERY IT
IT IS 3 MILLION SUBSCRIBERS ON
MLB'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL WATCHING
EVERY DAY.
WE WILL REMIND YOU ABOUT
UPCOMING GAMES.
YOUTUBE TV CUSTOMERS ARE HOOKED
UP WITH AN MLB POP UP WITHIN THE
CHANNEL GUIDE.
LOOK WHO POPPED UP FOR THE
ENTIRE GAME WITH US, MATT
HOLLIDAY, THE FORMER ST. LOUIS
CARDINAL.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON BOARD.
HOW SURREAL IS THIS FOR YOU?
WE WILL TALK TO ONE OF YOUR
FORMER TEAMMATES IN ADAM
WAINWRIGHT.
>> AM GLAD TO BE HERE.
IT IS PRETTY EXCITING TO GET A
CHANCE TO WATCH SOME OF MY OLD
TEAMMATES EVEN THOUGH YADI IS
GETTING SOFT ON ME AND SAT OUT
THE ONE GAME I GET TO DO.
MAYBE WE WILL GET A CHANCE TO
TALK TO ADAM MOORE YADI AND I'M
EXCITED TO BE HERE AND SEE SOME
GOOD BASEBALL.
SCOTT: WE HAVE WANO BOOKED FOR
THIS ONE.
JACK FLAHERTY IS MATCHING UP
AGAINST CORBIN BURNES, COMING
OFF AN INJURED LIST STENT.
HE WAS COVID POSITIVE AND HE IS
BACK.
HE DOES NOT WALK ANYONE.
DAN: IT HAS BEEN AMAZING THE
TRANSFORMATION OF CORBIN BURNES.
BOUNCED AROUND FROM THE ROTATION
TO THE BULLPEN.
LOOK AT THAT GRAPHIC RIGHT
THERE.
E.R.A. OF 1.53, 29.1 INNINGS.
HE HAS YET TO WALK A HITTER, HE
HAS PUNCHED OUT 49.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT ONE
PITCH COULD TURN IT GUYS CAME
AROUND AND THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS
WITH CORBIN BURNES.
THE CUTTER.
IT IS A NASTY PITCH.
HIGH BELOW.
96-98 AISLES PER HOUR -- MILES
PER HOUR.
HE WILL THROW IT FRONT DOOR,
BACKDOOR.
YOU CAN'T SIT ON ONE PITCH FOR
THIS GUY.
THIS CUTTER RIGHT NOW MIGHT BE
THE MOST DOMINANT PITCH IN
BASEBALL.
SCOTT: WHAT HE DID WAS
COMPLETELY REVAMPED HIS
REPERTOIRE.
THIS WAS A FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL IN
2019.
A VERY DOWN YEAR FOR HIM.
COMPLETELY CHANGED EVERYTHING.
NOW USING THE CUTTER MORE THAN
EVER.
ALSO IN OF THE OTHER END OF THE
PITCHING PAIRING YOU HAVE JACK
FLAHERTY, WHO ASIDE FROM ONE
CLUNKER ON OPENING DAY, HAS BEEN
FANTASTIC.
WHAT IS THE SCOUTING REPORT?
MATT: I THINK JACK FLAHERTY IS A
GUY THAT LOCATES HIS FASTBALL
DOWN AND AWAY TO RIGHTIES VERY
WELL.
HE TUNNELS THE FASTBALL DOWN AND
AWAY WITH HIS SLIDER THAT LOOKS
THE SAME AND DIES OFF THE
OUTSIDE OWNER.
YOU LOOK AT HIS FASTBALL, 92 UP
TO 97.
HE KIND OF USES IT WITH TWO
DIFFERENT PITCHES WHERE HE CAN
THROW THE 92 TO GET AHEAD IN THE
COUNT AND THEN REACH BACK AND
GET THE 97 LATE IN THE COUNT.
IT IS THE CONVICTION WITH WHICH
HE THROWS THE FASTBALL.
IT IS NOT A HUGE SPIN RATE.
IT KIND OF SURPRISES ME WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE AVERAGE AGAINST THE
FASTBALL LIKE THAT.
HE HAS CONVICTION IN HIS PITCHES
AND HE IS A GOOD COMPETITOR.
SCOTT: YOU CAN SEE APRIL 1
AGAINST THE REDS.
SINCE THEN, HE IS ELITE.
MATT: YOU TALK ABOUT THAT FIRST
GAME AND LIKE YOU SAID IT WAS A
LITTLE BIT OF A CLUNKER, BUT
SINCE THEN HAS FASTBALL VELOCITY
HAS TICKED UP.
HE IS A TWO PITCH PITCHER,
MOSTLY FASTBALL-SLIDER.
HE HAS BEEN DROPPING IN SOME
CURVEBALLS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CONVICTION
WITH WHICH HE THROWS THE
FASTBALL AND THE COMPETITOR THAT
HE IS IS KIND OF WHAT SETS THEM
APART AND MAKE SOME A TOP OF THE
ROTATION GUY.
SCOTT: IF THERE IS A GROUND
BALL, HE IS PROBABLY IN GOOD
SHAPE AT THE HOT CORNER WITH
NOLAN ARENADO AND HE CAN SWING
THE BAT A LITTLE BIT.
YOU HAVE A SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH HIM.
WHAT IS HE LIKE?
MATT: HE IS ALL AROUND ONE OF
THE BEST PLAYERS IN THE LEAGUE.
YOU TALK ABOUT HIS DEFENSE.
I KNEW HE WAS GREAT DEFENSE, BUT
IN 2018 WHEN I GOT A CHANCE TO
PLAY WITH HIM FOR ABOUT SIX
WEEKS, IT ALMOST SEEMED LIKE
EVERY DAY HE WAS MAKING SOME
SORT OF GOLD GLOVE PLAY.
WATCHING HIM DO HIS WORK BEFORE
THE GAME IS WHAT THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE THING TO ME WAS AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY HIS HITTING.
HE IS A 35 HOME RUN, 100 R.B.I.
GUY.
I THINK THE ONE THING THAT SETS
HIM APART IS HIS TENACITY.
HE PLAYS EVERY DAY.
HE WANTS TO BE IN THERE.
HE PLAYS WITH HIGH EMOTION.
HE IS A VERY TOUGH COMPETITOR.
SCOTT: AND A GUY THAT YOU JUST
FIGURE, THE ST. LOUIS CROWD WILL
GRAVITATE TOWARD, THEY LOVE TO
WATCH HIM.
ON THE OTHER SIDE WITH PAUL
GOLDSCHMIDT AT FIRST BASE, IT IS
A SPECIAL GROUP IN ST. LOUIS.
OVER IN MILWAUKEE IS J.P. MOROSI
, THE FOURTH MEMBER OF OUR TEAM.
VERY LUCKY GUY, VERY PUMPED FOR
THE MATCHUP.
J.P.: THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON FROM AMERICAN FAMILY
FIELD.
OUR BROADCAST LOCATION, A
GORGEOUS AFTERNOON HERE IN
MILWAUKEE.
JUST BESIDE US, CORBIN BURNES
GOING THROUGH HIS FIRST WARM-UP
ROUTINE FOR A START IN A LITTLE
MORE THAN TWO WEEKS AND ALL THE
EYES IN WISCONSIN THROUGHOUT THE
N.L. CENTRAL THE MLB WORLD
WONDERING, DOES HIS COMMAND
RETURN AS IT WAS TO BEGIN THE
SEASON?
AN INCREDIBLE START HE HAS BEEN
ON, NOT ISSUING A SINGLE WALK SO
FAR.
DURING THAT PLAYOFFS, HE WAS
ABLE TO KEEP THROWING.
WE WILL SEE IF THE CUTTER
COMMAND REMAINS INTACT THAT HAS
ALREADY SEEN HIM BE THE STARTING
PITCHING LEADER IN TERMS OF MOST
INNINGS PITCHED AND MOST
STRIKEOUTS WITHOUT HAVING ISSUED
A WALK.
JUST TO BEHIND KENLEY JANSEN OF
THE DODGERS FOR THE ALL-TIME
RECORD IN THAT CATEGORY.
A BLUSTERY AND HE HAD DAY IN
MILWAUKEE.
PITCH IS NEXT
ON YOUTUBE.
♪
>> THIS IS GOING TO GO FROM
QUESTIONABLE FOUL BALL TO
SOUVENIR.
>> WAY BACK.
AT THE WALL.
MY MAN CALLED IT.
HE CALLED IT AND WE ARE TIED.
NOLAN HAS TIED IT UP.
>> 0-1.
BASE HIT INTO CENTER.
2-0, CARDINALS.
A TWO-OUT RALLY FOR ST. LOUIS.
ARENADO SENDS IT DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
IT IS DOWN.
A GROUND RULE DOUBLE FULL MOON
-- FOUR FOUR NOLAN ARENADO.
>> WHAT A QUICK REACTION BY
NOLAN ARENADO.
HIT HARD TOWARD THIRD.
PICKED ON ONE HOP BY ARENADO AND
HE THROWS OUT HIS GOOD FRIEND,
TREVOR STORY.
ARENADO OUT TO DEEP LEFT FIELD.
HIS FIRST HOME RUN AGAINST HIS
FORMER TEAM.
LAUNCHED IT INTO THE BULLPEN.
YOU KNOW HE IS LOVING IT.
>> SIX HOME RUNS, 23 R.B.I., AND
A SEVEN-GAME HITTING STREAK.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
WE TAKE YOU TO AMERICAN FAMILY
FIELD AS THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS
HOST THE ST. LOUIS CARDINALS.
THE LEAD WIDE OPEN.
-- LID WIDE OPEN.
THIS IS THE LINEUP THAT CORBIN
BURNES WILL FACE PRESENTED BY
STATE FARM.
THE STARTING NINE FOR MIKE
SHILDT.
.
DYLAN CARLSON IN RIGHT FIELD.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT TERRORIZING
MILWAUKEE PITCHING, ESPECIALLY
IN THIS BALLPARK.
BADER IN CENTER.
KNIZNER IS GOING TO CATCH.
>> THERE HE IS, THE MAN OF THE
HOUR.
29.1 INNINGS.
NO WALKS, 49 STRIKEOUTS.
THAT IS ABOUT AS GOOD AS IT GETS
STRIKEOUT TO WALK RATIO.
THE CUTTER IS HIS MAIN WEAPON.
SCOTT: THE BIGGEST QUESTION WILL
BE, ANY REST COMING OFF ABOUT 8
-- RUST COMING OFF ABOUT A TWO
WEEK LAY OFF?
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVID-19.
HE SAID IT WAS ASYMPTOMATIC.
WORKING OUT AT HOME TO STAY IN
SHAPE.
HE DELIVERS THE FIRST PITCH ON
THE CORNER FOR A STRIKE TO TOMMY
EDMAN TO START THE DAY ON
YOUTUBE.
DAN: THAT IS THE CUTTER.
96 MILES PER HOUR.
HE THROWS THAT CUTTER TO BOTH
SIDES OF THE PLATE.
HE CAN THROW IT AWAY TO A LEFTY
AND DOWN AND IN TO A LEFTY LIKE
THAT ONE RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: HOW DO YOU GAME PLAN
AGAINST CORBIN BURNES?
MATT: THE ONE THING THAT IS
PUZZLING IS TYPICALLY IT IS A
ONE SIDE OF THE PLATE PITCH.
HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO PITCH IT TO
BOTH SIDES.
THE TOUGH PART IS THAT HE WILL
HIP SHOT THE RIGHT-HANDED HITTER
AND YOU CAN'T JUST LOOK OUT OVER
THE PLATE.
FOR ME, YOU'VE GOT TO LOOK ONE
SIDE OR THE OTHER.
YOU CAN'T JUST CHASE HIM.
SCOTT: HE IS AHEAD 0-2 TO
EDMUND.
RIGHT SIDE, IT GETS THROUGH AND
THE CARDINALS HAVE A LEADOFF
HITTER.
EDMUND IS THE BOARD AND IT IS
TIME FOR OUR STATE FARM PITCHING
BREAKDOWN.
WHAT MORE IS THERE TO SAY ABOUT
CORBIN BURNES SO FAR THIS YEAR?
DAN: ONE OF THE KEYS IS IS HE
GOING TO BE RUSTY ABOUT MISSING
2.5 WEEKS OF ACTION?
HE WAS IN SUCH A GOOD GROOVE.
THE CARDINALS MAY BE IN
BUSINESS.
THE CUTTER IS HIS BEST PITCH.
HE WENT FROM A TERRIBLE PITCHER
TO A GOOD PITCHER AND COMMAND.
IF HE IS COMMANDING ALL THREE
PITCHES, HE IS GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT TO GET MULTIPLE HITS
IN IN ANY INNING.
SCOTT: HE FACED ST. LOUIS ON
APRIL 8, EIGHT SHUTOUT INNINGS.
HE FINDS THE ZONE AGAINST DYLAN
CARLSON.
DAN: SO FAR, SO GOOD.
FOUR PITCHES AND FOR STRIKES
OUT OF THE GET GO.
MATT: I THINK HE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO USE HIS SINKER, TOO.
HE IS GOING TO TRY TO NEED TO
MAKE THE BALL GO AGAINST THESE
HITTERS.
MAKE THEM RESPECT THAT HE IS
GOING TO THROW SOMETHING BESIDE
THE CUTTER.
SCOTT: CARLSON HAS HAD BIG
NUMBERS IN THE FIRST INNING.
EDMUND IS ON THE MOVE.
THE THROW TO SECOND IS LATE.
A STOLEN BAG FOR TOMMY EDMAN,
HIS SECOND OF THE SERIES.
HE SWIPED ONE IN GAME ONE OF THE
THREE-GAME SET.
NUMBER SIX ON THE SEASON.
DAN: THAT IS A REALLY GOOD JUMP.
NO SHOT TO THROW HIM OUT.
WE PRETTY GOOD WALKING LEAD FROM
TOMMY EDMAN.
SCOTT: ALREADY A RUNNER IN
SCORING POSITION.
MATT: THIS IS A GOOD APPROACH
AGAINST A REALLY GOOD PITCHER IS
YOU GET A GUY ON EARLY, NO USE
ELEVATE, NOW WHAT MAKES
CARLSON'S JOB EASY AND YOU HAVE
A CHANCE TO SCORE EARLY WITH A
SAC FLY.
YOU GIVE A CHANCE TO SCORE OFF A
GUY LIKE BURNS EARLY, YOU FEEL A
LOT BETTER GOING OUT THERE WITH
THE LEAD AGAINST CORBIN BURNES.
SCOTT: WE HAVE NOT SEEN MUCH
SCORING IN THE FIRST TWO GAMES
OF THIS SERIES.
EXCELLENT STARTING PITCHING
EARLY ON.
BRANDON WOODRUFF AND FREDDY
PERALTA, EXCELLENT FOR
MILWAUKEE.
WE WILL TALK TO WOODRUFF A
COUPLE INNINGS FROM NOW.
AFTER THE FIRST INNING
CONCLUDES, ADAM WAINWRIGHT WILL
JOIN US.
MATT: NASTY CUTTER.
SCOTT: 42% WHIFF RATE FOR CORBIN
BURNES THIS SEASON, BEST IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
GOOD, OLD-FASHIONED SWING AND
MISS HE IS ABLE TO PRODUCE.
TWO STRIKES ON CARLSON.
BURNES WAS A SIXTH PLACE
FINISHER LAST YEAR FOR THE N.L.
CY YOUNG AWARD.
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE RATED HIGHER
AS CARLSON DOES NOT BITE.
CARLSON FACING A 3-2 COUNT.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD
SHOWS US HOW CORBIN BURNES LIKES
TO HANDLE HIS BUSINESS WITH
THREE BALL COUNTS.
CUTTERS AND HE STAYS IN THE
ZONE.
DAN: THAT SHOWS YOU HOW MUCH
CONFIDENCE HE HAS IN THAT PITCH.
BACK TO 2019, HE WAS BASICALLY A
FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL GUY UP IN THE
ZONE.
HE IS NOT AFRAID TO GO TO THAT
CUTTER 3-2.
SCOTT: AND CARLSON CHASES.
IT IS THE FIRST OUT OF THE DAY.
DAN: THE STREAK IS ALIVE.
HE HAS YET TO WALK A HITTER.
CARLSON MIGHT HAVE SWUNG AT BALL
FOR.
IT LOOKS LIKE A FASTBALL ALL THE
WAY.
THE BOTTOM JUST FALLS OFF THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
SCOTT: THAT IS STRIKEOUT NUMBER
50.
MATT: IT IS CRAZY, AS MUCH AS HE
USES HIS CUTTER, IT IS ALMOST
LIKE MARIANO RIVERA, HE IS
PITCHING BASICALLY WITH ONE
PITCH.
IT IS PRETTY AMAZING THAT YOU
KNOW HE IS GOING TO THROW IT,
BUT YOU STILL CAN'T HIT IT.
SCOTT: IT IS LIKE A CLOSER BUT
HE IS PITCHING ALL GAME LONG.
AND GOING UP AGAINST PAUL
GOLDSCHMIDT, NUMBER THREE HITTER
FOR ST. LOUIS.
ONE OUT AND ADMIN ON SECOND
--EDMAN ON SECOND.
WE WILL SEE SOME OF THOSE SWINGS
TODAY.
DAN: YOU KNOW AS A HITTER THAT
THERE IS A PRETTY GOOD CHANCE
YOU ARE GOING TO GET ONE OF
THOSE CUTTERS, BUT HE WILL THROW
IT UP IN THE ZONE.
THEN HE WILL BURY THAT ONE DOWN
AND IN LIKE HE DID ON THE
THREE-TO PITCH.
SCOTT: GOLDSCHMIDT MAKES CONTACT
.
THAT IS SHORT FOR URIAS.
VOGELBACH WILL SLAP THE TAG ON.
EDMAN MOVES TO THIRD.
YOUR STATE FARM DEFENSIVE
ALIGNMENT FOR THE BREWERS.
THEY PRIDE THEMSELVES ON THEIR
DEFENSE.
VOGELBACH MADE A BIG DEFENSE.
URIAS MADE THAT PLAY.
NARVAEZ IS BACK TODAY TO PLAY
CATCHER.
IN THE OUTFIELD, BRADLEY, AND
CAIN, GARCIA.
YELICH IS ON THE COMEBACK TRAIL.
HE WILL BEGIN A REHAB OUTING
THIS WEEKEND IN NASHVILLE TO GET
SOME AT-BATS.
MATT: THAT LAST PITCH TO
GOLDSCHMIDT WAS THE TWO-SEAMER
INSIDE AND THAT IS THE LIES ARE
WHERE HE KEEPS GUYS OFF THE
CUTTER A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: ARENADO GETS ONE PAST
SHORT AND THAT IS GOING TO BREAK
THE ICE FOR THE CARDINALS.
NOLAN ARENADO MAKES IT 1-0 AS
EDMUND SCORES --EDMAN SCORES.
MATT: CUTTER OUT OVER.
NICE SWING.
LINED IT THROUGH THE LEFT SIDE.
DAN: YOU GET A GOOD LOOK AT THE
VALUE OF THAT STOLEN BASE FROM
TOMMY EDMAN.
ABLE TO GET OVER TO THIRD AND
NOLAN ARENADO TAKES HIS CUTTER,
INTENDED TO BE AWAY, KIND OF
STAYS ON THE INNER HALF.
DRIVES IT RIGHT BETWEEN THE
WHOLE BETWEEN SHORT AND THIRD.
MATT: GOING BACK TO GETTING
AFTER THIS GUY EARLY IN THE
COUNT.
HE DOES NOT THROW A LOT OF
BALLS, HE PITCHES ON THE PLATE.
THERE IT IS AGGRESSIVE EARLY IN
THE COUNT AND TRY TO GET A RUN
HOME RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: JUST A COUPLE GROUND
BALLS PAST AGAIN FIELD.
TWO HITS, ONE RUN.
HERE COMES MATT CARPENTER.
3-11 WITH A COUPLE HOMERS IN HIS
CAREER AGAINST THE STARTER FROM
MILWAUKEE.
MATT: IT WAS INTERESTING, I
THINK HE WENT FIRST PITCH
CHANGEUP TO MATT CARPENTER.
HE KNOWS HE'S GOING TO BE
AGGRESSIVE EARLY IN THE COUNT.
HE HAS JUMP HIM A COUPLE TIMES
ALREADY.
HE GOES FIRST PITCH CHANGEUP,
THAN IT LOOKS LIKE MORE OF A
SINKER RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: AND THAT ONE IS LIFTED TO
SHALLOW CENTER.
CAIN RACING IN.
GOING TO BE A TOUGH PLAY AND IT
DROPS.
ARENADO IS GOING TO ROUND THIRD.
THE THROW IS IN TIME!
ARENADO, NARVAEZ SLAPS ON THE
TAG AT HOME.
THAT WILL END THE FRAME.
LORENZO CAIN, ALL AROUND
COMPLETE PLAYER.
CRAIG COUNSELL TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPACT HE MAKES ON A DAILY
BASIS.
SAVES THE RUN.
THEY WANTEDRENADO TO STICK
AROUND AT THIRD.
HE GOES AGGRESSIVE, THE BREWERS
PREVENT ONE RUN, BUT THE FIRST
OF THE DAY IS ON THE BOARD FOR
ST. LOUIS AND WE WILL HEAD TO
THE CARDINALS HALF OF THE FIRST.
>> A SWING AND A MISS.
STRIKES OUT.
>>.
HERE IS THE 2-2.
>> THERE IS A GOOD BREAKING BALL
DOWN ON STRIKES.
>> DEEP IN THE AIR.
AT THE TRACK.
HE HAS DONE IT AGAIN!
ADRIAN HOUSER GOES DEEP.
THE BREWERS LEAD 3-1!
>> AND A CALLED STRIKE THREE.
STRIKEOUT NUMBER FIVE FOR ADRIAN
HOUSER.
AND HE GOT HIM.
HE WENT BACK TO THE FASTBALL.
ANDERSON SLAMS HIS BAT DOWN.
CALLED STRIKE THREE.
STRIKEOUT NUMBER EIGHT.
>> NINTH STRIKEOUT.
>> PAYOFF PITCH AGAIN.
>> STRIKEOUT NUMBER 10 FOR
ADRIAN HOUSER.
>> ANDERSON ON THE FIRST PITCH.
TERRIFIC OUTING FOR ADRIAN
HOUSER.
SCOTT: 1-0, CARDINALS.
COULD HAVE BEEN TWO IF NOT FOR
URIAS BACKING UP LORENZO CAIN,
WHO DEFINITELY SOLD OUT FOR THIS
BASEBALL.
DAN: REALLY HEADS UP PLAY.
THEY REALLY LIKE THE DEFENSE AND
EDMAN REALLY JOHNNY ON THE SPOT
--URIAS REALLY JOHNNY ON THE
SPOT RIGHT THERE.
THIS IS A REALLY HEADS UP PLAY
RIGHT THERE.
GOOD BASE RUNNING BY THE
CARDINALS TO TRY TO GET THAT
SECOND RUN IN.
IT TOOK A GOOD THROW.
NOLAN ARENADO ALMOST ABLE TO
SCORE THE CARDINALS SECOND RUN.
SCOTT: THREE HITS FOR ST. LOUIS
AGAINST BURNES.
NOW JACK FLAHERTY'S TURN AGAINST
THE MILWAUKEE STARTING NINE.
JACK FLAHERTY WITH A 3.32 E.R.A.
IN HIS CAREER.
IT IS UNDER 3.00 SO FAR THIS
SEASON AND REALLY JUST ONE BAD
OUTING.
DAN: HIS FIRST OUTING OF THE
YEAR.
SINCE THEN, HE HAS GONE 6-0.
A LITTLE BIT OF A DISAPPOINTING
SEASON LAST YEAR IN THE 60 GAME
ABBREVIATED SCHEDULE.
I THINK THE STARTING AND
STOPPING REALLY HURT JACK
FLAHERTY.
IF THE CARDINALS ARE GOING WHERE
THEY WANT TO GO, THIS GUY WILL
BE DRIVING THE BUS.
A LOT OF TEAMS IN BASEBALL FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE AN ACE PITCHER,
YOU ARE LOOKING AT ONE RIGHT
HERE.
HE IS A LEGITIMATE TOP 10 IN ALL
OF BASEBALL.
SCOTT: 2-1 TWO KOLTEN WONG.
YOU HAD A PRETTY GOOD GAME PLAN,
MATT, WHAT IS THE ATTACK MODE
AGAINST FLIRTY TODAY?
MATT: I THINK FOR ME, YOU'VE GOT
TO STAY ON THE FOUR-SEAM
FASTBALL.
PROBABLY DOWN AND AWAY TO BOTH
HITTERS IS HIS HOTSPOT.
I WOULD BE SUPER AGGRESSIVE ON
THE FASTBALL.
SCOTT: HE HANDLES KOLTEN WONG.
LORENZO CAIN COMING UP.
THE STATE FARM BREWERS STARTING
NINE.
TRAVIS SHAW CLEANING UP.
AVISAIL GARCIA HITTING .469 IN
MAY.
HE HAS BEEN THEIR BEST BAT THIS
MONTH.
NARVAEZ ACTIVATED TODAY.
CORBIN BURNES IN THE NINE SPOT.
DAN: A GOOD LOOK AT JACK
FLAHERTY.
34TH PLAYER TAKEN IN THE DRAFT.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE JOHN
FLAHERTY, LUCAS GIOLITO, AND MAX
FRIED ALL ON YOUR HIGH SCHOOL
BASEBALL TEAM?
SCOTT: JACK, LUCAS, AND MAX ALL
ON THE SQUAD FOR A YEAR.
BACKING UP HIS CARLSON AND HE'S
GOT IT.
YOUR STATE FARM BREAKDOWN ON
JACK FLAHERTY.
DAN: 6-0 ON THE YEAR.
HE HAD A ROUGH ONE.
HE WILL MAINLY GO TO THE SLIDER
AS HIS SECONDARY PITCH.
THEN BE AN ACE.
THEY NEED AN ACE AND THIS WOULD
BE THEIR ACE.
HE WOULD BE A GAME ONE STARTER
FOR MOST TEAM, INCLUDING THE
CARDINALS.
SCOTT:SCOTT: THERE IS A STRIKE
TO VOGELBACH.
MATT: THE BREWERS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIND SOME OFFENSE
SOMEWHERE.
SCOTT: IT WILL GET EVEN SCARIER.
WE TALKED TO MIKE SHILDT ABOUT
JACK FLAHERTY'S UPTICK IN
VELOCITY AS THE GAME CONTINUES
ALONG AND ALSO YOU MENTIONED IN
THE PREGAME THE LOCATION AND
CONVICTION HE HAS BROUGHT TO THE
TABLE.
JACK IS REALLY PUTTING IT ALL
TOGETHER AND HE IS STILL SO
YOUNG.
MATT: I THINK THIS YEAR HE HAS
GOT OFF TO A REALLY GOOD START.
DAN MENTIONED THE COVID SEASON
LAST YEAR.
I THINK HE WAS PRETTY
DISAPPOINTED.
THE CARDINALS HAD A BIG PROBLEM
WITH COVID, HAD TO TAKE A COUPLE
WEEKS OFF.
HE NEVER REALLY FOUND HIS RHYTHM
AS A PITCHER.
I KNOW HE'S REALLY COMING INTO
THAT FORM THAT WE SAW A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO.
HIS FASTBALL WILL TAKE UP AS THE
GAME GOES AND HOPEFULLY HE CAN
CONTINUE TO KEEP MOVING.
SCOTT: THAT IS A GREAT PLAY BY
PAUL GOL BASE AND GETS THE JOB
DONE.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN IN THE
FIRST FOR CLARITY.
CARDINALS UP 1-0.
>> ONLY HIS THIRD THREE BALL
COUNT OF THE NIGHT.
>> IT IS DOWN OFF THE WARNING
TRACK.
A GROUND RULE DOUBLE.
1-0, BREWERS.
>> THE POTENTIAL GO-AHEAD RUN IS
AT SECOND BASE.
CARLSON WILL BAT.
2-2 PITCH IS HIT IN THE AIR TO
LEFT FIELD.
TAGGING AT THIRD IS HARRISON
BADER.
THE CATCH IS MADE IN LEFT.
THE THROW COMING HOME AND IT IS
NOT IN TIME!
CARDINALS HAVE TIED IT.
>> IT IS GOLDSCHMIDT.
FIRST PITCHES HAMMERED OUT TO
DEEP LEFT.
IT IS AT THE WALL.
GONE!
TWO-RUN BLAST FOR GOLDIE.
3-1, ST. LOUIS.
>> THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
TRAFFIC IN THIS 11TH INNING FOR
THE CARDINALS.
AND THAT IS HAMMERED.
INTO CENTER.
AT THE WALL.
IT IS GONE!
TYLER O'NEILL.
THREE RUN BLAST.
AND I SMELL THE COFFEE BREWING.
6-1, CARDINALS, IN THE 11TH.
SCOTT: YOU ARE WATCHING THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
CARDINALS HAVE A RUN AFTER ONE.
SCOTT BRAUN, DAN PLESAC, MATT
HOLLIDAY, AND J.P. MOROSI.
TIME FOR OUR INTERVIEW.
OUR YOUTUBE ARE -- YOUTUBERS HIT
US UP WITH SOME QUESTIONS FOR
THE GREAT ADAM WAINWRIGHT.
ADAM: THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
SCOTT: SAY HELLO TO YOUR BUDDY
MATT HOLLIDAY ON THE BROADCAST
TODAY.
ADAM: HE IS A REGIONAL CABLE
JOURNALIST NOW.
HEY, MATT. MATT: HEY, ADAM.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING OUT OF THE
LOCKER ROOM?
HOW MANY DEVILED EGGS THAT YOU
HAD?
ADAM: NO, THIS IS DURING THE
GAME, I'M ALL FOCUSED, I'M ALL
CARDINALS, GO TEAM.
ALSO NOT MUCH OF A DEVILED EGGS
GUY.
IT'S GOT TO HAVE SOME SMOKED
BARBECUE ON TOP OF IT OR SOME
BARBECUE SAUCE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: THAT IS LIFTED BY TYLER
O'NEILL AND VOGELBACH IS GOING
TO WATCH IT OUT OF PLAY.
TYLER O'NEILL, HARRISON BADER,
AND KNIZNER IN THE FRAME.
LET'S START WITH JACK FLAHERTY
AND HIS PROGRESSION IS AN UPPER
ECHELON PITCHER.
ADAM: YEAH, WELL, I THINK WHAT
WE ARE SEEING IS SHADES OF 2019,
WHERE HE IS WORKING DOWN REALLY
WELL, HE IS WORKING UP OFF OF
THAT REALLY WELL.
HE IS NOT HITTING A LOT OF THE
IN-BETWEEN ZONE WHERE HE WAS
HITTING A LOT LAST YEAR.
AT THIS BIG-LEAGUE LEVEL, IF YOU
ARE LIVING THIGH HIGH, YOU WILL
HAVE A HARD TIME GETTING
BIG-LEAGUE HITTERS OUT.
THAT IS HIS BREAD AND BUTTER.
OFF OF THAT, WORKING UP IN THE
ZONE.
GETTING THOSE LEFTIES UP ACROSS
THE TOP AND THEN DOWN AND AWAY,
DOWN AND IN FOR CHASE.
AND AWAY, DOWN AND IN
FOR CHASE.
WHEN YOU ARE NOT LIVING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PLATE, HITTERS
WILL HAVE A HARD TIME HITTING
YOU.
DAN: IS THE GAME OF BASEBALL
STILL AS FUN TO YOU AS IT WAS
10, 15 YEARS AGO?
ADAM: NO, IT IS MUCH MORE FUN.
DAN: IN WHAT WAY?
ADAM: I WON'T SAY MORE FUN -- 10
YEARS AGO, THE GAME WAS PRETTY
FUN, I WAS PRETTY GOOD.
THE GAME IS A LOT MORE FUN WHEN
YOU CAN DO EVERYTHING YOU ARE
TRYING TO DO, ACCOMPLISH WHAT
YOU ARE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH,
MAKE GOOD PICTURES, MAKE IT HARD
TO GET ON THE BAG EVERY NOW AND
THEN.
ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO, THE GAME
STOPPED BEING FUN.
SCOTT: BURNES PICKS UP THE
STRIKEOUT.
THANKS, ADAM, APPRECIATE THE
PAUSE.
THINGS ARE FUN FOR YOU AGAIN,
THINGS HAVE TURNED AROUND AND
YOU ARE LOVING LIFE, PROVING
EVERYONE WRONG, TOO?
ADAM: FOR FIVE YEARS AGO, THE
GAME STOPPED BEING FUN BECAUSE
EVERYTHING HURT ON ME.
MY BACK HURT, MY KNEES,
DEFINITELY MY ARM.
A VERY GOOD CHANCE THAT I WAS
PITCHING WITH A LITERAL BROKEN
BONE IN MY ELBOW FOR OVER A
YEAR.
WHEN YOU ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
PICKING A FORK UP, IT'S A LOT
HARDER TO PICK UP A BASEBALL AND
CAST IT WHERE YOU ARE TRYING TO
THROW IT TO WITH ANY AUTHORITY.
GLAD TO GET OVER THAT HUMP.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WORKED HARD TO
GET ME BACK HEALTHY AGAIN.
OUR TRAINING STAFF WAS AMAZING,
OUR DIETITIAN WORKED HARD ON ME.
AS MATT CAN TELL YOU, WE USED TO
BASICALLY SHARE A ROOM ON THE
ROAD.
WE WOULD GET ROOMS NEXT DOOR AND
HANG OUT ALL NIGHT, PLAYING
VIDEO GAMES AND WHATEVER,
PLAYING CARDS, TALKING BASEBALL,
TALKING LIFE.
THERE WAS NOT A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS GOING DOWN.
A LOT OF JUNK, PIZZA, LOTS OF
BAD STUFF, NOT TALKING
ABOUT HARD ALCOHOL OR ANYTHING,
BUT COKES, SUGAR DRINKS.
I HAD TO CHANGE MY DIET, MY WORK
AT, THE WAY I CONDITION, THE WAY
I PITCH.
WHEN YOU ARE OLD, YOU HAVE TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS.
IT IS A GAME OF ADJUSTMENTS.
IF YOU DON'T, YOU'LL BE SITTING
AT HOME.
MATT: WHO WOULD YOU SAY IS THE
BETTER MARIO KART PLAYER, YOU
ARE SKIP SCHUMAKER?
THAT IS WHAT EVERYONE WANTS TO
KNOW.
ADAM: NO ONE WANTS TO KNOW THAT
BECAUSE EVERYONE SHOULD KNOW
THAT I'M THE BETTER PLAYER.
THIS GUY PITCHING IS
RIDICULOUSLY NASTY.
I DID NOT APPRECIATE, HE BROKE
MY RECORD FOR STARTING PITCHERS
TO START THE SEASON WITH NO
WALKS, MOST OF STRIKEOUTS.
HE HAS JUST BLOWN IT OUT OF THE
WATER.
HE AND WOODRUFF, THEY ARE JUST
THROWING DIFFERENT STUFF.
THE PICTURES NOWADAYS ARE SO
TALENTED.
THAT CUTTER THAT HE THROWS, IT
GOES THREE DIFFERENT WAYS, AND
IT IS NASTY AND HARD TO HIT.
SCOTT: AND HE GETS BADER AND
SETS A NEW RECORD.
52 STRIKEOUTS AND NO WALKS.
IT IS THE MOST K BEFORE ISSUING
A WALK TO START A SEASON.
HE TOPS KENLEY JANSEN'S RECORD
OF 51 SET IN 2017.
THERE YOU ARE, HE BROKE A RECORD
AS A STARTER, 35, IN 2013.
ADAM: I WILL JUST SAY, THAT
YEAR, THAT STREAK ENDED BECAUSE
I HAD TO FACE A VERY TOUGH
NATIONALS TEAM.
BRYCE HARPER CAME UP IN A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE GAME.
I DID NOT GIVEN TO HIM.
I WOULD NOT HAVE HAD 52, SO
EITHER WAY, CORBIN IS BETTER.
SCOTT: BRAVO.
THAT IS KNIZNER FINDING SOME
OPEN SPACE FOR A BASE HIT.
FOURTH HIT OF THE DAY FOR ST.
LOUIS, THEY HAVE A 1-0 LEAD.
BURNES HAS A STRIKEOUT AND A NEW
RECORD TO START THE SEASON.
HERE IS THE SWING AND MISS HE
PRODUCED OFF OF HARRISON BADER.
DAN: NUMBER 52, LOOKS LIKE A
FASTBALL ALL THE WAY BUT
DISAPPEARS.
LATE CUT ACTION.
VERY DIFFICULT PITCH, AS ADAM
WAS TALKING ABOUT, IT LOOKS SO
GOOD AND INVITING, BUT RIGHT AT
THE END, IT IS GONE OUT OF THE
STRIKE ZONE.
ADAM: EARLIER HE HAD A 3-2 COUNT
ON DYLAN CARLSON.
BASEBALL IS A FUNNY THING.
IF YOU HAVE A NO-HITTER GOING OR
SOMETHING, YOU SAY, CORBIN
BURNES IS A NO-HITTER GOING.
THE NEXT GUY, SEEMS LIKE HE GETS
A HIT EVERY TIME.
I LOOK OVER AT OUR TRAINER AND I
SAID, DID YOU KNOW HE HASN'T
WALKED A GUY ALL SEASON?
THEN HE THREW THE BALL LOW.
THAT'S THE GREAT THING ABOUT
VELOCITY.
IT CAN MAKE UP FOR MISTAKES
SOMETIMES.
YOU HAVE TO CHASE A LITTLE BIT
OUT OF THE ZONE SOMETIMES.
VOGELBACH WAS INCREDIBLE
YESTERDAY, CHASING A BALL OVER
HIS HEAD.
YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH MORE
STUFF.
YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH BAD SWINGS
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT EXTRA
VELOCITY LIKE BURNES HAS.
DAN: THERE HAS TO BE A PLACE IN
THE GAME FOR GUYS THAT DO WHAT
YOU DO, WHAT KYLE HENDRICKS DO,
MOVE THE BALL AROUND, CHANGE
SPEEDS.
I KNOW YOU ARE NOT THE SAME
PITCHER THAT YOU WERE 10 YEARS
AGO WITH YOUR STUFF, BUT IS
THERE STILL ROOM IN THE GAME OF
BASEBALL OR THE CRAFT OF
PITCHING AND NOT JUST THROWING?
ADAM: ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK IT WILL COME BACK
AROUND, HONESTLY.
RIGHT NOW, THERE IS A LOVE
AFFAIR WITH MANY OF THE
DIFFERENT -- SPIN RATE'S,
EXPLORING DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
ZONE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, NO
PITCHER SHOULD BE HAPPY ABOUT
COMING OUT OF THE GAME AFTER
FOUR OR FIVE INNINGS.
I THINK IT WILL COME BACK
AROUND.
YOU SEE MORE PITCHERS NOW COMING
UP THROUGH THE RANKS THAT ARE
TRYING TO LEARN HOW TO PITCH
AGAIN AND NOT JUST THROW.
SCOTT: THEY ARE LOOKING UP TO
YOU.
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME AS
ALWAYS.
GOOD LUCK THE REST OF THE WAY.
MATT, SAY BYE.
ADAM: ADAM WAINWRIGHT JOINING
US.
MID SECOND.
BURNES SETS THE RECORD.
>> NOBODY OUT.
LORENZO CAIN IS THE RUNNER AT
SECOND BASE.
>> HIT WELL TO CENTER.
BADER DRIFTING BACK ONTO THE
WARNING TRACK, SLIPS AND FALLS,
BUT STILL MAKES THE CATCH.
CAIN WILL GO TO THIRD, THEY WILL
TRY TO SEND HIM AROUND.
THERE REALLY THROW AT HOME IS
NOT IN TIME!
THE BALL POPPED OUT AND CAIN
SCORED.
>> ANOTHER TERRIFIC PERFORMANCE
FROM BRANDON WOODRUFF.
7.2 INNINGS IN BACK-TO-BACK
GAMES.
DOUBLE-DIGIT STRIKEOUTS.
>> TYLER O'NEILL, 0-2 TONIGHT.
HIGH FLY BALL OUT TO DEEP RIGHT.
IT MAY GO.
GONE!
THE GAME IS TIED.
TYLER O'NEILL!
>> THINKING ABOUT, HOW DID THAT
BALL GET OUT?
>> SHAW TO RIGHT CENTER.
IT IS HEADED FOR THE GAP, IT IS
DOWN.
TRAVIS SHAW, GO-AHEAD DOUBLE IN
THE EIGHTH.
>> SWING AND A FLY BALL, GET UP,
GET OUT OF HERE!
GONE!
SCOTT: LAST OF THE SECOND WITH
THE CARDINALS UP 1-0.
TIED TO INTRODUCE OUR FIRST FULL
QUESTION OF THE DAY ON YOUTUBE.
YOU CAN PARTICIPATE, CHIME IN
AND LET US KNOW WHICH PITCHER
COULD BE ON THE CY YOUNG HIGHWAY
EARLY ON IN THE SEASON.
GIVING YOU A NUMBER OF
CANDIDATES NOT NAMED JACOB
DEGROM, THAT IS THE NAME OF THE
GAME.
DEGROM ON THE INJURED RIGHT NOW.
WHICH N.L. STARTER NOT NAMED
DEGROM HAS THE BEST CY YOUNG
CHANT BETWEEN POWER, CLARITY,
BURNES, SCHERZER.
YOU MAY BE IMPACTED BY SOME OF
THE VOTES FROM OUR FRIENDS,
INCLUDING MATT HOLLIDAY.
YOU GO FIRST.
MATT: I WILL TAKE JACK FLAHERTY
BECAUSE THAT IS WHO WE ARE
WATCHING.
I HAVE GOT TO KNOW HIM WELL,
KNOW WHAT KIND OF COMPETITOR HE
IS.
HE IS A HARD WORKER,
UP-AND-COMING STAR IN THE GAME.
DAN: I WILL DOUBLE DOWN ON
CLARITY.
HE HAS AN ABUNDANCE OF TALENT.
HIS ONLY CLUNKER OF THE YEAR WAS
HIS FIRST START AGAINST THE
CINCINNATI REDS.
SINCE THEN COME ABOUT AS GOOD AS
YOU CAN GET.
6-0.
ANOTHER THING, HE IS PLAYING ON
A WINNING TEAM.
HE WILL BE A BIG PART OF WHERE
THE CARDINALS ARE GOING.
MATT: WHEN YOU LOOK AT A 6-0
START, HE HAS A CHANCE TO WIN A
LOT OF GAMES.
I NO WINS ARE NOT QUITE AS
IMPORTANT IN THE METRICS THESE
DAYS, BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A CHANCE
TO WIN 20 GAMES, HE HAS A REAL
SHOT.
SCOTT: BIG-TIME RUN SUPPORT SO
FAR THIS SEASON FOR JACK
FLAHERTY.
HIS OFFENSE BACKING HIM UP IN
THE FIRST INNING.
LEAGUE LEADER IN WINS AT THE
MOMENT.
2-0 TO TRAVIS SHAW.
SWING AND A MISS.
DAN: THAT IS A PART OF HIS GAME,
BIG, STRONG GUY, BUT A 2-1
SINKING FASTBALL.
TRAVIS SHAW GETTING THE GREEN
LIGHT, TURNING IT LOOSE.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT IN THE OPEN.
HE IS KIND OF A THROWBACK,
PITCHES DOWN IN THE ZONE QUITE A
BIT.
SCOTT: SHAW LIFTS ONE INTO DEEP
RIGHT.
THERE IS CARLSON, AND HE LETS IT
GO OFF THE WALL.
CANNOT TIME IT UP.
HEADING TO SECOND BASE IS TRAVIS
SHAW WITH A BUT DOUBLE -- WITH A
DOUBLE.
DAN: IT CAN BE DIFFICULT IN
MILWAUKEE AT THIS TIME A DAY
WITH THE ROOF.
SHADOWS.
YOU CAN LOSE A BALL IN THAT OPEN
ROOF.
YOU GO FROM SUNLIGHT TO SHADE
THERE IN THE RIGHT-FIELD PART OF
THE AREA.
YOU CAN SEE HOW DARK IT IS.
HE HAS NO IDEA WHERE THE BALL
IS, FINALLY TRACKS IT RIGHT
BEFORE IT GETS TO THE WALL.
MATT: LOOK LIKE HE LOST IT.
I WOULD HAVE SET OFF THE BAT
THAT WAS A HOME RUN OR OUT
PRETTY EASILY BECAUSE OF HOW HOT
IT WAS.
HE LOST IT FOR A SECOND.
BY THE TIME HE WE FOUND IT, IT
WAS TOO LATE.
SHAW AND UP ON SECOND WITH
NOBODY OUT.
SCOTT: OFFICIALLY RULED A
DOUBLE.
ALSO LEADS THE TEAM IN HOMERS
AND R.B.I.'S.
HE IS IN SCORING POSITION TO
START THE SECOND FOR MILWAUKEE.
NOW, THEIR HOTTEST HITTER,
AVISAIL GARCIA, STEPPING UP.
DAN: WHEN TRAVIS SHAW PUTS ON A
BREWERS UNIFORM, HE JUST SEEMS
TO HIT.
NICKNAMED THE MAYOR OF DINGDONG
CITY.
SCOTT: YOU LOVE THAT NICKNAME.
DAN: THE BREWERS PR DEPARTMENT
SENT ME A BOBBLEHEAD ON THAT
DAY.
SCOTT: YOU LIKE THAT NICKNAME,
MATT?
MATT: I DO.
I LIKE A LOT OF THEM BUT THAT IS
THE FIRST ONE I HAVE HEARD OF
IT.
SCOTT: DAN IS NUMBER ONE
PROMOTER OF THAT NICKNAME.
SHAW GETTING THE JOB DONE,
GARCIA TRYING TO BRING HIM IN.
FLAHERTY'S 1-0 HOME.
CHASE DOWNSTAIRS.
DAN: SEE HOW THE SHADE IS RIGHT
TO THE BACK OF CARLSON.
GOING FROM SUNLIGHT TO DARK.
MUCH LIKE HITTERS AT WRIGLEY
FIELD DURING A DAY GAME WHERE
YOU ARE GOING FROM SHADOWS TO
SHADOWS, OR SHADOWS TO DAYLIGHT
-- DAYLIGHT TO SHADOWS, OR
SHADOWS TO DAYLIGHT.
MATT: THIS IS AN INTERESTING
SITUATION, YOU WONDER, A GUY
LIKE GARCIA WHO IS PAID TO DRIVE
IN RUNS, IF YOU WILL SHORTEN UP
AND BE OK WITH TAKING A GROUND
BALL TO SECOND BASE.
SCOTT: OFFENSE HAS BEEN TOUGH TO
FIND IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
THESE GAMES IN THIS SERIES.
THIS IS THE SIXTH MATCHUP OF THE
SEASON BETWEEN THESE TWO TEAMS.
GARCIA TAKES A PITCH WIDE.
MATT: I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE BREWERS OFFENSE IN GENERAL,
NEAR THE BOTTOM IN OFFENSE.
THESE OTHER KINDS OF SITUATIONS
WHERE YOU HAVE TO GET THE RUN
IN.
WHETHER IT TAKES MANUFACTURING
IT BY TAKING THE GROUNDER TO THE
RIGHT SIDE AND TURNING IT OVER
TO THE GUY BEHIND YOU.
IN LOOKING AT SOME OF THE STATS,
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT RUN FOR
THEM TO PICK UP.
SCOTT: 2-2.
DAN: THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT INCREASED VELOCITY MATT WAS
TALKING ABOUT IN THE PREGAME.
DOWN IN THE ZONE, 92 MILE PER
HOUR WHEN HE NEEDS IT.
2-1 COUNT AGAINST AVISAIL
GARCIA, A PRETTY GOOD IDEA.
HE IS SWINGING.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHAT MATT IS
TALKING ABOUT, UNDER FOUR RUNS A
GAME, 25TH IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL THE SEASON.
BUT THEY HAVE SOME SOLID
STARTERS, BULLPEN NAMES,
EXCELLENT DEFENSIVE CLUB.
MATT: DO YOU SEE A LITTLE BIT OF
CROSSFIRE?
DOES JACK FLAHERTY CREATE AN A
NGLE GOING FROM RIGHT TO LEFT,
THE CROSSFIRE LOOK?
DAN: NO DOUBT, IT IS A LOWER ARM
ANGLE.
IT GIVES HIM A LITTLE BIT OF
MOVEMENT, CUT ON THE FASTBALL.
ON THE PREVIOUS PITCH TO GARCIA,
A PRETTY GOOD SWING ON IT, BUT
THE BALL IS MOVING AWAY FROM THE
BAT.
NOT ONLY IS IT 94, 90 FIVE, BUT
IT HAS SOME CUT ACTION.
SCOTT: GARCIA DOWN ON STRIKES.
FIRST PUNCH OUT FOR JACK
FLAHERTY.
BEHIND HIM IN CENTER FIELD IS
HARRISON BADER.
HE IS LIKED UP -- MIC'ED UP.
>> YOU GOT ROOM, YOU GOT ROOM!
THAT WIND IS FUNKY.
IT'S OK.
ALL GOOD.
DOUBLE.
SCOTT: THAT IS THE GOOD STUFF,
THE INSIDE ACCESS ON THAT PLAY,
DOUBLE FOR TRAVIS SHAW.
DYLAN CARLSON MISSING THE BALL
IN RIGHT FIELD.
LITTLE WORDS OF ENCOURAGEMENT
FROM HARRISON BADER.
OMAR NARVAEZ IS FOULED BACK
FIRST PITCH FROM
FLAHERTY.
ARE THOSE THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
GO ON OUT THERE, A LITTLE PICK
ME UP?
MATT: YOU ARE ALWAYS TALKING TO
YOUR FELLOW OUTFIELDERS, PICKING
EACH OTHER UP, TALKING ABOUT
WHAT YOU SEE, WHAT THE WIND IS
DOING.
SHADOWS.
IF THE BALL COMES IN THIS AREA,
I MAY NEED YOU.
THE SUN IS ALWAYS A FACTOR.
CONSTANT COMMUNICATION.
SCOTT: THAT JUST MISSED TWO
NARVAEZ -- TO NARVAEZ.
FIRST AT-BAT OFF OF THE INJURED
LIST.
THE BREWERS CATCHERS HAVE BEEN
STRONG AT THE PLATE SO FAR THIS
YEAR.
IN HIS STARTS, HITTING .385, 11
R.B.I.'S, HAS HIT SAFELY IN 17
OF HIS 19 STARTS THE SEASON.
DEALT WITH A LITTLE HAMMY ISSUE
AND TAKES A TIGHT PITCH.
TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
MATT: THAT STRIKEOUT GIVES HIM A
CHANCE TO GET OUT OF THIS INNING
A LOT EASIER.
THAT STRIKEOUT GIVES HIM
CONFIDENCE THAT IF HE GETS
NARVAEZ TO GROUND OUT OR FLY
OUT, HE HAS A GOOD OPPORTUNITY
TO GET OUT OF THE INNING WITH
THE PITCHER COMING UP.
DAN: TALK ABOUT SOME BIG TIME
PITCHING.
THAT AT-BAT TO GARCIA WAS
ANOTHER LEVEL.
GOOD HARD SLIDER TO NARVAEZ, BUT
THAT IS WHAT THE GOOD ONES DO.
THEY GET INTO PRESSURE BUT CAN
ELEVATE THEIR GAME.
WE HAVE SEEN FLAHERTY'S
VELOCITY, 91, 92.
THEN HE REACHES BACK FOR 94, 95
WHEN HE NEEDS TO.
HE IS STEPPING IT UP RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT: FULL BOAT TO NARVAEZ.
BRADLEY JUNIOR ON DECK.
SHAW DOUBLE TO LEAD OFF THE
BOTTOM OF THE SECOND FOR
MILWAUKEE.
GARCIA STRUCK OUT.
NARVAEZ FILLING UP THE COUNT.
CARDINALS GET A RUN IN THE
FIRST, THANKS TO NOLAN ARENADO'S
R.B.I. HIT.
CARPENTER FOLLOWED WITH A KNOCK.
ARENADO WAS CAUGHT AT HOME
PLATE.
POPPED UP.
ARENADO FINDS IT.
J.P., HOW ARE THE SHADOWS AND
THE SUNSHINE IN MILWAUKEE THIS
AFTERNOON?
CAN YOU SEE OK?
J.P.: [LAUGHTER]
SCOTT, I REALLY THINK THE WIND
PLAYED A HUGE ROLE ON THAT BALL
BY SHAW IN RIGHT FIELD.
WE ARE HERE IN THE OUTFIELD, AND
THE WIND IS AT OUR BACKS, COMING
IN.
I HAVE OFTEN HEARD DAN PLESAC
TALK ABOUT HOW WRIGLEY FIELD
PLAYS DIFFERENTLY.
WHEN YOU HAVE PANELS OPEN, THE
ROOF OPEN ON A GLORIOUS DAY IN
MILWAUKEE, AND THE WIND IS IN,
PITCHER-FRIENDLY SO FAR HERE.
SCOTT: YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
AT WRIGLEY.
DAN: IT'S A BEATABLE THING BEING
ON THE MOUND AT 4:30 IN THE
AFTERNOON -- BEAUTIFUL THING
BEING ON THE MOUND AT 4:30 IN
THE AFTERNOON.
LOOK AT THIS LAST PLAY BY
ARENADO.
OLD-SCHOOL, THE FLIP DOWN
SHADES.
HE PICKS UP THE BALL.
WAY TO DO WOULD OLD-SCHOOL,
NOLAN ARENADO.
MATT: THEY USED TO HAVE THOSE IN
THE DUGOUT FOR EVERYBODY.
THEY HAVE SLOWLY DISAPPEARED
WHERE EVERYONE HAS THEIR OWN
OAKLEYS, BUT NOLAN IS STILL
ROCKING IT OLD-SCHOOL.
SCOTT: MATT, WHY ARE THOSE
SLOWLY GOING EXTINCT?
LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE QUITE
PRACTICAL.
MATT: I THINK THE OAKLEY
GENERATION, HOW GOOD LOOKING
SUNGLASSES EVERYONE MAKES NOW
I'M EVERYONE PREFERS THE
OAKLEYS.
NOLAN LIKES THE OPTION TO HAVE
YOUR OWN EYES.
IF IT GETS IN THE SUN, YOU HAVE
THE CHANCE TO FLIP THEM DOWN.
LIKE YOU SAID, IT IS VERY
PRACTICAL, BUT I THINK THERE IS
SOME FASHION FLARE INVOLVED.
SCOTT: WE SAW GOLDSCHMIDT
ROCKING THE NIKES.
DAN: JACKIE BRADLEY DOES NOT
LIKE THIS CALL.
A COUPLE INCHES OFF THE PLATE.
AGAINST A GUY LIKE JACK
FLAHERTY, THE LAST THING YOU
WANT TO DO IS BE BEHIND THE
COUNT.
MULTIPLE WEAPONS FOR CLARITY.
MATT: IF JACK FLAHERTY IS
GETTING THAT PITCH, IT WILL BE
TOUGH FOR THE HITTERS TODAY.
IF HE CAN LOCATE THAT PITCH, YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO HIT THAT.
SCOTT: JACK IS COMING OUT SEVEN
SCORELESS INNINGS AGAINST THE
ROCKIES ON FRIDAY, AND HIS FIRST
CAREER HOME RUN IN THAT ONE.
ACTUALLY, THE BEST OVATION AFTER
THE HOMER WAS FROM WAINWRIGHT.
HIS NATURAL REACTION WAS GREAT.
BRADLEY JUNIOR TO CENTER.
SECOND.LIDES
SHAW WITH A LEADOFF DOUBLE, HE
IS STRANDED.
GOOD WORK BY JACK FLAHERTY.
GETTING BACK TO THE ST. LOUIS
CARDINALS IN THE THIRD.
>> DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD LINE,
WILL IT STAY FAIR?
IT IS HOOKING AND IT IS CAUGHT
AGAINST THE WALL!
WHAT A CATCH!
JUSTIN WILLIAMS.
AND HE SMOKES IT.
1-0 CARDINALS.
OH MY.
HE ALMOST BROKE THE SIGN IN LEFT
FIELD.
>> THIS WILL GO FROM
QUESTIONABLE FOUL BALL TO
SOUVENIR.
>> YOU ARE CALLING IT.
>> ARENADO WAY BACK AT THE WALL!
MY MAN CALLED IT.
HE CALLED IT, AND WE ARE TIED.
NOLAN HAS TIED IT UP 5-5.
>> TIME FOR A HOMER.
>> ARE YOU CALLING IT?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT.
>> EVERYONE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IT, I WANT TO KNOW IF YOU ARE
CALLING IT.
>> GOLDSCHMIDT WITH A HOME RUN!
TWO-RUN HOMER.
>> THERE IS A SWING AND A
HIGHBALL.
INTO DEEP LEFT FIELD, FLAHERTY
HAS JUST HIT A HOME RUN!
HIS FIRST MAJOR LEAGUE HOME RUN.
SCOTT: IT IS 1-0 CARDINALS.
TOP THREE.
A UNIQUE VIEWING ASPECT OF THESE
GAMES, CHECK OUT YOUTUBE'S LIVE
GAME COMMENTARY INCLUDING MLB,
THE CARDINALS BREWERS, AND A
SELECT GROUP OF YOUTUBE
CREATORS.
YOU CAN VIEW THAT ON YOUR
COMPUTER, MOBILE DEVICE, SMART
TV.
WE WILL TAKE SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS.
A CALL OUT TO OUR CREATORS NOW.
QUESTIONS FOR BRANDON WOODRUFF.
WE WILL MIX SOME IN IN OUR
INTERVIEW.
AND UNIQUE BOWLING THAT WE HAVE
ON YOUTUBE.
OUR FIRST QUESTION IS OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW.
CHECK THOSE OUT DURING THE GAME.
PLEASE PARTICIPATE AND WE WILL
GET THE ANSWERS FROM DAN AND
MATT.
A FEW GOOD ONES COMING UP TODAY.
FIRST ONE ON THE BOARD, WHICH
N.L. STARTER NOT NAMED JACOB
DEGROM HAS THE BEST CY YOUNG
CHANCE?
THOSE RESULTS COMING SOON.
TOMMY EDMAN TO LEAD OFF THE
THIRD INNING.
EDMAN, CARLSON, GOLDSCHMIDT.
ADMIN SCORING THE ONLY RUN OF
THE GAME SO FAR, ACTUALLY THE
FIRST RUN OF THE SERIES FOR ST.
LOUIS BEFORE THE EIGHTH INNING.
CORBIN BURNES COMING OFF OF A
THREE-STRIKEOUT SECOND, FOUR
TOTAL IN THE GAME.
DAN: CORBIN BURNES IS THE CUTTER
MACHINE.
IT IS AMAZING THE TRANSFORMATION
HE HAS MADE.
97 MILES PER HOUR, SO IT IS NOT
LIKE AN 89 MILE PER HOUR CUTTER.
IT IS KIND OF A ONE TRICK PONY
LIKE MARIANO RIVERA, BUT HE
THROWS IT ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
PLATE, AND WITH INCREDIBLE
VELOCITY.
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS HE IS
SO DIFFICULT TO CENTER IT.
SCOTT: A BALL AND TO STRIKES TO
ADMIN.
THAT IS NASTY.
DAN: THAT HE TAKES SOME OFF AND
IT IS ALMOST A SLURVE.
NOT A TRUE SLIDER.
83 MILES PER HOUR, SO HE GETS
YOU LOOKING AT THAT CUTTER DOWN
AND IN.
YOU SEE THE HAND ON TOP, THAT IS
ALMOST THE CURVEBALL GRIP.
NASTY PITCH TO TOMMY EDMAN.
MATT: THE SECOND TIME THROUGH
THE ORDER, HE WENT CURVEBALL,
CHANGEUP, CURVEBALL TO TOMMY
EDMAN AFTER HE GOT THAT FIRST
INNING RALLY GOING.
SECOND TIME THROUGH THE ORDER,
LOOKS LIKE HE IS USING MORE
OFFSPEED PITCHES.
SCOTT: AND HE IS GOING AFTER
ANOTHER RECORD.
MOST STRIKEOUTS BETWEEN WALKS.
GERRIT COLE THIS YEAR.
THAT IS AN ACTIVE STREAK.
BURNES, TWO AWAY FROM MATCHING
COLE, WHO PITCHED LAST NIGHT, A
GEM AGAINST THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
DAN: 12 STRIKEOUTS, NO WALKS,
EIGHT INNINGS.
THINGS WERE REALLY ROCKY IN THE
BRONX, WONDERING WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH THE RED SOX, THE YANKEES
ARE STRUGGLING, ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THE PITCHING HAS STEPPED UP,
TAILLON WALKER WAS GOOD.
COREY KLUBER HAS BEEN THROWING
THE BALL GREAT.
JORDAN MONTGOMERY.
GIANCARLO STANTON, WHITE-HOT
NOW.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THE YANKEES
HITTING, PITCHING.
NOT AS LOUD AS IT WAS A WEEK
AGO.
SCOTT: A FORMER TEAMMATE OF MATT
HOLLIDAY'S.
THE FREAK-OUT FACTOR IN NEW YORK
CAN BE HIGH AFTER A SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME.
MATT: I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
THEIR ROSTER, THE TALENT ON THE
ROSTER, EVENTUALLY IF YOU DON'T
OVERREACT, ESPECIALLY IN A
FULL-TERM SEASON, LAST YEAR YOU
COULD REACT BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH
A SHORT SEASON.
WHEN YOU ARE LOOKING AT 162, YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT TOO MUCH
TALENT TO STAY DOWN LONG.
SCOTT: YOU SEE BRANDON WOODRUFF
JOINING US AFTER THIS TOP THREE
COMES TO A CLOSE.
DAN: HE IS BEHIND THREE BALLS
AND ONE STRIKE.
THAT WAS A PRETTY GOOD PITCH.
CORBIN BURNES WANTED THAT LAST
ONE.
SCOTT: CARLSON SWINGS THROUGH.
DAN: THAT JUST GOES TO SHOW YOU
HOW GOOD THAT CUTTER IS.
YOU ARE SITTING ON THREE BALLS
AND ONE STRIKE, AND YOU GET IT
PRETTY MUCH MIDDLE MIDDLE AND
YOU MISS IT.
MATT: THAT IS THE REASON HE HAS
THIS STREAK.
YOU CAN THROW THAT PITCH DOWN
THE MIDDLE AND GUYS HAVE A HARD
TIME HITTING.
HE IS NOT AFRAID OF CHALLENGING
THE MIDDLE OF THE PLATE.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHAT KENLEY
JANSEN DID ESPECIALLY IN HIS
PRIME.
BURNES BREAKS THE STRIKEOUT
RECORD WITHOUT A WALK TO START
THE SEASON.
KENLEY HAD IT IN 2014.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THAT MONEY
PITCH IN THE CUTTER.
MATT: YOU CAN AIM FOR THE
MIDDLE.
HE IS NOT ONE OF THOSE GUYS THAT
HAS TO PICK AROUND THE ZONE OR
BE TOO FINE.
HE CAN REAR BACK AND THROW THAT
CUTTER AND AIM FOR THE MIDDLE,
WHICH A LOT OF GUYS CANNOT GET
AWAY WITH.
SCOTT: THAT IS DANIEL VOGELBACH.
MATT: FAIR BALL.
SCOTT: DILSON CARLSON -- DYLAN
CARLSON SAID IT HIT HIS FOOT.
CAN YOU REVIEW THAT?
MATT: NOBODY KNOWS BETTER THAN
THE HITTER IF IT HITS YOUR FOOT.
TYPICALLY NOT VERY GOOD ACTORS,
HITTERS.
IF YOU DON'T RUN, IT TYPICALLY
HITS YOUR FOOT.
YOU DON'T STAND IN THE BOX IF IT
DOESN'T HIT YOU.
DAN: NO QUESTION.
MATT: RIGHT TOE.
YUP.
SCOTT: VOGELBACH COLLECTED THE
BALL AS IF IT WAS FOUL, MAKES
THE THROW OVER TO BURNES.
TWO OUTS AT THE MOMENT.
MATT: IS HE ALLOWED TO TAKE HIS
SHOE OFF AND SHOW HIM HIS TOE?
SCOTT: [LAUGHTER]
MATT: UH OH.
SCOTT: CARLSON IS GOING TO
CONTINUE THIS AT-BAT.
MATT: IS THIS REVIEWABLE OR NOT
A REVIEWABLE PLAY?
SCOTT: CHECKING ON IF IT IS WERE
RUBLE FOR YOU, MATT.
CRAIG COUNSELL STILL GETTING
ANOTHER WORD HERE IN.
WE REVIEWED IT, MATT.
IT LOOKS LIKE CARLSON'S AT-BAT
SHOULD CONTINUE.
MATT: WE GOT IT RIGHT.
HITTERS ARE NOT VERY GOOD
ACTORS.
YOU CAN TELL WHAT HAPPENED BY
THE REACTION OF THE HITTER.
SCOTT: AT-BAT CONTINUES AFTER
THE FOUL BALL.
MATT: THIS PLACE MIGHT GO NUTS
IF THE WALK RECORD IS BROKEN
HERE.
SCOTT: NO MORE CRAIG COUNSELL
FOR THE REST OF THE GAME.
EJECTED FROM THE CONTEST, HERE
IN THE THIRD.
CARLSON SENDS ONE TO LEFT.
BRADLEY JUNIOR RACING TO THE
LINE, ADJUSTS ON THE MOVE AND
MAKES THE CATCH.
HAD TO REDIRECT HIS ROUTE TO
RETIRE CARLSON.
TWO AWAY.
DAN: I THINK CRAIG COUNSELL IS
GOING FOR THE RUNWAY.
YOU CAN SEE THIS HITS RIGHT OFF
THE TOP OF THE RIGHT FOOT OF
DYLAN CARLSON.
PRETTY OBVIOUS.
EVEN DANIEL VOGELBACH GAVE UP ON
THE PLAY, MAYBE WE GET A FREE
OUT HERE.
MATT: IT'S INTERESTING, WHEN JON
PAUL WAS TALKING ABOUT THE WIND,
JACKIE BRADLEY HAD A HARD TIME
WITH THAT BALL DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE, ALMOST OVERRAN
IT.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE WIND IS A REAL
FACTOR IN THE OUTFIELD.
SCOTT: BRADLEY JUNIOR, GOLD
GLOVER IN CENTER FIELD ONE YEAR
WITH BOSTON.
GOLDSCHMIDT TAKES THE PITCH DOWN
THE PIKE.
DAN: THAT IS BASICALLY, WHAT HAS
MADE PARENTS SO EFFECTIVE, WE
SEE THAT CUTTER AT 97.
TAKES A LITTLE OFF, THAT IS
ALMOST A SLIDER AT 86 MILES PER
HOUR.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN THE CURVEBALL.
HE IS NOT JUST A ONE TRICK GUY.
SCOTT: GOLDSCHMIDT LINES THAT
ONE UP AND SEND IT TO BRADLEY
JUNIOR IN LEFT.
TWO OUT BASE RUNNER FOR ST.
LOUIS.
BACK TO CRAIG COUNSELL BEING
TOSSED IN THE GAME.
SNEAKING IN ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
YOUR VIEW.
PAT MURPHY WILL TAKE OVER.
THE BENCH COACH HAS DONE SOME
HEAD IN HIS DAYS, A LITTLE BIT
OF INTERIM MANAGING WITH THE
PADRES.
MATT: IT LOOKED LIKE IT TOOK REC
A LOT TO SAY THE MAGIC WORD BUT
HE GOT THERE.
JIM REYNOLDS HAD HAD ENOUGH.
HE WILL STAND SLIGHTLY PROBABLY
OFF THE DUGOUT WHERE NOBODY CAN
SEE HIM AND HELP FINISH THE REST
OF THE GAME.
MAYBE HE WILL TURN IT OVER TO
PAT AND LET HIM GO WITH IT.
SCOTT: PAT WAS A GREAT HEAD
COACH AT NOTRE DAME, ARIZONA
STATE.
COUNCIL, THE FIRST TIME HE IS
EJECTED FROM A GAME THIS SEASON.
19TH TIME IN HIS CAREER.
DAN: YOU CAN SEE THE GAME PLAN
FOR NOLAN ARENADO, JUMP HIM
EARLY TO DRIVE IN THAT RUN.
HE IS UP THERE SWINGING.
MATT: YOU CAN DEFINITELY TELL HE
IS CHANGING SPEEDS MORE THIS
TIME THROUGH.
MIXING THE CURVEBALL, SLIDER
MORE.
MAYBE THE TWO-SEAMER.
SCOTT: LAZY FLY BALL, WHO WANTS
IT? URIAS FINDS IT IN THE SUN.
THAT SITS DOWN THE ST. LOUIS
CARDINALS IN THE TOP HALF OF THE
THIRD.
CARDINALS
BACK TO JACK FLAHERTY IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE INNING.
>> CAIN BACK IN THERE.
LAST APPEARED IN THE CONTEST ON
THE 13TH OF APRIL.
>> HIGH DRIVE, CENTER FIELD,
WELCOME BACK LORENZO CAIN.
>> THAT IS A RETURN.
>> BASE HIT BACK UP THE MIDDLE.
DUVALL AROUND THIRD, ON HIS WAY
TO THE PLATE.
IT IS CLOSE.
HE IS OUT.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> HOSKINS SENDS ONE IN THE AIR,
RIGHT SIDE, FOUL TERRITORY.
TYRONE TAYLOR WITH A SLIDING
CATCH FOR OUT NUMBER ONE.
>> HOUSER SENDS THIS ONE IN THE
AIR.
RACING BACK IS COOPER AT THE
TRACK.
HE HAS DONE IT AGAIN!
ADRIAN HOUSER GOES DEEP!
>> ADRIAN HOUSER, LIGHTNING
STRIKES TWICE AGAINST CASSANO.
>> SEE HOW SHARP HADER WILL BE
AFTER A WEEK.
SWING AND A MISS, AND THERE YOU
GO.
>> STRIKEOUT NUMBER 400.
>> FASTEST IN MAJOR LEAGUE
HISTORY, JOSH HADER.
SCOTT: BREWERS HALF OF THE THIRD
TRAILING 1-0 IN MILWAUKEE.
JACK FLAHERTY GETTING READY TO
GO AGAINST EIGHT, 9, 1,
INCLUDING CORBIN BURNES.
LET'S PAY OFF THE FIRST PULL ON
YOUTUBE.
WHICH AN ALL-STAR NOT NAMED
DEGROM HAS THE BEST CY YOUNG
CHANCE.
BURNES TAKES THE PIE, 36%.
HE BEATS JACK FLAHERTY AT 29,
TREVOR BAUER AT 23, MAX
SCHERZER COMING IN AT 12% OF THE
VOTE.
FIRST, IT IS LUISA RIOS -- LUIS
URIAS.
TIME FOR OUR STATE FARM DUGOUT
INTERVIEW.
ALL-STAR BRANDON WOODRUFF
JOINING US, COMING OFF OF A GEM
YESTERDAY, 7.2, HOW ARE YOU
DOING TODAY?
>> GOOD TO FINALLY SEE SOME
WARMER WEATHER, THE ROOF OPEN,
THE SUN SHINING.
THIS WEEKEND WE ARE GETTING TO
50% CAPACITY, SO ALL IS GOOD.
SCOTT: WE DIDN'T INCLUDE YOU
BECAUSE WE KNEW WE WOULD HAVE
YOU ON HERE FOR THE POLL
QUESTION.
YOU ARE OBVIOUSLY OFF TO A
STANDUP START, BUT WHO IS YOUR
BOAT OUT OF THE FOUR PLAYERS I
MENTIONED FOR THE EARLY CY YOUNG
CANDIDATE ASIDE FROM JACOB
DEGROM?
BRANDON: THAT'S PRETTY EASY FOR
ME, THE GUY ON DECK.
HE CAN ALSO HIT.
HOUSER AS WELL, HE HAS BEEN
PUTTING ON A SHOW.
ME AND FREDDIE ARE TRYING TO
PICK UP THE SLACK.
THESE GUYS ON THE MOUND ARE
GOOD.
I WILL DEFINITELY HAVE TO GO
WITH CORBIN.
SCOTT: URIAS WITH A KNOCK TO
START OFF THE BREWERS PORTION OF
THE INNING.
BURNES, COMING UP.
DAN: YOU TAKE A LOT OF PRIDE IN
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE IN HITTING.
ADRIAN HOUSER HIT A BOMB THE
OTHER DAY.
HOW MUCH TIME DO YOU SPEND ON
THAT IN SPRING TRAINING, WORKING
ON THAT IN THE BATTER'S BOX?
BRANDON: THIS YEAR WAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
WE WERE STILL TRYING TO WAIT AND
SEE WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH THE D.H., STUFF LIKE THAT.
NORMALLY, WE GET STARTED A
LITTLE EARLIER.
HONESTLY, MOST OF THE TIME WE
ARE DOING WHAT CORBIN IS TRYING
TO DO HERE, GET A BUNT DOWN AND
PUT A RUNNER IN SCORING
POSITION.
SCOTT: HE GETS IT DOWN.
MOVING URIAS OVER TO SECOND.
ONE RUNNER IN SCORING POSITION.
DAN: WHEN YOU WATCH A GUY LIKE
CORBIN BURNES, HE HAS
INCORPORATED THAT CUTTER.
IS THAT A PITCH THAT YOU HAVE
TINKERED AROUND WITH AT ALL
BECAUSE YOU SEE THE SUCCESS HE
HAS HAD WITH IT?
BRANDON: YOU KNOW WHAT, I HAVE
DONE A COUPLE DIFFERENT THINGS.
THE TWO DIFFERENT BREAKING BALLS
FOR ME RIGHT NOW HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO DO.
I GO BACK TO DOUBLE-A IN 2016,
LAST YEAR, I STARTED TO HAVE
SOME SUCCESS WITH IT IN THE
SHORTENED SEASON.
THIS OFF-SEASON, HAMMERED THOSE
OUT.
I FEEL LIKE I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
ABLE TO THROW THE TWO FASTBALLS,
FOUR-SEAM, TWO, CHANGEUP, BUT
THE BREAKING IS COMING AROUND
FOR ME.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN I GET ON
THE SIDE OF THE FOUR-SEAM A
LITTLE BIT AND IT DOES CUT, BUT
I HAVEN'T TRIED TO INTENTIONALLY
DO IT.
JUST SEEING HOW CORBIN'S BALL
PLAY SO WELL, AND HE THROWS
EXTREMELY HARD, WITH A TON OF
MOVEMENT.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE
HIS HANDS CONSISTENTLY GET IN A
GOOD SPOT AT RELEASE POINT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I DON'T
DO AS WELL, SO I TRY TO STICK TO
WHAT I KNOW WORKS FOR ME, GO
WITH THAT.
CORBIN HAS WORKED REALLY HARD ON
PERFECTING THAT PITCH,
COMPLEMENT AND IT.
YOU SEE THE RESULTS, IT IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
SCOTT: HE IS SO FUN TO WATCH.
GET THE JOB DONE WITH OUR SAC
BUNT.
OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS.
THEY CANNOT RESIST, SO I WILL DO
A 241.
-- TWO FOR ONE.
AS SUCH A GOOD PITCHER WHO CAN
HIT, ARE YOU EXCITED TO HIT THIS
YEAR?
AND THEN HOW DID IT FEEL TO
HOMER OF KERSHAW?
BRANDON: THAT IS FINE.
I WILL TELL YOU, I LOVE IT.
PERSONALLY, I LOVE IT.
YOU GET SOME MOMENTS THAT YOU
JUST DON'T GET WITH THE D.H.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT PEOPLE SAY
ABOUT THE D.H., BUT THAT IS WHAT
MAKES THE NATIONAL LEAGUE THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE.
A LOT MORE STRATEGY GOES ALONG
WITH IT.
HOUSER HIT AN OPPOSITE FIELD
BOMB AT MARLINS PARK.
EVEN FOR A HITTER, THAT DOESN'T
REALLY HAPPEN.
HE HAS BIG POP.
I LOVE GETTING IN THERE AND
SEEING THESE FRONT-LINE GUYS,
SEE HOW DIFFICULT IT IS.
IT IS JUST FUN TO BE ABLE TO
HELP YOUR CAUSE.
IT KEEPS YOU IN THE GAME A
LITTLE LONGER IF YOU CAN HANDLE
THE BAT.
THE HOME RUN A FEW YEARS AGO, IT
DEFINITELY CHANGE THE WAY
PITCHERS PITCH ME NOW.
I TELL PEOPLE THAT I'M NOT THAT
GREAT OF A HITTER.
I LOOK HITTERISH IN THE BOX,
AND THEY ARE THROWING BREAKING
BALLS AT MID 90'S, THAT IS HARD
TO HIT.
YOU UNDERSTAND ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF IT, ON THE MOUND, YOU NEED TO
BE THERE AND ATTACK, MAKE THESE
GUYS BEAT YOU.
DEFINITELY A COOL MOMENT FOR ME,
SOMETHING I WILL ALWAYS HAVE.
DAN: WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH YOUR
MIND ROUNDING THE BASES OFF OF
KERSHAW?
GETTING TO SECOND AND THIRD, DO
YOU EVEN KNOW HOW TO HANDSHAKE
THE THIRD-BASE COACH?
BRANDON: WHEN I TOUCHED FIRST
BASE -- AND THIS IS THE HONEST
TRUTH.
I DON'T REALLY REMEMBER TOO
MUCH.
I REMEMBER TOUCHING FIRST BASE,
SHOWED SOME EMOTION LOOKING AT
THE DUGOUT.
AFTER THAT, I DON'T REMEMBER TOO
MUCH RUNNING AROUND THE BASES.
I REMEMBER COMING BACK IN,
EVERYONE JUMPING ON TOP OF ME,
MOBBING ME, HITTING ME ON THE
HELMET.
QUICKLY AFTER THAT, CURTIS
GRANDERSON COMES UP TO ME.
THANK GOODNESS THERE WERE NO
OUTS.
HE SAID, I KNOW IT IS A HUGE
MOMENT, BUT YOU HAVE TO SETTLE
DOWN AND PITCH AGAIN.
THANK GOODNESS FOR CURTIS TO DO
THAT.
I DON'T THINK I COULD'VE GOT MY
HEART RATE SLOWED DOWN, IF HE
HADN'T TOLD ME THAT.
I DON'T RUBBER TOO MUCH ABOUT
RUNNING AROUND THE BASES.
I HAVE SEEN THE VIDEO PLENTY OF
TIMES, I REMEMBER ALMOST TAKING
LORENZO'S ARM OFF.
I ALMOST SNAPPED HIS ARM AND
HAVE GIVING HIM A HIGH FIVE.
HE KIND OF LOOKS BACK AT ME -- I
ALMOST TOOK HIM OUT.
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL WITH THAT
NEXT TIME.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE EARLY-SEASON, OFFENSIVE
STRUGGLES YOUR TEAM HAS HAD, DO
YOU SAY AS A STAFF, WE HAVE TO
TAKE IT UPON OURSELVES TO GO OUT
AND PITCH REALLY WELL, GIVE OUR
TEAM A CHANCE TO WIN?
THE OFFENSE HAS HAD A HARD TIME
GETTING IT GOING.
BRANDON: I DON'T THINK WE REALLY
LOOK AT IT THAT WAY.
EVERYBODY JUST TRIES TO PREPARE
AND DO THEIR JOB IN BETWEEN EACH
START.
WHEN IT IS YOUR START DAY, JUST
COMPETE, LEAVE IT ON THE FIELD.
WE JUST TRYING TO HANDLE IT THAT
WAY, KNOW THAT WE HAVE A REALLY
GOOD TEAM AND THE OFFENSE WILL
COME AROUND.
SCOTT: BRANDON, THIS WAS FUN,
THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US.
DAN: BRANDON WOODRUFF ON A
GLOBAL STAGE, YOUTUBE.
1-0 AFTER THREE.
CLARITY LOOKING STRONG.
>> DOING A LITTLE FISHING TODAY
IN BIG MAC LAND.
>> HAS HE FORGOTTEN ALL OF HIS
ANIMAL INSTINCTS?
THAT IS NOT HOW YOU ARE SUPPOSED
TO CATCH A FISH.
>> DID I TELL YOU ABOUT THE GIFT
THAT FRED BIRD GAVE ME A YEAR
BACK?
SEWED ME A NICE SWEATER.
IT HAS A BEAUTIFUL LITTLE FRED
BERG.
YOU KNOW THOSE CHRISTMAS ONES
WITH THE REINDEER?
IT IS LIKE THAT WITH REDBIRD.
>> WHAT IS FRED BERG DOING
TODAY?
VACUUMING THE CARDBOARD CUTOUTS.
>> HE FIGURED I HAVE TO GET MY
CHORES DONE.
>> LAST NIGHT IT WAS THE IRONING
BOARD.
TODAY, HE IS BIRDWATCHING.
>> HE HAS SOMETHING NEW FOR US
EVERY GAME.
TONIGHT, HE IS BACK TO SCHOOL.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE IS VIRTUALLY
LEARNING.
>> YES, THAT IS FRED BIRD.
I DO BELIEVE THAT IS TIGER KING.
VERY APPROPRIATE.
THAT MAYBE HIS BEST ONE YET.
>> I THINK SO.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: WE HAVE REACHED THE
FOURTH INNING.
SOME STAND OUT DO'S IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL.
LOOK AT THE FLOW FROM SOME OF
THE SUPERSTARS, WHICH BRINGS US
-- JOSH CHISHOLM HAS ADDED SOME
RED.
YULI GURRIEL, SO MUCH ACTION
GOING ON THERE.
JOSH HADER WITH A LONG LOCKS.
CORBIN BURNES HAS THAT GOING ON
AS WELL, ON THE MOUND.
WHO HAS THE MOST UNIQUE
HAIRSTYLE IN BASEBALL RIGHT NOW?
CHISHOLM, WE SHOWED YOU,
GURRIEL, TATIS JR., JOHN GANT.
SOME REALLY UNIQUE HAIRSTYLES.
DAN: I WILL GO WITH YULI
GURRIEL.
EVERY TIME THAT HELMET COMES
OFF, I LOOK AT IT -- WOW.
I GUESS YOU HAVE TO BE REALLY
CONFIDENT IN YOURSELF TO GO
AHEAD AND KEEP THAT LOOK, MAKE
THAT LOOK YOUR BRAND.
SCOTT: IT IS LIKE A TOWER, JUST
KEEPS GROWING.
DAN: THE GIFT THAT KEEPS ON
GIVING.
SCOTT: CHIA PET ACTION.
MATT?
MATT: I WILL GO WITH JOSH
CHISHOLM.
I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD PULL OFF
THE BLUE, YOU SAY THERE IS MORE
RED.
I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD PULL
THAT OFF.
A LOT OF SWAG.
I WILL GO WITH JAZZ AND HIS
MULTICOLORED, WHATEVER THAT
STYLE IS.
SCOTT: I LOVE IT.
I KNOW CARDINALS FANS ARE
DIGGING JOHN GANT.
HERE IS THE 1-1 TO CARPENTER.
ONE MORE HELPER.
WISCONSIN KNOWS THIS GUY WELL.
DAN: THE FONZ!
SCOTT: WHY DIDN'T YOU PUT ME ON
THE POLL.
HOME OF THE HAPPY DAYS.
BRANDON WOODRUFF TALKING TO US
EARLIER ABOUT SUNSHINE TODAY IN
MILWAUKEE.
CORBIN BURNES MOVING THE COUNT
TO 2-2.
THERE IS GANT.
HE GOT RID OF THE CORNROWS, AT
LEAST FOR NOW.
DAN: HE CAN DO SO MANY THINGS
WITH THAT NICE HAIR.
SCOTT: JUST LIKE THE WAY HE
WORKS ON THE MOUND, VERSATILE,
HE CAN START, PICK THINGS UP IN
THE MIDDLE INNINGS, LONG RELIEF,
HIGH LEVERAGE, HE IS THERE.
BYRNE'S SPOTS THAT ONE
BEAUTIFULLY FOR THE STRIKEOUT,
HIS STICKS OF THE DAY.
DAN: JUST MOVES THE BALL IN AN
OUT.
89 MILES PER HOUR.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT CUTTER
ANYWHERE FROM 87 TO 98.
NARVAEZ IS SITTING AWAY.
THAT IS THE CHANGEUP GRIP.
WAS INTENDED TO BE AWAY.
GREG MADDUX BROUGHT THAT PITCH
IN TO PLAY.
MATT: THAT IS A TOUGH CHANGEUP
RIGHT AT YOU, THAT IS A TOUGH
PITCH, ACCIDENTAL TOUGH PITCH.
SCOTT: MOST POWERFUL HITTER OF
THE SERIES, TYLER O'NEILL.
HOMER IN GAME ONE ON TUESDAY.
ANOTHER ONE YESTERDAY.
SIX HOMERS IN 16 STARTS SINCE
COMING BACK FROM THE INJURED
LIST ENTERING TODAY.
MATT: TYLER O'NEILL IS ONE OF
THESE GUYS, IF YOU CAN INCREASE
HIS SWING AND MISS RATE, MAKE
MORE CONTACT, I THINK HE HAS THE
POWER POTENTIAL AND THE SPEED,
ABILITY TO BE AN ELITE OFFENSIVE
PLAYER.
A LITTLE TOO MUCH SWING AND MISS
FOR ME RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: HE CRUSHES THE BASEBALL
WHEN HE CONNECTS.
LOOKING MORE LOCKED IN SINCE HIS
RETURN FROM THE I.L., DEALING
WITH A GROIN INJURY.
ELITE RUNNER, STRONG GUY, GOLD
GLOVER LAST YEAR IN LEFT FIELD.
DAN: YOU ALMOST FEEL, IF YOU ARE
A HITTER, YOU GET A COUNT
LEVERAGE, TWO BALLS AND ONE
STRIKE.
IF YOU ARE O'NEILL, YOU PUT
YOURSELF IN A TOUGH SPOT HERE.
WE SAW BURNES THROUGH THE
CURVEBALL FOR A STRIKE.
WE SAW THE SLIDER AND THE
CUTTER.
YOU KNOW THAT SOMETHING IS
BREAKING AWAY FROM YOU.
SCOTT: IT IS A VIDEOGAME, WHICH
BUTTON ARE YOU PRESSING?
MATT: ONE OF THE THINGS WITH
CORBIN BURNES, HIS 55TH
STRIKEOUT OF THE YEAR WITH NO
WALKS.
THERE IS THE CURVEBALL.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF CUTTERS
THIS AFTERNOON, OCCASIONAL
SLIDER.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE HE IS PULLING
THE STRING AT THE RIGHT TIME.
SHADOWS ARE STARTING TO CREEP
IN, YOU CAN SEE IT IN THE
LEFT-HANDED BATTER'S BOX.
IT WILL GET MORE DIFFICULT FOR
BOTH OF THESE TEAM TO PUT
SOMETHING TOGETHER.
THIS HAS LIVED UP TO THE BILLING
SO FAR.
JACK FLAHERTY HAS BEEN TERRIFIC,
PITCHED OUT OF TROUBLE A COUPLE
OCCASIONS.
CORBIN BURNES GAVE UP A RUN IN
THE FIRST INNING BUT HAS BEEN
ROCKSOLID EVER SINCE.
SCOTT: 56 STRIKEOUTS WITHOUT A
WALK, MATCHING THE CURRENT
RECORD.
THAT IS AN EASY ONE TO THREE IN
THE FOURTH TO SIT DOWN THE SIDE
IN ORDER.
AS WE FLAHERTY IN THIS MLBPA
FEATURE.
>> I DON'T THINK ABOUT WHAT I DO
WITHOUT HER, JUST HOW THANKFUL I
AM TO BE IN THE SITUATION I AND
BECAUSE OF HER.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT ME
BEING HOME RIGHT NOW?
>> SHE MEANS EVERYTHING TO ME.
SHE IS SUPERWOMAN.
>> WHEN JACK FLAHERTY WAS THREE
WEEKS OLD, HE WAS ADOPTED BY A
SINGLE MOM WHO BECAME THE SINGLE
BIGGEST INFLUENCE FOR JACK AND
HIS BROTHER.
EILEEN FLAHERTY'S LIFE LESSONS
CONTINUE TO SHAPE JACK TODAY.
>> TO BE MYSELF, TRUST MYSELF,
ALWAYS A MEMBER IT IS NEVER
ABOUT ME.
THAT WAS THE THING IN THE HOUSE.
>> WE WON'T TELL PEOPLE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY TROPHIES AT THE
HOUSE.
IT IS IN THE ATTIC.
>> AT HOME, HE IS JUST JACK,
BECAUSE THAT IS HOW EILEEN
RAISED HIM.
>> I GO HOME ON WEDNESDAYS, DO
YOGA.
WHEN I'M DONE WITH YOGA, THAT IS
TRASH DAY.
>> WHEN HE IS AT WORK, FLAHERTY
IS ALL BUSINESS.
WHEN HE IS NOT, HE IS OFTEN
QUIETLY GIVING BACK IN ST.
LOUIS, ALWAYS PREPARING THAT
NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT IT.
>> SHE DID THE BEST SHE COULD
AND SHE DID A PRETTY DAM GOOD
JOB.
SHE HAS BEEN EVERYTHING.
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE HOME
FOURTH, CARDINALS UP A RUN.
EACH WEEK THIS SEASON, WE WILL
FOCUS ON A YOUTUBE CONTENT
CREATOR FEATURED IN OUR LIVE
COMMENTARY SECTION.
TODAY OUR SPOTLIGHT IS ON FINN
MACCONNELL.
HE PROVIDES COMMENTARY ON A
NUMBER OF VIDEOGAMES.
THEFINNFTW.
100 29,000 SUBSCRIBERS, HIS
VIDEOS HAVE OVER 35 MILLION
VIEWS.
JUST ABOUT EVERY DAY HE UPLOADS
A VIDEO AT 1:00 AND 3:00
EASTERN.
A LOT TO ENTERTAIN THE PEOPLE.
SAY HELLO TO US IN THE LIVE
CHAT, WELCOME ABOARD TODAY.
THANKS FOR WATCHING WITH US AND
THANKS TO THE CREATORS FOR
HANGING FOR A PITCHING DUEL, AS
EXPECTED BETWEEN JACK FLAHERTY
AND CORBIN BURNES.
AS VOGELBACH STEPS IN FOR HIS
SECOND AT-BAT OF THE DAY, WHAT
KIND OF ADJUSTMENTS CAN THE
BREWERS MAKE SECOND TIME AROUND
HERE AGAINST THE CARDINALS' ACE?
MATT: LOOKS TO ME LIKE HE IS
WORKING DOWN AND AWAY, LIKE WE
TALKED ABOUT.
THEY WILL HAVE TO USE THE WHOLE
FIELD TO MAKE ANYTHING HAPPEN.
THE SHADOWS ARE GOING TO GET
WORSE AS THE GAME GETS GOING.
YOU WILL START TALKING ABOUT
TOUGH TO PICK UP SPIN, YOU'LL
SEE PITCHERS START TO THROW MORE
BREAKING BALLS AS THAT SHADOW
MOVES CLOSER TO THE PITCHER.
BOTH BULLPENS HAVE NASTY STUFF
WAITING FOR THE HITTERS.
I THINK IT WILL GET HARDER AS
THE GAME GOES ON TO SCORE
SOMETHING OFF OF THESE GUYS.
SCOTT: ONE NOTE, JOSH HADER NOT
AVAILABLE TODAY.
PITCHED IN FOUR OF THE LAST FIVE
GAMES IN MILWAUKEE, INCLUDING
BACK OUTINGS.
THEY MADE HIM WORK TO PICK UP
THE SAVE OR MILWAUKEE.
DAN: THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT CRAIG COUNSEL HAS HAD,
DEPTH IN THE BULLPEN.
HOW ABOUT DANIEL VOGELBACH?
SCOTT: YANKS THAT ONE FOUL.
DAN: CRAIG COUNSEL CAME OUT A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, TALKING
ABOUT HIS BULLPEN GUYS.
HE HAD A COLLECTION OF OUT
GUTTERS.
GUYS THAT ARE READY TO GO FROM
THE SIXTH INNING ON.
THERE YOU LOOK AT JOSH HADER,
WHO HAS BEEN TERRIFIC SINCE
PUTTING ON A BREWERS UNIFORM.
KIND OF A HARD GUY TO PICK UP,
MID UPPER 90'S FASTBALL.
INCORPORATING THE SLIDER A
LITTLE BIT INTO HIS REPERTOIRE.
HE WAS ABLE TO FIGHT THROUGH
THAT GAME LAST NIGHT.
THE BREWERS FEEL LIKE IF THEY
HAVE THE LEAD GOING INTO THE
SIXTH AND SEVENTH INNING, THEY
FEEL PRETTY GOOD ABOUT IT.
SCOTT: BALL FOUR, FREE PASS FROM
VOGELBACH.
LET'S BRING IN J.P. AT THE
BALLPARK.
THE BALLPARK IS GOING TO GET
LOUDER AS WE CONTINUE ALONG OVER
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
J.P.: SCOTT, I LOVE IT.
I REMEMBER COMING HERE LAST YEAR
FOR AN MLB GAME OF THE WEEK ON
YOUTUBE BUT NO FANS.
NOW, 50% CROWD THIS WEEK WILL BE
AVAILABLE.
AND THE BREWERS ANNOUNCED TODAY,
100% JUNE 25, ONE OF THE VERY
BEST ATMOSPHERES IN ALL OF
BASEBALL.
A CITY THAT LOVES THEIR BREWERS
SO MUCH, THIS IS GREAT TO HEAR
AND ALL AROUND THE MAJOR
LEAGUES.
MORE AND MORE FANS SAFELY IN THE
BALLPARK.
SCOTT: THAT'S GREAT NEWS, WE
LOVE TO HEAR IT.
WE KNOW CAPACITY HAS BEEN
INCREASING IN ST. LOUIS AS WELL.
HERE IS TRAVIS SHAW, WHO DOUBLED
IN THE SECOND OFF OF FLAHERTY.
MATT: I'M SURE THE PLAYERS ARE
THRILLED THE FANS ARE STARTING
TO COME BACK, WILL START TO PLAY
IN FRONT OF BIGGER AND BIGGER
CROWDS.
I CANNOT IMAGINE LAST YEAR -- I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, DAN -- BUT
I RELIED ON THE CROWDS TO GIVE
YOU THAT EXTRA ADRENALINE ON
THOSE DAYS THAT YOU FEEL
FATIGUED.
DAN: ESPECIALLY MARKETS LIKE ST.
LOUIS, NEW YORK, YOU HAVING PLAY
FOR BOTH TEAMS, THERE IS A BUZZ.
THERE IS SOMETHING AT YANKEE
STADIUM THAT UPLIFTS YOU.
YOU GO TO A GAME AND THE PLACE
IS ROCKING AND ROLLING.
WHEN YOU ARE TIRED, THAT
MOMENTUM GETS YOU GOING.
A LOT OF PLAYERS MISS THAT.
LAST YEAR, YOU HAD TO BE A
SELF-STARTER.
YOU HAD TO BE ABLE TO MOTIVATE
YOURSELF.
I COULD NOT IMAGINE THE GRIND OF
BEING AN EVERYDAY PLAYER,
NIGHT GAME AND THEN DAY GAME,
NOT HAVING THE MUSIC AND THE
FANS TO FIRE THEM UP.
I THINK THEY ARE LOVING THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE GETTING MORE FANS
BACK IN THESE BALLPARKS.
MATT: EVEN BE AS A SPECTATOR
WATCHING ON TV, IT FELT LIKE YOU
ARE WATCHING A SPRING TRAINING
SCRIMMAGE LAST YEAR WHEN YOU
THREW IT INTO A GAME AND THERE
WAS NOBODY BEHIND HOME PLATE.
THE FOUL BALLS YOU WOULD SEE,
THE TARPS, NOBODY SITTING THERE.
IT IS JUST A MUCH BETTER VISUAL
ON TV AS WELL.
SCOTT: FEELS SO MUCH MORE NORMAL
THIS YEAR.
SHAW SENDS ONE TO CENTER.
RACING IN IS BADER.
HE IS CALLED OFF IN CENTER FIELD
AND THE CATCH IS MADE BY TOMMY
EDMAN.
NICE CATCH FOR OUT NUMBER ONE.
DAN: TRAVIS SHAW HAD VISIONS OF
GOING 2-2 ON SOME SOFTBALLS.
THIS IS A TERRIFIC PLAY.
NOT AN EASY PLAY GOING OUT BY
TOMMY EDMAN.
HARRISON BADER SLIDING IN.
LUCKILY, THEY AVOID A COLLISION.
HEADS UP PLAY.
MATT: THAT IS WHAT THEY TEACH.
THE OUTFIELDER GOES LOW, THE
INFIELDER GOES HIGH, SO YOU
DON'T RUN HEAD INTO EACH OTHER.
YOU HOPE THAT HE SLIDES.
WORST CASE, TAKES HIS LEGS OUT
BUT NOBODY IS HURT.
GOOD PLAY BY BADER TO GO LOW,
GOOD CATCH BY EDMUND.
AS WE TALKED ABOUT, VERY
VERSATILE WHERE YOU CAN PLAY
HIM.
SCOTT: MAKING HIS FIRST START AT
SHORTSTOP THIS SEASON.
THAT ONE IS DEEP TO CENTER AND
BADER HAS IT FOR A LONG AND LOUD
OUT OFF THE BAT OF AVISAIL
GARCIA.
MATT: I THINK THE WIN IS A REAL
FACTOR TODAY.
THESE ARE TYPICAL HOME RUNS.
EVEN THE REACTION OF THE
HITTERS, THEY FEEL LIKE THEY GOT
THESE PRETTY GOOD, IN A VERY
OFFENSIVE BALLPARK MOST OF THE
TIME.
FEELS LIKE THE WIND REALLY IS
BLOWING IN, KEEPING THESE BALLS
IN THE BALLPARK.
SCOTT: ABOUT 10 MILES PER HOUR,
A LITTLE LEFT TO RIGHT ACTION
GOING ON.
MATT, I KNOW IT IS PROBABLY
ONGOING FOR YOU AND YOUR FELLOW
OUTFIELDERS, BUT FOR US, IT IS A
PHONE WATCH TO SEE THE ROUTES
CIRCLING AROUND.
EVERY FLY BALL IS A LITTLE MORE
ENTERTAINING, AS WE ROLL IT BACK
TO BADER'S ADVENTURE IN CENTER.
MATT: LIKE YOU SAID, HE THOUGHT
THAT HAD A CHANCE TO GET OUT.
IT IS A GOOD 10 FEET SHORT.
MAYBE HE JUST MISSED IT, A
LITTLE FRUSTRATED HE CAUGHT IT
OFF THE END A LITTLE BIT.
I HAVE SEEN THIS PARK PLAY
REALLY SMALL.
WHEN THE PANELS ARE CLOSED, THE
ROOF IS CLOSED, IT IS VERY
HITTER FRIENDLY.
SCOTT: THERE IS YOUR WIND IN
MILWAUKEE TODAY, SHADOWS WORKING
FOR FLAHERTY.
JUST MISSED DOWN.
SPRAY CHART FOR OMAR NARVAEZ.
LAST 100 BATTED BALLS 200 FEET
OR LESS.
DOWN 2020 AT THE PLATE AFTER A
STRONG 2019.
AND THE HITTING PROWESS IS BACK.
FOUR-PITCH WALK.
TWO ON AND TO OUTS HERE IN THE
FOURTH -- TWO OUTS HERE IN THE
FOURTH.
MATT: LOOKS LIKE JACK LOST HIS
CONCENTRATION THERE.
PRETTY UNCOMMON.
HE WILL HAVE TO DIAL IT BACK IN.
AS YOU SEE THESE SHADOWS, MOVING
CLOSER TO THE PITCHER, WHICH
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE
HITTERS TO PICK UP SPIN.
SCOTT: AND A CHAT ON THE MOUND,
AS JACKIE BRADLEY JR. WILL CRAWL
IN WITH TWO ON.
VOGELBACH ON SECOND, NARVAEZ AT
FIRST.
DAN: I THINK THE BREWERS FELT
VERY FORTUNATE THIS OFF-SEASON.
THE FREE AGENT MARKET WAS SLOW.
BRADLEY JUNIOR KIND OF FELL
RIGHT INTO THEIR WHEELHOUSE.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
MILWAUKEE WERE WONDERING WHERE
HE WOULD PLAY.
CHRISTIAN YELICH ON THE INJURED
LIST, HEADING OUT FOR ASSIGNMENT
IN THE MINOR LEAGUES.
IT IS A LITTLE BIT OF A CROWDED
OUTFIELD WITH LORENZO CAIN,
AVISAIL GARCIA.
THINGS HAVE A FUNNY WAY OF
WORKING OUT.
CRAIG COUNSEL TOLD US BEFORE THE
GAME, ONE OF THE REASON THEIR
OFFENSE OF PRODUCTION IS BETTER
THAN IT'S BEEN SINCE HE HAS BEEN
MANAGING, THEY STRUGGLE TO HIT,
BUT A LOT OF TEAMS HAVE SCUFFLED
OFFENSIVELY THIS YEAR.
THE BREWERS, THEIR STARTING
PITCHING HAS BEEN GOOD.
THE BACK END OF THE BULLPEN HAS
BEEN SOLID.
JACKIE BRADLEY COMING INTO PLAY,
HE WILL EVENTUALLY HIT FOR THE
BREWERS AND HE GETS MORE
CONSISTENT PLAYING TIME AND
A.B.'S.
MATT: IT MAKES YOU WONDER WHEN
YELICH COMES BACK HEALTHY WHAT
THEY WILL DO WITH THOSE FOUR
GUYS, IF ONE OF THEM COULD SLIDE
OVER TO FIRST BASE.
EVEN LOOKING AT YELICH, IF HE IS
HAVING SOME BACK PROBLEMS, YOU
CAN TAKE THE STRESS OFF OF HIM
BY TEACHING HIM TO PLAY FIRST.
TRY TO GET ALL FOUR OF THESE
GUYS IN THE LINEUP WHEN HE IS
BACK HEALTHY.
SCOTT: BRADLEY JUNIOR WATCHES
PAUL TO -- BALL TWO.
INTERESTING TO SEE THE
TRANSITION FOR THE BREWERS WITH
AN EMPHASIS ON DEFENSE.
MIKE MOUSTAKAS PLAYED SECOND
BASE FOR THIS TEAM.
NOW THEY HAVE THE BEST DEFENSIVE
SECOND BASEMAN IN KOLTEN WONG.
THAT IS FOULED BACK BY BRADLEY
JUNIOR.
FOUR HIGHEST-PAID PLAYERS ON THE
TEAM ARE OUTFIELDERS.
IT IS A FLY BALL WORLD OF THESE
DAYS.
THEY HAVE GUYS THAT KNOW HOW TO
RUN IT DOWN.
MATT: THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
THINGS THAT ARE POSITIVE FOR THE
BREWERS.
ONE THING THAT IS NEGATIVE, JUST
AN ERROR, THEY WERE HOPING,
FORMER FIRST-ROUND ARE OUT OF
CAL BERKELEY.
OFF TO A SLOW START, IN THE
MINOR LEAGUES NOW.
LONG TERM, THEY HOPE THAT THE
BAT COMES INTO PLAY, AND YOU'LL
BE SEEING HIM PLAY THE MAJORITY
OF FIRST BASE POST ALL-STAR
BREAK, IF YOU CAN GET THINGS
TURNED AROUND.
IT HAS BEEN A SURPRISE TO ME TO
SEE HIM STRUGGLE WITH THE BAT.
WATCHING HIM SWING THE BAT, HE
HAS A REALLY GOOD SWING, SNEAKY
POP FOR A SMALLER GUY.
HE CAN HIT THE BALL OUT TO RIGHT
CENTER.
I'VE BEEN SURPRISED WITH THE
FACT THAT HE HAD TO GO BACK DOWN
TO THE MINOR LEAGUES TO GET
THINGS TIGHTENED UP.
I SEE A FUTURE BIG-TIME HITTER
AND WHAT HE DOES AT THE PLATE.
SCOTT: I KNOW ONE THING,
TRIPLE-A NASHVILLE THIS WEEKEND
WILL BE HOPPING.
CHRISTIAN YELICH AND KESTON
HIURA IN THE LINEUP.
FLARED INTO BRADLEY JUNIOR, UP
THE MIDDLE.
THEY HAVE A MAN THERE, EDMUND.
EASY DOES IT WITH A TOSS OVER TO
FIRST.
STILL JUST ONE ON THE BOARD.
ST. LOUIS IN THE FIRST SCORING
TO MAKE IT 1-0.
WE ARE COMPLETED THROUGH FOUR.
>> WELCOME TO BUSCH STADIUM, A
PARK NOT DESIGNED FOR THE POWER
PACKED MILWAUKEE BREWERS BUT
IDEAL FOR THE ST. LOUIS
CARDINALS.
THIS MARKS THE CARDINALS 13TH
WORLD SERIES IN CONTRAST TO THE
BREWERS, WHO IN THEIR 13-YEAR
HISTORY, ARE HERE FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
NOW FOR GAME ONE.
>> DEEP TO RIGHT, IT IS GONE.
HE HAS RETIRED TO ST. LOUIS WITH
A VENGEANCE.
>> 6-0 MILWAUKEE ON A BLOOP
DOUBLE BY ROBIN YOUNT.
>> POPPED UP AND FOULED.
>> COOPER MAKES THE PLAY, THAT
IS THE BALLGAME.
10-0 AGAINST THE CARDINALS.
>> ANOTHER CAPACITY CROWD AS WE
GET READY FOR GAME TWO.
>> BASE HIT.
HERE COMES HENRY.
>> BASES LOADED, AND THE 3-0
PITCH.
>> THE CARDINALS TAKE THE LEAD
5-4.
>> DRIVE TO STRAIGHTAWAY CENTER.
WILLIE MCGEE PUTS IT AWAY.
>> A GAME APIECE.
SCOTT: CARDINALS, ONE, BREWERS,
NOTHING.
LIVE ON YOUTUBE THIS YEAR, THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
FANS WATCHING ON MOBILE DEVICES
AND COMPUTERS CAN VOTE WHICH
PLAYER WILL RECEIVE THE AWARD.
YOU ARE ALSO VOTING FOR OUR
POSTGAME INTERVIEW CONVERSATION.
PLAYER OF THE GAME POLLING
OPTIONS LATER IN THE SHOW.
A FEW EARLY CANDIDATES HERE.
OF COURSE, NOLAN ARENADO, WHO
HAS NOT BEEN THE ONLY RUN.
BOTH STARTING PITCHERS HAVE BEEN
SENSATIONAL.
LET'S PAY OFF THE YOUTUBE POLE.
WHO HAS THE MOST UNIQUE
HAIRSTYLE IN BASEBALL RIGHT NOW?
MATT WENT WITH JAZZ CHISHOLM.
FERNANDO TATIS JUNIOR CAN ALSO
BRING IT.
HIS HAIR GAME IS STRONG.
DAN: THERE IS SOME STRONG HAIR.
WE ARE MISSING THE BOAT WHEN IT
COMES TO HAIR NEWS.
MATT: I AM NOT MUCH QUALIFIED TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
SCOTT: COULD NOT CONVINCE THE
CROWD.
JOHN GANT, OUR OTHER OPTION WITH
THE LONGLOCKS.
KNIZNER, FLAHERTY, EDMAN DUE UP
HERE IN THE FIFTH.
WE START WITH KNIZNER.
I THINK MATT HOLLIDAY IS ONE OF
THE ONLY HUMANS ON THE PLANET
THAT CAN CALL OUT YADI MOLINA
AND SAY, IT WOULD'VE BEEN COOL
IF YOU PLAYED TODAY.
YADI TAKES A SEAT, WHICH HE
DOESN'T DO OFTEN.
MATT: I THINK HE GOT A TIP THAT
I WAS GOING TO BE DOING THE
GAME, DECIDED HE WOULD RATHER
LISTEN IN THE CLUBHOUSE, HEAR
WHAT I HAVE TO SAY.
I REALLY APPRECIATE HIM TAKING
SOME TIME TO SIT IN THE
CLUBHOUSE AND REALLY FOCUS ON
WHAT I'M SAYING, MAYBE PICK UP A
FEW TIPS HERE AND THERE.
SCOTT: HE IS SUCH A TEACHER, HE
WILL TEXT YOU AFTER THE GAME.
I LIKE YOUR CADENCE IN THE THIRD
INNING.
YOU DON'T SHAKE YADI.
KNIZNER FOULS THAT ONE BACK.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
SCOTT BRAUN, MATT HOLLIDAY, DAN
PLESAC.
YOU SEE ME UP THERE.
MATT: I SEE YOU GUYS.
SCOTT: MATT IS IN OKLAHOMA.
WE MISS YOU.
DAN PLESAC AND MYSELF STATIONED
IN NEW JERSEY, J.P. MOROSI AT
THE BALLPARK.
DAN: THIS MATCHUP HAS BEEN
ADVERSE -- AS ADVERTISED.
SEVEN PUNCH OUTS SO FAR TODAY.
HE IS THROWING THE BALL AS WELL
AS HE HAS ALL YEAR.
ABOUT AS GOOD AS IT GETS IN
BASEBALL.
MATT: HE IS A TOUGH AT-BAT.
THE WAY THAT HE IS ABLE TO THROW
THE CUTTER AWAY, CHASE IT WITH A
SLOWER SLIDER, MIX IN THE
BREAKING BALL.
I HAVE NOT SEEN A TON OF
SINKERS.
I WAS INTERESTED TO SEE HOW MUCH
HE WOULD USE THE BALL RUNNING
THE OTHER WAY.
I THINK HE GOT GOLDSCHMIDT
RUNNING ON HIS HANDS, BUT IT
WILL BE INTERESTING THE THIRD
TIME UP, IF HE MAKES THE BALL
MOVE IN THE OTHER DIRECTION.
SCOTT: GOOD BATTLED FOR KNIZNER.
HE LOSES OUT TO CORBIN BURNES.
STRIKEOUT NUMBER EIGHT OF THE
AFTERNOON.
WE ARE ONLY IN THE FIFTH.
DAN: GOOD LOOK AT IT HERE,
OFFSET FASTBALL, 94 MILES PER
HOUR WITH CUT ACTION.
WHAT MAKES IT SO LETHAL, HE
THROWS IT TO BOTH SIDES OF THE
PLATE.
SCOTT: J.P., WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THIS BREWERS PITCHING STAFF?
J.P.: A HUGE REASON WHY THE
BREWERS HAVE MADE THE POSTSEASON
IN THREE CONSECUTIVE YEARS,
FIRST TIME EVER. FOR THE
FRANCHISE
WOULD YOU BELIEVE THAT ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT PLACES FOR
THEIR DEVELOPMENT IS THE
PITCHING LAB AT THEIR SPRING
TRAINING HOME IN ARIZONA?
THE RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT FOR THE BREWERS HAS
BEEN KEY IN INTEGRATING THE
ANALYTICS WITH THE FEEL OF
PITCHING.
THEIR PITCHING COACHES ONE OF
THE BEST IN THE GAME.
CORBIN BURNES, BRANDON WOODRUFF,
DEVIN WILLIAMS WITH THAT DYNAMIC
CHANGEUP, ALL OF THAT CAN TRACE
SOME OF THE KEY ADJUSTMENT THEY
HAVE MADE TO THEIR PITCHING LAB
IN PHOENIX.
AND THE TECHNOLOGY THEY HAVE AT
EVERY SINGLE MINOR LEAGUE
AFFILIATE, AND HERE, AT AMERICAN
FAMILY FIELD.
SCOTT: THEY HAVE DONE SUCH AN
INCREDIBLE JOB WITH THEIR
PITCHING.
WE HAVE SEEN SOME OF THEIR YOUNG
ARMS VALID INTO STARS, LIKE THE
YOUNG MEN WE ARE WATCHING THIS
AFTERNOON, WHO CURRENTLY HOLDS
THE RECORD FOR STRIKE OUT
BETWEEN WALKS.
IT IS AN ACTIVE RACE BECAUSE
GERRIT COLE HAS 56 IN A ROW.
HE PITCHED YESTERDAY, SO BURNES
PASSES HIM FOR NOW.
COLE MIGHT TOP HIM LATER THIS
WEEK.
AND HE PUTS AWAY FLAHERTY.
MATT: JACK FLAHERTY, THAT IS NOT
A GOOD MATCHUP FOR HIM.
NOT A GOOD MATCHUP FOR A PITCHER
HITTING.
DAN: ALMOST IDENTICAL PITCH THAT
HE STRUCK OUT KNIZNER ON.
HARD CUTTER DOWN AND AWAY.
HE IS THROWING ENOUGH PITCHES TO
THE MIDDLE AND OUTER PART OF THE
STRIKE ZONE, YOU CANNOT LOOK AT
ONE PARTICULAR AREA.
TOMMY EDMAN, STRUCK HIM OUT LAST
TIME.
HE IS NOT AFRAID TO START THAT
HARD CUTTER, BRING IT OFF THE
PLATE, BACK AROUND THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
HE IS THROWING THIS CUTTER TO
BOTH SIDES OF THE PLATE.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES IT NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO HIT.
BACKDOOR ACTION ON THE SLIDER.
MATT: IT'S INTERESTING, HE WORKS
OUT THE FIRST BASE SIDE OF THE
RUBBER.
FOR HIM TO MAKE THAT CUTTER GO
BACKDOOR TO LEFTIES, FRONT DOOR
TO RIGHTIES, ON THAT SIDE OF THE
RUBBER IS PRETTY UNCOMMON.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT WHERE YOU
PLACE YOUR FOOT ON THE RUBBER,
BUT THAT IS PRETTY AMAZING THAT
HE CAN MAKE THAT CUTTER WORK ON
THE THIRD-BASE SIDE OF THE
PLATE.
DAN: YOU TALK TO BRANDON
WOODRUFF.
HE SAYS HE IS ABLE TO GET HIS
HANDS IN THE RIGHT PLACEMENT.
IT IS AN ACCOUNTABLE ANGLE.
WHERE HE IS STANDING, MORE
TOWARD THE FIRST BASE SIDE.
YOU ALMOST HAVE TO CUT THAT ON
THE OUTSIDE PART OF THE PLATE TO
GET IT THERE.
PITCHING IS SO MUCH TOUCH AND
FEEL.
RIGHT NOW HE IS IN THE LOCKDOWN
MODE.
A COUPLE OF THREE-BALL COUNTS
THIS AFTERNOON, BUT HE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO THROW THAT CUTTER,
PARTICULARLY DOWN AND IN AT
LEFTIES, WHEN HE NEEDS A STRIKE,
THAT HAS BEEN HIS SAVING SPOT.
MATT: INTERESTING TO SEE, 3-1
COUNT HERE, HOW AGGRESSIVE EDMAN
IS.
IF HE IS INNING FOR THE MIDDLE,
MAYBE TRY TO JUMP SHIP.
IF YOU HAVE THAT CUTTER GETTING
INTO A LEFTY, HE HAS THE POWER
TO DO SOME DAMAGE HERE.
SCOTT: EDMAN STARTED THE FIRST
WITH A SINGLE.
ONLY MAN TO SCORE TODAY.
HE IS ON BOARD TODAY, REACHES
FOR A SECOND TIME, AND THE
STREAK HAS COME TO A CLOSE.
CORBIN BURNES HAS FINALLY ISSUED
A FREE PASS FOR THE FIRST TIME
THIS SEASON.
MATT: THAT IS PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
DAN: STANDING OVATION FROM THE
FANS IN MILWAUKEE.
WHAT A TERRIFIC START TO THE
YEAR FOR CORBIN BURNES.
3-1 PITCH, THAT COULD'VE EASILY
BEEN A STRIKE.
JUST CURIOUS HOW LONG THE
BREWERS WILL GO WITH HIM.
HE HAS MISSED ALMOST TWO WEEKS
OF INACTIVITY.
THERE'S A LOT MORE FISH TO FRY.
HE HAS HAD 74 PITCHES.
I'M NOT SURE WHERE THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE, BUT THIS IS OUT OF
THE ZONE, BUT AWFULLY CLOSE.
MATT: TOMMY EDMAN IS NOT THE
TALLEST GUY.
I THINK A LITTLE TALLER PLAYER,
MAYBE IT IS A STRIKE.
THAT BALL IS DEFINITELY UP.
I THINK THIS IS PROBABLY HIS
LAST INNING.
THEY WILL GIVE HIM A CHANCE TO
GET THROUGH THIS INNING BUT I
WOULD SAY THIS IS IT.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT FOUR INNINGS
OF RELIEF.
DAN: THE STARTING PITCHING FOR
THIS TEAM HAS BEEN SO GOOD.
PERALTA HAS BEEN TERRIFIC,
BRANDON WOODRUFF, ADRIAN HOUSER.
IT'S BEEN A STRONG START TO THE
YEAR.
TOP TO BOTTOM, THE BREWERS FEEL
LIKE THEIR STARTING PITCHING IS
AS GOOD AS ANYONE IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE, INCLUDING THE
CARDINALS OR ANYONE IN THE N.L.
CENTRAL.
MATT: HARD TO ARGUE THAT.
NASTY STARTERS.
THESE GUYS ARE FEATURING SOME
NASTY STUFF.
IT IS SUSTAINABLE IN MY MIND.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE BREWERS'
ROTATION RANKED IN BASEBALL,
FOURTH IN K'S PER NINE.
THANKS TO GUYS LIKE BURNES,
PERALTA, WOODRUFF.
THAT ONE SALES AWAY.
DYLAN CARLSON IS 0-2 SO FAR.
TOMMY EDMAN ALSO STOLE BASE IN
THE FIRST TOP OF NARVAEZ -- OF
FF OF NARVAEZ.
MATT: I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO STEAL A BASE
AGAIN.
I WOULD LOOK TO TOMMY EDMAN TO
GET IN SCORING POSITION HERE,
TRY TO STEAL ANOTHER BASE, HELP
THE CARDINALS SCRATCH OFF
ANOTHER RUN, IN A DAY WHERE IT
IS GETTING TOUGHER AND TOUGHER
TO SEE, TO TRY AND GET ONE MORE
INSURANCE RUN.
SCOTT: HE WILL KEEP HIM TIGHT TO
THE BAG.
WHAT IS UNIQUE ABOUT BURNES, HE
HAD TO MISS THESE TWO WEEKS,
COULD NOT MAKE A REHAB OUTING,
OTHERWISE, THEY WOULD HAVE HAD
TO PUSH HIM BACK FURTHER.
THEY WANTED HIM ON A BIG-LEAGUE
HILL AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THE RUNNER GOING.
THERE IS THE THROW AND HIGH.
ANOTHER STOLEN BACK FORTH TOMMY
EDMAN, SEVENTH OF THE SEASON AND
THIRD OF THE SERIES.
DAN: STOLEN BASES HAVE BEEN THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE GAME.
LEADOFF SINGLE IN THE FIRST,
ABLE TO GET INTO SCORING
POSITION.
NARVAEZ, NO CHANCE TO THROW HIM
OUT.
GETS A BIG JUMP OFF OF CORBIN
BURNES.
EVEN IF THAT THROW WAS ON THE
MONEY, THEY HAD NO CHANCE OF
GETTING TOMMY EDMAN THERE.
MATT: GOOD JOB GETTING HIS HAND
BACK ON THE BASE.
HOLDING THE TAG ON THE RUNNER
THESE DAYS, JUST POPPING UP,
BARELY COMING OFF, A LOT OF
RUNNERS HAVE A HARD TIME HOLDING
THE BASE.
SCOTT: CARLSON SHIPS 12 CENTER.
HERE COMES CAIN.
BURNES DOES COMPLETE THE
FIFTH HE FINALLY WALKS SOMEONE.
IT WAS BOUND TO HAPPEN
EVENTUALLY.
WHAT A DAY FROM BOTH MEN ON THE
MOUND.
>> GAME THREE OF THE 1982 WORLD
SERIES.
FIFTH INNING OF THIS SCORELESS
TIE.
DEEP TO RIGHT FIELD.
>> HOME RUN, WILLIE MCGEE.
>> THE CARDINALS JUMP OUT IN
FRONT 3-0.
TWO FOR MCGEE, ANOTHER HOMER.
>> BOTTOM OF THE SEVENTH INNING.
5-1, ST. LOUIS.
>> BASE HIT, ONE RUN IS IN, TWO
RUNS ARE IN.
5-4.
BASE HIT.
BREWERS WILL TAKE THE LEAD.
>> GOT HIM SWINGING.
>> 7-5 FINAL SCORE AND ALL EVEN
AT 2-2.
>> GAME. FIVE
MOLITOR GETS ONE OUT THERE.
DOUBLE PLAY.
>> RIGHT CENTER, CHARLIE MOORE.
WHAT AN AND STANDING PLAY.
>> WELL HIT, RIGHT FIELD, HOME
RUN!
>> LEFT FIELD, THIS COULD BE IT.
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS TAKE A
ONE-GAME LEAD GOING BACK TO ST.
LOUIS.
J.P.: WELCOME BACK TO MILWAUKEE.
NO PLAYER MORE CLOSELY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BREWERS
RENAISSANCE AND CHRISTIAN
YELICH.
BACK-TO-BACK BATTING TITLES,
2020 M.V.P., SIGNED A MEGGITT
EXTENSION LAST MARCH.
THEN A DIFFICULT SEASON.
INJURIES THIS YEAR.
TWO DIFFERENT STINTS ON THE
INJURED LIST WITH LOWER BACK
ISSUES.
HE HAS PLAYED IN ONE MAJOR
LEAGUE REGULAR SEASON GAME IN
THE LAST MONTH, BUT THERE IS
SOME OPTIMISM THAT AS THE FANS
RETURN HERE TO AMERICAN FAMILY
FIELD THAT THERE M.V.P.,
CHRISTIAN YELICH, COULD BE BACK
ON THE ACTIVE ROSTER BEFORE THE
END OF THIS MONTH.
SCOTT: THEY MISS HIM IN SO MANY
WAYS, BUT THE OFFENSE FOR
MILWAUKEE IS THE ONE SPOT WHERE
THEY REALLY HAVE PINPOINTED A
NEED.
CHRISTIAN YELICH IS ONE OF THE
BEST IN THE BUSINESS WHEN HE IS
HEALTHY IN THAT CATEGORY.
8, 9, 1 COMING UP FOR MILWAUKEE.
URIAS SWINGS OUT OF HIS SHOES
AGAINST CLARITY.
PITCH NUMBER 70 FOUR THE
CARDINALS STARTER.
DAN: CRAIG COUNSELL TOLD US
BEFORE THE GAME, URIAS, IT'S
BEEN EASIER FOR HIM TO GET THE
BALL IN THE AIR, HIT FOR POWER.
LAST YEAR HE WAS A PUT THE BALL
IN PLAY GUY.
EVENTUALLY THEY THINK HE WILL
HIT FOR A LITTLE BIT OF POWER.
SCOTT: HE WAS TRYING TO SEND A
BALL TO ST. LOUIS JUST NOW.
OFF-SPEED PITCH FROM FLAHERTY.
ANOTHER SWING AND A MISS.
DAN: ABOUT 20 MORE MINUTES OF
DAYTIME AND THAT SHADE WILL BE
COVERING THE MOUND.
CERTAINLY A LITTLE BIT EASIER
NOW THAN WHEN IT WAS 15 MINUTES
AGO, WHEN THAT SHADE LINE WAS
HALFWAY BETWEEN THE MOUND AND
HOME PLATE.
SCOTT: GOT HIM.
INSIDE CORNER PAINT.
URIAS IS DOWN ON STRIKES.
DAN: PRETTY GOOD PITCH, FASTBALL
IN AFTER A SERIES OF STUFF AWAY,
A COUPLE BREAKING BALLS.
LOCKS UP URIAS ON THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
MATT: NICE JOB BY KNIZNER MAKING
THAT PITCH LOOK LIKE IT CAUGHT
THE INSIDE CORNER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BOX, IT
LOOKS LIKE IT IS OFF.
THAT IS A TOUGH PITCH, AS A RITE
HITTER, WHEN YOU ARE THROWING
CUTTERS AWAY, FOR HIM TO PAINT
INSIDE AND GET A COUPLE OF
INCHES OFF OF THE CORNER, THAT
IS A TOUGH AT-BAT.
SCOTT: NOW PINCH HITTER IN BILLY
MCKINNEY.
THREE HOMERS ON THE SEASON, HAD
A BIG SPRING WITH THE BALLCLUB
TO MAKE THE TEAM.
DAN: BIG CATCH ON THE ROAD TRIP
IN SAN DIEGO.
WOULD HAVE BEEN A BASES CLEARING
EXTRA-BASE HIT DOWN THE LINE.
MADE A FULLY EXTENDED GREAT
CATCH.
SCOTT: CORBIN BURNES, OFFICIALLY
DONE FOR THE DAY.
FIVE INNINGS ON 78 PITCHES, FIVE
HITS, A RUN, NINE STRIKEOUTS,
ONE WALK.
YOU NOTICE THE PITCH COUNT IS A
LITTLE LOWER THAN ANTICIPATED,
BUT HE HAS NOT PITCHED IN ABOUT
TWO WEEKS.
MATT: GOING BACK TO CHRISTIAN
YELICH, I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
UNDERSTATE HOW IMPORTANT HE IS
TO THEIR OFFENSE AND THIS TEAM,
HAVING THAT M.V.P. CALIBER
PLAYER IN THE MIDDLE OF YOUR
ORDER THAT YOU CAN RELY ON TO
COME UP WITH THOSE BIG HITS.
SOMETIMES TEAMS WILL PITCH
AROUND HIM BUT IT ALSO PROVIDES
YOU BASE RUNNERS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO SCORE.
WATCHING THE BREWERS, SCORING
WILL BE PRETTY DIFFICULT, IF
THOSE GUYS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
ORDER DON'T GET HOT, LORENZO
CAIN, THESE VETERANS, YET THEY
ARE PAYING TO PROVIDE OFFENSE.
YELICH IS SUCH A HUGE PART OF
GETTING THIS BREWERS' TEAM INTO
THE POSTSEASON WITH THE PITCHING
THEY HAVE.
SCOTT: JUST TWO GAMES PLAYED
SINCE THE 11TH OF APRIL.
YELICH, 2018 M.V.P..
LAST YEAR, IN A SHORTENED
SEASON, HE SAID HIMSELF, HE WAS
ALL AROUND TERRIBLE.
BIGGEST SLUGGING PERCENTAGE
DECLINE IN THE GAME.
ON BASE SLUGGING PERCENTAGE
DROPPED 300 POINTS.
AGAIN, SMALL SAMPLE SIZE, WAS
TRYING TO FIND HIMSELF
TIMING-WISE.
THAT IS SHIPPED TO CENTER, IT
WILL FALL FOR A BASE HIT.
BILLY MCKINNEY, PINCH-HIT SINGLE
WITH ONE OUT IN THE FIFTH.
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE ORDER FOR
MILWAUKEE.
KOLTEN WONG IS MIC'D UP TODAY.
MY WHOLE PROCESS IS >> >>
LOOKING AWAY.
IF I SEE SPIN, MAYBE I WILL CLIP
HIM ON THE FRONT.
DIFFERENT SPEEDS.
DIFFERENT BREAK.
THAT FASTBALL, MAN, IT GETS ON
YOU.
IT STARTS LOW AND HAS A LITTLE
BIT AT THE END.
SCOTT: THAT IS THE GOOD STUFF.
KOLTEN WONG ALWAYS TALKING
BASEBALL.
HE IS A GAMER.
GIVING US SOME IN-GAME ANALYSIS.
PULL TO THE RIGHT  SIDE,
CARDINALS WILL TRY FORTWO --
JUST ONE.
MATT: I THINK IT JUST GOES BACK
TO TALKING ABOUT JACK FLAHERTY.
50% FOUR-SEAM FASTBALLS, AND HIS
SPIN RATE IS NOT OVERLY HIGH FOR
A MAJOR LEAGUE AVERAGE PITCH.
HOW HE IS ABLE TO PITCH WITH 50%
FASTBALL RATE, THERE MUST BE
SOMETHING ELSE TO IT.
AS HE IS TALKING, IT HAS THAT
EXTRA CARRY, EXTRAZIP TO IT THAT
THROWS HITTERS OFF.
INTERESTING TO HEAR A GUY WHO IS
FACING HIM IN REAL TIME TALK
ABOUT WHAT MAKES THIS FASTBALL
SO EFFECTIVE, HOW HE IS GETTING
GUYS OUT, USING ONE PITCH FOR
50% OF HIS PITCHES.
SCOTT: I THINK MANY KIDS
WATCHING AT HOME WORLDWIDE ON
YOUTUBE ARE THINKING, HOW DO I
DO THAT?
CAN I GIVE MY FASTBALL EXTRA
LIFE?
DAN: IT IS A GIFT.
THERE ARE SOME GUYS THAT YOU
PROBABLY FACED, MATT, THAT HAVE
A HEAVY, SINKING FASTBALL.
IT IS JUST A NATURAL GIFT.
SOME PITCHERS, THEIR BALL HAS
TREMENDOUS CARRY.
WHEN I WATCH A JACK FLAHERTY, HE
REMINDS ME OF SOMEONE WITH THE
PHILADELPHIA PHILLIES, ZACK
WHEELER.
HE PITCHES DOWN IN THE ZONE BUT
THERE IS EXTRA LIFE.
THE HITTERS TAKE SWINGS AT IT
LIKE IT IS 97 TO 100 MILE PER
HOUR.
JACK FLAHERTY HAS THAT, AND
KOLTEN WONG TOUCHED ON THAT.
PART OF IT, TOO, HE HAS A REAL
SMOOTH DELIVERY THAT LULLS YOU
TO SLEEP BUT THE BALL JUMPS ON
YOU AT THE END.
MATT: IT LOOKS LIKE HE GETS
REALLY GOOD EXTENSION THROUGH
HIS FINGERS OUT IN FRONT.
MAYBE ADDS A LITTLE BIT OF LIFE
TO IT, GOOD REACH.
BIG, STRONG GUY.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE GETS OUT THERE
IN FRONT OF THE BALL, GETS ON
YOU MORE THAN THE GUYS THAT KIND
OF RETREAT OR MOVE OFF TO THE
SIDE OF THE MOUND ON THEIR
FINISH.
DAN: HERE'S A GOOD LOOK AT WHAT
MATT WAS TALKING ABOUT, THE
EXTENSION.
YOU SEE THE FRONT FOOT DOWN,
BACKHAND ALMOST COMING ACROSS
AND HITTING HIS LEFT POCKET,
FULL EXTENSION.
SCOTT: JUST LIKE MIKE SHILDT
TOLD US, THAT VELOCITY IS
PICKING UP.
MATT: PRETTY NICE WEAPON TO HAVE
WHEN YOU CAN REACH BACK FOR A
FASTBALL.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE CONDITIONING,
TAKING CARE OF HIS BODY, THE
OVERALL WEIGHT, RUNNING PROGRAM
THAT JACK DOES.
YOU ARE STILL IN THE 80 PITCHES
AND YOU ARE THROWING YOUR
HARDEST PITCHES.
DAN: THAT WAS 97 MILES ROUND.
SECOND INNING, TRAVIS SHAW WITH
A LEADOFF DOUBLE.
GARCIA, WE SAW THE VELO
CLIMBING.
THAT WAS THE FASTEST HE HAS
THROWN ALL AFTERNOON AT 97.
THERE IS GAS LEFT IN THE TANK.
HE IS ONE OF THE BEST
CONDITIONED PITCHERS IN ALL OF
BASEBALL.
SCOTT: BATTING AVERAGE AGAINST
THE FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL, ONE OF
THE BEST IN BASEBALL.
WE WILL DO IT AGAIN.
97.
MATT: HE IS GOING TO GET IT
RIGHT HERE.
DAN: IF YOU ARE LORENZO CAIN AND
SELLING OUT ON 97, JACK FLAHERTY
CAN THROW ANYTHING CLOSE TO THE
STRIKE ZONE WITH ANYTHING CLOSE
TO THE STRIKE ZONE.
MATT: SHOOK TO THE FASTBALL.
THIS SHOULD BE INTERESTING.
SCOTT: CHALLENGED HIM AGAIN, AND
HE FOUGHT IT OFF.
DAN: YOU SEE THE PITCH USAGE.
THAT IS WHAT WE TOUCHED ON IN
THE PREGAME SHOW, 49%, FOUR-SEAM
FASTBALL.
IT IS EASY TO THROW THE NUMBER
ONE WHEN YOU SEE THE RESULTS.
MATT: IT IS PRETTY AMAZING THAT
HE IS A STARTER AND CAN GET AWAY
WITH BEING PRIMARILY A TWO PITCH
PITCHER.
SCOTT: 80% FOUR-SEAMER SLIDER.
HE IS FEELING THE HEAT RIGHT
NOW.
MATT: DAN, AS HE THROWS MORE AND
MORE STRESSFUL PITCHES HERE, AS
A PITCHING COACH, DOES THAT MAKE
YOU THINK ABOUT, HEY, WE BETTER
GET SOMEBODY LOOSE?
HE IS EXPENDING A LOT OF ENERGY
IN THE FIFTH INNING WITH 88
PITCHES AND USING HIS FASTBALL
OVER AND OVER.
DAN: IT DOES, MATT.
HE IS ABOUT TO THROW HIS 89TH
PITCH, LOOKS LIKE A SLIDER DOWN
AND AWAY AFTER FOUR FASTBALLS IN
A ROW IN THE UPPER 90'S.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS, RIGHT DOWN
BROADWAY.
DIFFERENT SPEEDS.
JACK FLAHERTY GETS THE JOB DONE
WITH THE STRIKEOUT.
TWO IN THIS INNING, FIVE IN THE
GAME, FIVE SCORELESS.
NOW THE BIG BATS FOR ST. LOUIS
COMING UP IN THE ARNALDO
AND CARPENTER.
-- COMING UP IN THE SIXTH.
GOLDSCHMIDT, ARENADO, AND
CARPENTER.
>> THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS ARE ONE
GAME AWAY FROM THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> DEEP INTO RIGHT FIELD.
IT IS GOING TO BE OUT!
>> ONE BALL, ONE STRIKE.
AND A HIGH DRIVE DEEP TO RIGHT.
HOME RUN, AND THE CARDINALS
CELEBRATE A 4-0 LEAD.
>> ST. LOUIS CARDINALS ARE ALIVE
AND WELL.
>> THE WORLD SERIES IS HOT,
THREE GAMES APIECE.
>> THEY ARE READY HERE IN ST.
LOUIS FOR GAME SEVEN, AND NOW IT
CULMINATES INTO ONE GAME FOR
BASEBALL'S CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> WE ARE IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
SIXTH INNING IN THIS FINAL GAME
IN THE 1982 WORLD SERIES.
>> HIT TO RIGHT CENTER.
BASE HIT.
THE GAME IS TIED.
INTO RIGHT FIELD.
IT IS SEAMLESS.
>> THE WHOLE CITY OF ST. LOUIS
COLLECTIVELY HOLDING ITS BREATH.
3-2 THE COUNT.
>> THAT IS A WINNER!
A WORLD SERIES WINNER FOR THE
CARDINALS!
♪
SCOTT: WHY DOES J.D. MARTINEZ
LOVE BUBBLEGUM SO MUCH, AND WHAT
IS THAT WATCH ON HIS WRIST?
FIND OUT ON THE SEASON PREMIERE
OF BIG LEAGUES LOCKERS ON
YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
MILWAUKEE IS THE SPOT THIS
AFTERNOON IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
GOOD PITCHING.
CORBIN BURNES DONE FOR THE DAY
AFTER FIVE INNINGS AND DREW
RASMUSSEN IS GOING TO TAKE OVER
FROM MILWAUKEE.
CARDINALS HAD A RUN AND CAME
BACK IN THE FIRST, THERE LEADOFF
MAN TOMMY EDMAN WITH A SINGLE.
HE EVENTUALLY SCORED, THE ONLY
RUN SCORING ACTION SO FAR TODAY.
HERE IS RASMUSSEN GETTING READY
TO PITCH THE SIXTH.
DAN: YOU LOOK AT THE E.R.A.,
SOUTH OF FIVE.
HE WILL ASK TO GO MULTIPLE
INNINGS.
LAST NIGHT, BREWERS WON LATE.
CRAIG COUNSELL SAID JOSH HADER
NOT AVAILABLE THIS AFTERNOON, HE
HAD PITCHED FOUR OUT OF FIVE
DAYS, SO THE BULLPEN GOING TO
HAVE TO SHAKE THINGS OUT.
GET SOME LENGTH.
FIVE REALLY GOOD INDIANS FROM
CORBIN BURNES AFTER MISSING
NEARLY TWO WEEKS -- FIVE REALLY
GOOD INDIANS FROM CORBIN BURNES
AFTER MISSING NEARLY TWO WEEKS.
SCOTT: GOLDSCHMIDT, ARENADO, AND
CARPENTER UP FOR ST. LOUIS.
RASMUSSEN PICKED UP HIS FIRST
SAVE OF HIS PROFESSIONAL CAREER
WITH AN INNING WALK AND A
STRIKEOUT.
MATT: IT IS SO EXCITING GETTING
STARTER OUT OF THEIR AND HAVE A
GUY COME IN AND THROW THE HIGH
90'S WITH AN 87 MILE AN HOUR
SLIDER.
IT NEVER ENDS.
NOWADAYS, THESE GUYS COMING
THROWING HIGH-END STUFF.
JUST BECAUSE THE STARTER IS OUT
OF THE GAME AS A HITTER, IT
DOESN'T MEAN THE AT-BAT'S GET
ANY EASIER.
SCOTT: 96, UP IN THE ZONE.
AND HE HAS BEEN ON A ROLL LATELY
AS YOU SEE ARENADO WAITING.
RASMUSSEN'S LAST NIGHT
APPEARANCES, E.R.A. IS .079.
A HIT FOR GOLDSCHMIDT LAST TIME
UP IN THE THIRD.
HE WORKS THE COUNT FULL.
DAN: PRETTY GOOD TAKE ON A 2-2
SLIDER, DOWN AND AWAY.
MATT: GREAT TAKE.
DAN: PITCH BEFORE THAT 98 MILES
AN HOUR.
MATT: GREAT TAKE RIGHT THERE.
NOW HE SET HIMSELF UP TO MAYBE
GET A FASTBALL HERE IN THE 3-2
COUNT AND POTENTIALLY DO SOME
DAMAGE.
SCOTT: BALL FOUR.
GOLDSCHMIDT IS GOING TO LEAD OFF
THE INNING WITH A WALK TO SET UP
FOR NOLAN ARENADO, WHO PULLED A
BASE HIT IN THE FIRST INNING.
THAT SCORED TOMMY EDMAN.
AND THIS IS THE FULL HITTING
DAMAGE, FULL SIDE, 25 TIMES OUT
OF THESE 39 HITS THIS SEASON, SO
SECOND MOST IN BASEBALL.
THAT IS THE GOOD OLD-FASHIONED
POWER, MATT.
MATT: YOU KNOW, HE HAS GOT A
VERY DIRECT SWING, SO HE IS VERY
DIRECT TO THE BALL.
HE IS OUT IN FRONT, HIS BURIAL
GETS OUT IN FRONT OF HIS BODY
PRETTY EASILY, SO -- IS BARREL
GETS IT OUT IN FRONT OF HIS BODY
PRETTY EASILY.
I THINK THE BEST VERSION OF
NOLAN ARENADO IS THE ONE DRIVING
THE BALL TO RIGHT CENTER AND
PULLING OFF TO RIGHT SPEED.
HE HAS PULLED THE BALL REALLY
WELL HIS WHOLE CAREER.
SCOTT: WE SAW HIM DO THE DAMAGE
IN THE FIRST INNING TO DRIVE
HOME EDMUND, AND HE DOES NOT
BITE ON THAT PAGE FROM
RASMUSSEN.
PAUL AND HIS STRIKE.
I THINK NOW IS THE TIME TO LET
US KNOW ABOUT YOUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH NOLAN.
I WAS ON RADIO THIS MORNING WITH
RANDY MICHELLE IN 101 IN ST.
LOUIS AND HE SAID, ASK MATT
ABOUT HOW HE WAS THE BIGGEST
PART OF NOLAN ARENADO COMING TO
ST. LOUIS.
IS THAT TRUE?
MATT: [LAUGHTER]
I DON'T KNOW IF I WAS THE
BIGGEST PART.
NOLAN AND I ARE CLOSE, AND WE
TALKED ABOUT PLAYING IN ST.
LOUIS AND THE POTENTIAL OF HIM
GETTING TRADED THERE, AND WHAT
THAT WAS LIKE AND THE EXCITEMENT
OF BEING A ST. LOUIS CARDINALS
AND EVERYTHING THAT GOES INTO
PLAYING FOR THE CARDINALS AND
HOW MUCH THE CITY LOVES THE TEAM
AND LOVES ITS PLAYERS, AND JUST
THE KIND OF STYLE OF PLAYER HE
IS.
IT JUST WAS A GREAT FIT.
I WOULD NOT TAKE TOO MUCH CREDIT
AS HE RIPS ONE INTO LEFT RIGHT
THERE, BUT HE DEFINITELY HAD A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT BEING A
ST. LOUIS CARDINALS, WHICH I WAS
HAPPY TO FILL HIM IN ON.
SCOTT: A LITTLE DÉJÀ VU FROM THE
FIRST INNING, SAME WORK AGAIN.
PULLS A PITCH, LEFT SIDE, TWO
FOR THREE TODAY, AND MOVES
GOLDSCHMIDT INTO SCORING
POSITION.
DAN: ADD THIS TO THE LIST OF
PULL SIDE BASE HITS FOR NOLAN
ARENADO.
MATT, WHEN YOU WERE TRADED THE
ST. LOUIS CARDINALS, WAS IT A
DIFFICULT TRANSITION AFTER
SPENDING SO MANY YEARS WITH THE
ROCKIES?
MATT: WELL, YOU KNOW, I HAD TO
STOP IN BETWEEN IN OAKLAND AT
ANY TIME, THE TRANSITION FROM
COLORADO TO OAKLAND WAS
DIFFICULT.
THE FIRST TIME YOU GET TRADED IS
A LITTLE BIT CHALLENGING, BUT
GETTING A CHANCE TO GO OVER TO
ST. LOUIS AND PLAY IN FRONT OF
THAT CROWD AND THE ATMOSPHERE,
AND I GOT TRADED RIGHT BEFORE
THE TRADING DEADLINE, AND THEY
WERE IN FIRST PLACE OR CLOSE TO
FIRST PLACE AND IN THE PLAYOFF
HUNT, SO IT WAS PRETTY AWESOME
JUST TO STEP RIGHT INTO A
PLAYOFF RACE AND THE EXCITEMENT
OF PLAYING FOR SUCH A STORIED,
TRADITIONAL POWERHOUSE.
I LOVED EVERY MINUTE OF PLAYING
FOR THE CARDINALS.
SCOTT: GOLDSCHMIDT AND ARENADO
ON THE BASES FOR MATT CARPENTER
GETTING THE START AT SECOND BASE
TODAY.
SINGLE INTO FIRST, STRIKEOUT IN
THE FOURTH.
FILES THAT ONE OFF.
MATT, I WILL TAKE YOU BACK TO
YOUR DEBUT IN FRONT OF THE CROWD
IN ST. LOUIS WITH THE OVATION.
HEY, YOU LOVED THE BIG MOMENT.
MATT: YEAH, IT TAKES ME BACK.
PRETTY EXCITING TIMES.
YOU KNOW, I STARTED OUT IN
PHILADELPHIA, GOT TRADED ON THE
ROAD.
THAT WAS MY FIRST GAME AT HOME,
FIRST AT-BAT TO HIT A DOUBLE.
PRETTY INCREDIBLE MOMENT FOR ME.
WHEN I WILL NEVER FORGET.
IT BRINGS BACK SO MANY MEMORIES
AND JUST THE EXCITEMENT OF THAT
MOMENT FOR ME.
IT FEELS LIKE YESTERDAY.
DAN: HOW ABOUT MARK DEROSA FOR
YOUR FIRST RUNS BATTED IN FOR
THE RECORDS?
MATT: YOU KNOW, THAT IS AN EASY.
YOU HAVE TO HIT PRETTY FAR TO
DRIVE AND DERO.
DERO IS AN INCREDIBLE GUY,
AWESOME TEAMMATE.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE TEAMMATES AND
IS AN INCREDIBLE JOB IN THE
NETWORK TALKING BASEBALL.
YEAH, SO, WE HAD A NICE LITTLE
RUN AS TEAMMATES.
LIKE I SAID, HILARIOUS,
INCREDIBLE GUY.
SCOTT: MARK DEROSA, STAR ON MLB
NETWORK, STAR QUARTERBACK IN
HIGH SCHOOL LIKE YOU, MATT.
.475 22 RUNS DRIVEN IN YOUR
FIRST YEAR THE CARDINALS.
I FEEL LIKE THAT IS PRETTY GOOD.
MATT: I GOT OFF TO A REALLY GOOD
START, WHICH WAS A LOT OF FUN.
I SET THE BAR PRETTY HIGH FOR
MYSELF AND FOR THE NEXT EIGHT
YEARS, BUT OR SEVEN YEARS, BUT I
WAS TRADED RIGHT INTO PLAYOFF
RACE AND WAS SWINGING THE BAT
WELL WHEN I GOT TRADED.
IT WAS GOOD TIMING FOR ME GOING
IN THERE, AND IT WAS A FUN TEAM
TO PLAY ON.
I GOT A CHANCE TO BAT BEHIND
ALBERT PUJOLS.
IMMEDIATELY, I WAS PUT FORTH,
AND IMMEDIATELY HAD TONS OF
AT-BATS WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITIONS BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT
PITCHING TO ALBERT.
I GOT A LOT OF AT-BATS WITH
ALBERT GETTING THE FOUR BALLS
RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME.
DAN: WHAT MAKES IT SO SPECIAL
PLAYING THERE, MATT?
IS AT THE ST. LOUIS AREA?
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE FANS
AND THE PLAYERS?
MATT: I THINK IT IS ALL OF THOSE
THINGS.
I THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
CARDINAL FANS, THE WHOLE REGION
I THINK LOVES CARDINAL BASEBALL.
THE HISTORY OF THE ORGANIZATION
ALSO PLAYS INTO IT, AND ALL THE
GREAT PLAYERS, HALL OF FAMERS
AND WORK THEY DO IN THE
COMMUNITY AND GIVING BACK TO THE
CITY OF ST. LOUIS IS JUST A
REALLY COOL PLACE TO PLAY AND A
LOT OF FUN.
SCOTT: IT WAS BOBBLED, SO JUST
THE OUT AT FIRST.
TWO DOWN IN THE INNING.
COULD HAVE BEEN A DOUBLE PLAY
BALL FOR MILWAUKEE TO GET OUT OF
THIS JAM.
GOLDSCHMIDT IS GOING TO MOVE TO
THIRD, AND ARENADO IS AT SECOND
AFTER THE GROUNDBALL OUT
OFF THE BAT OF TYLER O'NEILL.
MATT: IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A TOUGH
DOUBLE PLAY.
I DON'T THINK YOU ARE TURNING A
DOUBLE PLAY ON O'NEILL.
I DON'T THINK YOU ARE GETTING
HIM.
I THINK THAT TURNED OUT, AND NOW
THEY HAVE TWO RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION, BUT I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE GETTING TWO ON THAT PLAY,
DAN.
DAN: TOTALLY AGREE, AS WELL AS
HE RUNS, YOU WOULD REALLY HAVE
TO HAVE A GREAT EXCHANGE.
THAT BALL HAS TAKEN LONG AWAY
FROM SECOND -- WONG AWAY FROM
SECOND BASE WHERE HE WOULD HAVE
TO RUN TO A -- THROW TO A
RUNNING TARGET AT SHORT.
SCOTT: THAT IS TRUE, HE IS THIRD
FASTEST BEHIND TREA TURNER AND
TIM LOCASTRO.
GOOD CALL.
THIS GUY HAS WHEELS, TOO.
HARRISON BADER WITH TWO OUTS AND
TWO ON FOR THE CARDINALS.
BIG SPOT HERE.
BURNES IS OUT OF THE GAME AND
THE CARDINALS TRY TO POUNCE ON
THE BREWERS' BULLPENS.
GOOD PITCH.
MATT: THIS IS A BIG AT-BAT FOR
HIM.
HE WOULD TALK TO MIKE SHILDT
BEFORE THE GAME AND HE TALKED
ABOUT HARRISON BADER LAYING OFF
THE SLIDER A LITTLE MORE THIS
YEAR AND BE RELAXED IN THE BOX
AND GETTING GOOD PITCHES TO HIT.
HIS CHASE RATE I THINK IS LOWER.
THIS IS A BIG AT-BAT.
THIS COULD ADD SEPARATION IF HE
IS ABLE TO GET A HIT.
A 3-0 LEAD FEELS REALLY BIG.
SCOTT: LAYS UP 97.
MISS THE FIRST MONTH OF THE
SEASON WITH A FOREARM INJURY.
0-2 TODAY.
2-1.
IT IS 3-1.
MATT: YEAH, THIS IS WHERE THEY
WILL PUT THEM ON TO PITCH TO THE
PITCHER.
SCOTT: INTENTIONAL PASS NOW.
MATT: HERE IS THE DIFFERENCE I
THE NATIONALN AND AMERICAN
LEAGUES, DAN, YOU GET A CHANCE
TO PITCH THE PITCHER, OH, I AM
SORRY, THIS IS KNIZNER.
I THAT WE WERE ONTO THE PITCHER,
BUT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE
YOU PITCH AROUND HIM TO PITCH
.218 HITTER I GET A CHANCE TO
GET OUT OF THE MESS.
DAN: NO QUESTION ABOUT IT, AND
IT MAKES IT EASIER.
PARTICULARLY FOR STARTING
PITCHERS.
THERE IS THIS RAGING DEBATE, CAN
YOU PITCH IN EITHER LEAGUE?
THE LINEUPS ARE BOARD DEEP IN
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE, AND THIS
WAS A GOOD MOVE, PARTICULARLY
WITH A YOUNG PITCHER THAT WENT
FIRST AND THIRD, ONE OUT, YOU
FALL BEHIND THREE BALLS AND ONE
STRIKE.
MORE OF A VETERAN-TYPE PITCHER
AND YOU MIGHT LET SOMEONE LIKE
ADAM WAINWRIGHT TRY TO WRIGGLE
OUT OF THAT, BUT THIS IS THE
RIGHT MOVE, GROUNDBALL IS PRETTY
MUCH A FORCED OUT AT ANY BASE.
IT PUTS A LITTLE EXTRA PRESSURE
ON RASMUSSEN TO GET STRIKE ONE,
BUT THIS IS THE RIGHT MOVE.
SCOTT: BAGS FULL OF CARDINALS
FOR KNIZNER.
FIRST PITCH MISSES UPSTAIRS.
MATT: THEN, ARE YOU SURPRISED AT
ALL THE HIGH TARGETS THEY ARE
HOLDING WITH THIS PITCHER?
IT FEELS LIKE HE SET A BALL AS
THE TARGET AND HAS THREE OR FOUR
PITCHES WHERE HE HITS THE TARGET
AND THE CARDINALS HAVE NOT
CHASED.
IT HAS GOT HIM BEHIND IN COUNTS.
DAN: IT SEEMS LIKE HE IS A
FOUR-SEAM GUY UP IN THE ZONE.
THERE IS A BREAKING BALL.
NOT PARTICULARLY GOOD.
88 MILES AN HOUR.
BUT I THINK THE BREWERS THEIR
METRICS, THEY'RE PITCHING AND
RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT,
THEY LIKE GUYS LIKE JOSH HADER
TO THROW THE BALL UP IN THE
STRIKE ZONE.
A DANGEROUS PLACE TO PITCH.
PARTICULARLY NOW, SHADOWS HAVE
SUBSIDED.
IT IS PRETTY MUCH EQUAL GAME AS
FAR AS HITTERS AND PITCHERS.
ANOTHER BREAKING BALL TO FALL
BEHIND IN THE COUNT.
IF YOU ARE KNIZNER RIGHT NOW,
YOU KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO GET A
FASTBALL RIGHT HERE.
MATT: THIS IS A BIG PICTURE
RIGHT HERE.
-- THIS IS A BIG PITCH RIGHT
HERE.
SCOTT: SOME COUNT LEVERAGE FOR
KNIZNER.
BADER, ARENADO AND GOLDSCHMIDT
OUR OWN.
ARE ON.
SENT OUT TO DEEP RIGHT.
GARCIA BACK INTO THE TRACK, AND
HE HAS GOT IT.
EAVE THEM
LOADED IN THE SIXTH.
THEY ARE STILL HANGING ONTO
THEIR 1-0 LEAD FOR JACK FLAHERTY
BACK TO THE MOUND, COMING UP.
♪
>> AHHH!
[CHEERING]
SCOTT: LAST OF THE SIXTH,
CARDINALS UP 1-0.
TED SUZUKI WITH THE SLEEVELESS
ACTION.
BO JACKSON A STUD, BOTH ON THE
GRIDIRON AND BASEBALL DIAMOND.
FRANK THOMAS A BIG, HULKING
FIGURE.
LOOK AT GABE KAPLER WITH THE
TEXAS RANGERS PER NOTICE THE
THEME?
GIVE US YOUR INTIMIDATING LOOK,
MATT HOLLIDAY, A FORCE AT THE
DISH.
I HURRIED ACTUALLY, MATT, AND
HERE IS TYLER O'NEILL SETTING UP
OUR NEXT POLL QUESTION, WHO IS
THE MOST "JACKED" PLAYER IN MLB
TODAY?
AARON JUDGE, GIANCARLO STANTON,
TANNER O'NEILL AND MICHAEL
LORENZEN.
MATT, I HEARD YOU WERE SUCH A
PHYSICAL SPECIMEN GROWING UP
THAT WHEN YOU HIT THREE HOME
RUNS WHEN YOU PLAYED WITH YOUR
FRIENDS, IT ONLY COUNTED AS ONE,
AND YOU HAD TO PLAY QUARTERBACK
FOR BOTH TEAMS IN THE YARD.
IS THAT TRUE?
MATT: [LAUGHTER]
YEAH, THAT IS TRUE.
YOU KNOW, I WAS BIG EARLY.
I WAS THE BIG KID.
I WAS THE KID THAT GOT BIG EDDIE
ENGAGE.
I THINK I WAS AS BIG AS I AM NOW
BY THE TIME I WAS A FRESHMAN IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
I GREW EARLY AND PRETTY BIG.
YEAH, SO SOME OF THAT IS TRUE.
AND WEIGHING IN ON THE POLE, IT
WOULD BE TOUGH TO GO AGAINST
JUDGE, HAVING PLAYED WITH HIM
AND BEEN NEXT TO HIM, AND
KNOWING HOW BIG HE IS.
I WILL TAKE AARON JUDGE IN THIS
ONE.
SCOTT: THAT IS FAIR.
DANIEL VOGELBACH SWINGS THROUGH
THE PITCH FROM CLARITY.
0-2.
MATT 6'2", AND DAN PLESAC, WHO
DO YOU HAVE ON THE BOARD?
DAN: I HAVE TO GO ALONG WITH
JUDGE.
I HAVE BEEN AROUND BASEBALL MOST
OF MY ADULT LIFE, AND I REMEMBER
DOING 30 TEAMS FOR 30 DAYS FOR
MLB NETWORK, AND GOING TO TAMPA,
WHEN AARON JUDGE WALKED OUT OF
THE DUGOUT, VERY RARELY DO I
LOOK AT SOMEONE AND GO, LOOK AT
THE SIZE OF THAT GUY.
HE JUST IMMEDIATELY GETS YOUR
ATTENTION.
HE IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS WHO
WALKS INTO A ROOM AND YOU CANNOT
HELP NOT SEEN HIM.
HE HAS A PRESENCE.
SCOTT: VOGELBACH WITH OPEN REAL
ESTATE IN RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
HE IS HEADING FOR TWO WHAT THEY
STAND OUT DOUBLE TO START THE
SIXTH INNING FOR MILWAUKEE --
248 STAND OUT DOUBLE TO START
THE SIX INNING FOR MILWAUKEE.
MATT: LOOKED LIKE A BREAKING
BALL IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PLATE,
CAUGHT OUT FRONT AND DROVE TO
RIGHT CENTER.IT
WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE IF
THEY GO WITH THE PINCH RUNNER.
THIS COULD BE HUGE.
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT THEY DO
HERE AS THEY THINK ABOUT MOVING
THEM OVER.
-- MOVING HIM OVER.
SCOTT: 24.4 FEET PER SECOND.
NOT THE FLEETEST OF FOOT, MATT.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER A PINCH
RUNNER OR NOT NECESSARILY?
MATT: WELL, I WOULD, ESPECIALLY
IF YOU GET A STRIKEOUT HERE.
YOU THE GUIDE TO SCORE FOR
SECOND ON A SINGLE AGAINST JACK
FLAHERTY.
I WOULD CONSIDER IT IF HE GETS A
PUNCH HERE AND YOU HAVE ONE OUT,
A MAN ON SECOND.
IF YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO CAN
COME AND PLAY FIRST BASE, IT IS
ONLY THE SIXTH INNING, BUT THIS
ONE COULD BE HUGE.
AND YOU GET A CHANCE TO GET TO
CLARITY, WHO IS VERY -- TO JACK
FLAHERTY, WHO IS DIFFICULT.
IT MIGHT BE AN IMPORTANT BASE
RUNNER.
SCOTT: SAHW HAS BEEN THERE --
SHAW HAS BEEN THEIR BEST BAT IN
THE SERIES.
DOUBLED HIS FIRST TIME UP AND
POPPED OUT DAN: IN THE DAN:
FOURTH.
WHAT GOOD PITCHERS DO, THEY HAVE
MADE SOME REALLY GOOD PITCHERS.
THIS MAY HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE
BEST FASTBALL'S HE'S BALLGAME.
96 MILES AN HOUR, DOWN AND AWAY.
TRAVIS SHAW CAN DEAL WITH THAT
ONE.
MATT: IT JUST LOOKS LIKE HIS
CONCENTRATION HAS INCREASED
EVERY TIME THEY HAVE A RUNNER AT
SCORING POSITION.
IT LOOKS LIKE HIS EXECUTION OF
PITCHES HAS GOTTEN SHARPER.
SCOTT: SHAW GOES FISHING.
VOGELBACH HANGING OUT AT SECOND.
DAN: MIKE SHILDT TOLD US BEFORE
THE GAME THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
HE MARVELED ABOUT JACK FLAHERTY
IS HIS ABILITY TO STEP IT UP
WHEN NEEDED.
HE SAYS YOU WILL SEE HIM
CRUISING AROUND 92, 93 MILES AN
HOUR, BUT THERE IS RESERVE IN
THE TANK WHEN HE NEEDS IT.
HE CAN GET IT TO 96.
A GREAT SEQUENCE OF PITCHES TO
TRAVIS SHAW, STARTING HIM OFF
WITH 96 MILES AN HOUR FASTBALLS
AND THEN THE CURVEBALL, SO WE
HAVE SEEN A LITTLE OF EVERYTHING
FROM JACK FLAHERTY.
SCOTT: GARCIA HOMERED YESTERDAY.
I SAW HIM IN A PREGAME VIDEO,
TALKING TO HISBAT, CALLING HE
WOULD HOMER IN THE GAME.
HE DID.
I LOVE THE LIGHTS ON, LIGHTS OFF
ACTION AFTER THE HOME RUN IN
MILWAUKEE.
THAT PUT THE GAME AWAY IN THE
LATE STAGES FOR THE BREW CREW.
THEY SPLIT THE SERIES, THESE
TWO.
THIS IS THE RUBBER MATCH BEFORE
THEY HAD THEIR SEPARATE WAYS.
AVISAIL GARCIA IS ON FIRE IN THE
MONTH OF MAY.
MATT: THAT WAS A BIG BOY BOMB.
THAT IS GOING PRETTY DEEP BACK
IN THERE, SO THAT WAS A HANGING
SLIDER, AND HE DID NOT MISS IT.
THAT WAS FULL BARRELED RIGHT
THERE.
SCOTT: 442 FEET FOR GARCIA LAST
NIGHT.
WHAT WAS YOUR BEST DISTANCE,
MATT?
DO YOU KNOW IT OFF THE TOP OF
YOUR HEAD?
MATT: I DO NOT KNOW IT OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD.
I DO NOT KNOW.
I HIT A FEW IN COLORADO BEFORE
THEY HAD ALL THE TRACK MAN
STUFF.
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT MY RECORD WAS
FOR THE LONGEST HOME RUN.
I HIT A FEW IN THE HOME RUN
DERBY THAT WENT FAR.
I AM NOT QUITE SURE.
SCOTT: FLAHERTY QUICKLY AHEAD,
0-2.
DAN: 97.
MATT: HE IS MAKING SOME PITCHES,
DAN.
DAN: HE IS, AND THERE IS A
REASON WHY THE CARDINALS THINK A
LONG LINE OF GREAT PITCHERS WHO
HAVE PUT ON THE UNIFORM, THEY
THINK HE IS AS GREAT AS ANY.
A LOT OF TEAMS TALK ABOUT WE
THROW THAT WORD AROUND LIKE TRUE
ACES, BUT HE REALLY IS.
THERE MAY BE 10 TO 12 AND ALL OF
BASEBALL, BUT YOU ARE LOOKING AT
ONE RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT: CHOPPED LEFT SIDE.
SECOND OUT EDMAN.
MLB FOOD FIGHT PRESENTED BY
MASTERCARD.
IT WILL DETERMINE WHICH BALLPARK
FOOD IS THE BEST.
FILL OUT YOUR BRACKET AT
MLB.COM/FOODFIGHT TODAY.
DAN: I WOULD LIKE TO GET IN ON
SOME OF THAT ACTION.
SCOTT: WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR?
DAN: I AM A BIG FAN OF, THE
CHICAGO WHITE SOX.
I AM ALL INTO THAT ITALIAN
SAUSAGE THING WITH SOME FRENCH
FRIES AT A BALLGAME WITH AN
ADULT BEVERAGE.
COUNT ME IN ON THAT.
A LITTLE YELLOW MUSTARD.
I AM NOT INTO THE WHOLE ONIONS
AND PEPPERS ECHO ON THE HOTDOG
OR SAUERKRAUT.
BUT GIVE ME A GOOD HOTDOG,
ITALIAN SAUSAGE/BRAT WITH YELLOW
MUSTARD AND I AM ALL IN.
SCOTT: HOME RUN.
THE PITCHES TAKEN DOWN.
MATT, YOUR WEAPON OF CHOICE AT
THE TABLE?
JOIN THE SPREAD IN THE CLUBHOUSE
WHERE THE BALLPARK IF YOU
VENTURED ANYWHERE?
MATT: YOU KNOW, I THINK THE
SMELL OF THE GARLIC FRIES IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
I'M NOT SURE I HAVE HAD ANY, BUT
DURING BATTING PRACTICE WHEN
THEY CRANK THOSE OUT, IT IS A
PRETTY INVITING SMELL.
I HAVE TO GIVE IT TO THEM FOR
THAT.
SCOTT: I AM WITH YOU.
NARVAEZ TAKES A SIMILAR HIT,
SIMILAR SPOT.
I HAVE YOUR LONGEST HOME RUN,
MATT, IN THIS STATCAST TIME
PERIOD GOING BACK TO 2015.
I KNOW YOU HAD LONG DRIVES
BEFORE THAT, BUT 466.
NOT TOO SHABBY.
MATT: YEAH, THAT IS NOT TOO BAD.
NOT TOO BAD.
I THINK I MAY HAVE HAD A FEW
EARLIER IN MY CAREER SCOTT: THAT
WENT EARLIER.
SCOTT:I AGREE, BASED ON THE EYE
TEST AND WATCHING YOU FOR THOSE
YEARS IN COLORADO.
MATT: INTERESTING SPOT, DAN,
WITH THE 2-0 COUNT DINA TYING
RUN ON SECOND.
IF HE REALLY TRIES TO PITCH
AROUND HIM OR POTENTIALLY PUT
HIM ON, BUT HE IS DEFINITELY
BEHIND THE COUNT TO A GUY WHO IS
SWINGING THE BAT REALLY WELL.
DAN: THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS,
MATT, YOU SEE GENESIS CABRERA
WARMING UP IN THE BULLPEN.
THEY HAVE JACKIE BRADLEY JR. ON
THE ON-DECK CIRCLE.
SCOTT: DRIVE TO DEEP CENTER AND
BADER BACKING UP.
HE HAS GOT SOME ROOM.
AT SITS DOWN THE SIDE.
LONG DRIVE THE BAT OF OMAR
NARVAEZ, BUT JACK FLAHERTY
WORKING MAGIC.
1-0 AFTER SIX.
♪
>> HAD, I AM CHIP CAREY, MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL ANNOUNCER.
>> I AM SKIP CARAY, MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL ANNOUNCER.
>> AND I AM HARRY CARAY, MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL ANNOUNCER.
>> THAT WAS A FUN DAY.
MY GRANDFATHER, WHO STARTED IN
1945, I DAD, STARTED IN 1976,
AND THEN ME, WHO STARTS IN 1991,
ALL ALMOST 25 YEARS APART, ALL
DOING THE SAME GAME IN THE SAME
TOWN AND AT THE SAME TIME.
>> RUNNER HEADS FOR THIRD.
GOES TO FIRST.
HE MIGHT HAVE HAD A PLAY AT
THIRD BASE, BUT HRABOSKY.
>> HE GETS A SACRIFICE OUT OF
HIM, THROWN OUT.
>> LET'S SEE IF HE SLIPPED WHEN
HE MADE THE PLAY.
>> OUT OF ALL THE THINGS THAT
HAVE HAPPENED TO ME IN 50 YEARS
IN BROADCASTING, THIS IS THE
THING I AM PROUDEST OF BECAUSE
THIS IS MY FAMILY.
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE SEVENTH IN
MILWAUKEE, ONE-ZERO CARDINALS.
THE MLB DRAFT COMBINE WILL BE A
NEW EVENT, SIMILAR LIKE OTHER
PRO SPORTS LIKE NFL AND NBA, AND
WILL FEATURE THREE MAIN
COMPONENTS.
ON-FIELD WORK OUT FIELD TESTING
AND EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING.
IT IS STRUCTURED TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEDIA OUTLETS
LIKE MLB NETWORK AND CREATE NEW
CONTENT TO PROMOTE THE DRAFT.
THIS IS COOL.
MATT, YOU ARE A COACH AT
OKLAHOMA STATE.
BIG W OVER OKLAHOMA YESTERDAY,
BUT ALSO I KNOW THERE ARE
PLAYERS ON YOUR SQUAD WHO HAVE
BEEN INVITED TO ATTEND THE
COMBINE.
MATT: YEAH, THAT IS EXCITING.
I THINK IT HAS BEEN KIND OF, YOU
ARE SURPRISED THEY HAVE NOT GONE
TO IT SOONER WITH ALL THE
COMBINES IN THE OTHER LEAGUES,
SO IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE.
IT WILL BE COOL TO SEE HOW IT
HELPS THEM LEAD UP TO THE DRAFT
AND YOU GET CONTENT ON THE
PLAYERS.
WE HAVE A THIRD BASEMAN NAMED
CHRISTIAN ENCARNACION WHO GOT
INVITED, A STRONG THIRD BASEMAN.
I THINK HE HAS GOT 15 HOME RUNS.
HE IS ONE OF THE LEADERS IN
R.B.I.'S, SO HE WILL BE FUN TO
WATCH.
I'M TRACKING THAT.
AND WE HAVE A PITCHER INVITED TO
THAT, SO WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
GUYS WHO COULD GO INTO THAT.
MAKE SURE YOU CHECK THAT OUT.
SCOTT: IT IS THE WEEK OF JUNE 21
IN NORTHJUSTIN WILLIAMS IS A PIH
HITTER, SO NEW MAN COMING IN,
BRENT SUTER.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT!
>> MY GOODNESS.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> AND THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO!
>> THAT BALL IS CRUSHED.
>> AND THIS IS GOING TO DO IT!
OH MY!
>> STRIKE THREE.
THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
HE TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS, THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: BRENT SUTER PORES AND A
STRIKE AGAINST JUSTIN WILLIAMS,
PINCH HITTER, AND TYRONE TAYLOR
REPLACING AVISAIL GARCIA.
A1-ZERO GAME IN MILWAUKEE.
TIGHT SERIES, ESPECIALLY THE
EARLY PARTS OF THE GAMES WITH
OUTSTANDING STARTING PITCHING.
WE SAW AGAIN TODAY.
SUTER WORKS FAST.
YOU LOVE TO SEE IT, AS HE COMES
IN AND MAKES HIS FIRST
APPEARANCE AFTER BEING PLACED ON
THE BEREAVEMENT LIST LAST
SATURDAY.
LAST PITCH WAS A START ON FRIDAY
AT MIAMI.
DAN: SUTER IS VERY VERSATILE.
CRAIG COUNSELL LIKE SOME BECAUSE
FOR THE MOST PART, HE IS A
STRIKER.
HE IS A THROWBACK TO A GUY WHO
WOULD PITCH THE 1980'S OR 1930'S
WITH AQUA DELIVERY AND NOT
OVERPOWERING.
87 TO 89 MILES-PER-HOUR.
HIS BREAKING BALL IS KIND OF
SQUARELY.
FOR SOME REASON, I HAD A CHANCE
TO TALK TO A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THE RULERS CAP A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, AND THEY FEEL HE IS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO HIT.
HE DOES NOT HAVE ONE PARTICULAR
PITCH THAT HE RELIES ON.
HE IS A LITTLE DECEPTIVE AND
FUNKY.
SCOTT: AND HE WALKS WILLIAMS,
THE PINCH HITTER LEADS OFF THE
SEVENTH FOR ST. LOUIS.
WE WILL GO BACK TO THE TOP OF
THE ORDER IN TOMMY EDMAN.
DAN: IT IS SO IMPORTANT NOW,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU START WITH
RELIEVERS WITH THE THREE-BAGGER
MINIMUM, THE DAY AND AGE OF
HAVING THAT SPECIALTY RELIEVER
FOR THE EIGHTH OR NINTH, YOU
HAVE TO MAKE SURE IF YOU ARE A
MANAGER AND YOU GO TO THAT GUY,
THAT HE IS ABLE TO GET RIGHTIES
AND LEFTIES OUT.
PAT MURPHY TAKING OVER.
CRAIG COUNSELL WAS GIVEN THE HE
HOE EARLIER AND THIS ONE, SO
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR LEFTIES TO
GET RIGHTIES AND LEFTIES OUT.
SCOTT: SWITCH HITTER TOMMY EDMAN
FIRST TO CHECK OVER AT FIRST.
" FOR JUSTIN WILLIAMS.
-- CLOSE CALL FOR JUSTIN
WILLIAMS.
MATT: YEAH, IT HAS CHANGED THE
LEFTIES A LOT.
YOU TALK ABOUT HAVING A PITCH
THAT CAN GET RIGHTIES OUT, AS
WELL.
SCOTT: BREWERS WAITING TO MAKE
SURE THEY SHOULD NOT CHALLENGE
THIS CALL.
AND SUTER BACK TO THE MOUND NOW.
DAN: CHRISTIAN YELICH SITTING
THERE WITH THE BAT IN HIS HAND.
SCOTT: HE WILL BE IN NASHVILLE
THIS WEEKEND FOR SOME A.B.'S.
DAN: MIGHT HAVE TO MAKE A TRIP
DOWN TO NASHVILLE AND WATCH
CHRISTIAN YELICH.
KRISTIN HARRAH.
SCOTT: MUSIC CITY.
DAN: NASHVILLE HAS ALWAYS TALKED
ABOUT ONE OF THE POTENTIAL SITES
OF EXPANSION.
WE HEAR NASHVILLE, LAS VEGAS,
PORTLAND, OREGON.
POSSIBLY BACK UP TO MONTRÉAL.
MONTRÉAL WAS A GREAT BASEBALL
CITY.
SCOTT: ALSO, IF YOU ARE IN
NASHVILLE, DAN, HEAD OVER TO
VANDERBILT UNIVERSITY AND SEE
TWO OF THE TOPICS COMING UP IN
THE MLB DRAFT.
WILLIAMS STAYS PUT.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES THE COUNT
TO EDMAN.
MATT: I GOT A CHANCE TO SEE BOTH
OF THOSE GUYS UP CLOSE.
WE PLAYED A THREE-GAME SERIES
HERE IN STILLWATER AGAINST
VANDERBILT.
I GOT A GOOD LOOK FROM THE FIRST
BASE COACH INBOX AT JACK LEITER
AND IT WAS NOT THAT FUN FOR OUR
HITTERS.
DAN: LET ME ASK YOU, MATT, WHEN
YOU WATCHED THEM THROW, COULD
YOU SEE WHITE SCOUTS AND
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SO HIGH ON
BOTH OF THESE GUYS?
MATT: YOU KNOW, IT WAS VERY
OBVIOUS, DAN, YOU TALK ABOUT
KUMAR AND HOW BIG AND PHYSICAL
HE IS, THAT NIGHT HE WAS
THROWING A SLIDER FOR STRIKES,
FOR CHASE.
HE WAS LOCATING A FASTBALL
BETWEEN 95 AND 97.HE LOOKED LIKE
A BIG-LEAGUE PICTURE
TCHER.
SCOTT: BREWERS GET THE FORCE AT
SECOND TO GET RID OF WILLIAMS
AND EDMAN BEATS IT OUT AT FIRST.
MATT: YEAH, TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, DAN, IT WAS PRETTY FUN
TO WATCH TWO OF THOSE YOUNG GUYS
AND THE STUFF THEY HAD.
LEITER WAS A LITTLE
SMALLER IN STATURE BUT HAD AN
ELECTRIC FASTBALL.
I AM NOT SURPRISED THEY ARE
BEING TALKED ABOUT FOR TOP FIVE
PICKS.
SHOULD BE AN INTERESTING DRAFT.
LIKE I SAID, THAT NIGHT, KUMAR
COULD PITCH IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUES.
I'M CONVINCED OF THAT WHERE HE
LOCATED HIS PITCHES.
SCOTT: ONE IS DROPPED INTO RIGHT
FIELD FOR A BASE HIT.
EDMAN BRACING AROUND TO THIRD
AND HE IS IN THERE.
THAT WILL SET UP RUNNERS ON THE
CORNERS FOR ST. LOUIS.
DYLAN CARLSON ATTACKING THE
FIRST PITCH HE SAW FROM BRENT
SUTER.
MATT: LOOKS LIKE A LITTLE
FASTBALL IN, STAY INSIDE IT, AND
FOUND A HOME TO RIGHT FIELD.
GREAT FIRST TO THIRD BASE
RUNNING.
THAT IS A GREAT PLAY BY TOMMY
EDMAN.
SCOTT: PUTTING THE PRESSURE ON
SUTER IN THE SEVENTH WITH THE
BIG BOYS COMING UP, GOLDSCHMIDT
AND ARENADO ON-DECK.
MATT: SUTER HAS GOT TO TRY TO
GET A GROUNDBALL, DAN, WORK BALL
DOWN AND AWAY.
MAYBE A CHANGEUP DOWN AND AWAY
AND ON THE GROUND.
DAN: NOT EASY TO DO.
HE HAS A PRETTY GOOD IDEA OF
WHAT SUTER IS GOING TO TRY TO
DO.
HE IS GOING TO TRY TO PICK A
PITCHER HE COULD GET AT MINIMUM
SOMETHING IN THE AIR.
GOLDSCHMIDT COULD TAKE THAT
CHANGE UP OR SINKER AWAY AND HIT
IT DEEP ENOUGH TO RIGHT FIELD.
SCOTT: YOUR SAC FLY LINE BASED
ON THE THROWING ARM STRENGTH.
THERE IT IS FROM THE THREE
OUTFIELDERS, TYRONE TAYLOR, BEST
ARM OUT THERE.
J.B.J. IN LEFT, KEYNAN CENTER --
CAIN AT CENTER.
FOULED.
GOLDSCHMIDT HAS THE BEST NUMBERS
EVER AT THIS BALLPARK OF ANY
PLAYER THAT HAS BEEN HERE AT
AMERICAN FAMILY FIELD, HIS OPS
ENTERING TODAY 11.85.
MATT: SO HE IS FEELING PRETTY
GOOD.
I THINK HE IS FEELING GOOD ABOUT
HIS SITUATION.
SCOTT: THERE IS YOUR CHANCE,
LORENZO CAIN LINES IT UP, TOSSES
HOME.
EDMAN BRACING IN,
THAT THROW HIS MONEY!
-- EDMAN RACING IN AND THE THROW
HIS MONEY!
MATT: WHAT A THROW.
SCOTT: ULTIMATE ACCURACY FROM
LORENZO CAIN.
MATT: INCREDIBLE JOB OF GETTING
BEHIND IT AND WORKING HIS BODY
THROUGH IT TO MAKE THAT KIND OF
THROW.
SCOTT: THE SECOND TIME THE
BREWERS HAVE DONE THIS TODAY.
ONE FROM CAIN JUST NOW AND
EARLIER IN THE DAY, URIAS
GUNNING DOWN A RUNNER AT HOME.
LOOK AT LORENZO CAIN.
PERFECTLY PLACED FOR NARVAEZ IN
STRIDE.
HE CANNOT AVOID HIM.
THIS GAME REMAINS 1-0, ST.
LOUIS.
LET'S STRETCH.
♪
>> BATTING THIRD AND PLAYING
FIRST BASE FROM THE ST. LOUIS
CARDINALS, ALBERT PUJOLS.
>> ALBERT PUJOLS IS GOING TO GO
DOWN AS ONE OF THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE HITTERS IN MAJOR
LEAGUE HISTORY.
>> BASE HIT, PUJOLS.
HIS FIRST HIT IN THE BIG
LEAGUES.
>> FIRST CAREER BIG-LEAGUE HOME
RUN.
AFTER WATCHING THIS KID AT
BATTING PRACTICE AND THAT SWING
RIGHT THERE, IT WILL NOT BE THE
LAST.
>> HE HAS THE BIGGEST START IN
HIS CAREER AT ST. LOUIS.
>> YOU CAN SEE ALBERT PUJOLS!
>> 414 HOME RUNS IN HIS FIRST
THREE MAJOR LEAGUE SEASONS, THE
MOST EVER!
>> IN THE AIR, LEFT FIELD, AND
GIVES ST. LOUIS THE LEAD.
STUNNED DISBELIEF HERE IN
HOUSTON.
>> THE CARDINALS ARE THE WORLD
CHAMPIONS FOR 2006.
>> NUMBER 400 FOR ALBERT PUJOLS.
>> PUJOLS IS THE FASTEST EVER TO
400, AND ALBERT PUJOLS HAS TIED
REGGIE JACKSON WITH THREE HOME
RUNS IN GAME THREE.
THE CARDINALS ARE WORLD CHAMPS
IN 2011.
SCOTT: STRONG PULL QUESTION
LITERALLY.
BICEPS, LET'S SHOW IT OFF, THE
BOTTOM OF THE SEVENTH, CARDINALS
UP 1-0.
THE MOST JACK PLAYER IN MLB
TODAY -- THE MOST "JACKED"
PLAYER IN MLB TODAY, TYLER
O'NEILL, ST. LOUIS CARDINALS
FANS WAITING IN AND STANTON
FINISHES IN SECOND.
O'NEILL IS A BIG, STRONG MAN.
HE CAN RUN, A SUPERPOWERFUL WITH
THE  BAT SPEED, AND HE WINS
THE POLE TODAY.
HIS FATHER, TERRY, WAS A PRO
BODYBUILDER.
HE IS PROBABLY STRONGER THAN
TYLER, AS GIOVANNI --
GIOVANNY GALLEGOS TAKES OVER ON
THE MOUND FOR ST. LOUIS.
DAN: ONE OF THE REASONS ST.
LOUIS ARE TOP OF THE LIST RIGHT
NOW, THE THEY HAVE A REALLY,
REALLY GOOD BULLPEN.
THE BREWERS MAY HAVE MORE
HOUSEHOLD NAMES BUT REYES HAS
BEEN TERRIFIC, AND THIS GUY HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS OUT GETTER.
IF THE CARDINALS' BULLPEN
CONTINUES TO PITCH LIKE THIS THE
REST OF THE WAY, THIS LOOKS LIKE
TWO TEAMS ARE GOING TO DO GET
OUT.
THE CARDINALS ON THE BREWERS.
I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
TWO BEST TEAMS IN THE CENTRAL
RIGHT NOW, SCOTT.
SCOTT: 29-YEAR-OLD GALLEGOS
FACING JACKIE BRADLEY, JUNIOR.
LAST PITCHED ON TUESDAY AGAINST
MILWAUKEE.
SCORELESS INNINGS.
27 PITCHES.
SECOND PITCH TO BRADLEY.
IT IS A STRIKE.
MATT: HE HAS GOT A REALLY GOOD
SLIDER.
I THINK HIS FASTBALL CAN GET TO
THE MID-90'S.
HIS SLIDER HAS A DOWNWARD DEPTH
THAN A SIDE-TO-SIDE.
HE CAN PITCH OFF IT, THROW FOR
STRIKES, BUT HE CAN ALSO.
FOR STRIKEOUTS.
HE DOES HAVE A FASTBALL THAT HE
CAN KEEP HITTERS HONEST WITH.
SCOTT: SLIDER CATCHES THE EDGE
OF THE ZONE FOR STRIKE TWO.
DAN: YOU KNOW IN THIS DAY AND
AGE, SCOTT, ESPECIALLY OF THE 60
GAME SEASON LAST YEAR, WHERE THE
DEPTH OF EVERY TEAM IS GOING TO
BE CAST, PARTICULARLY AT THE
PITCHING LEVEL, MINOR LEAGUE
SEASON LAST YEAR VIRTUALLY WAS
NO SEASON, SO A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONS NOT SURE HOW MUCH
DEPTH THEY HAVE AVAILABLE AND
READY AT THE BIG-LEAGUE LEVEL.
BULLPENS ARE BEING LEANED ON
MORE AND MORE EARLY.
YOU REALLY HAVE TO RESIST THE
TEMPTATION IF YOU ARE CRAIG
COUNSELL OR MIKE SHILDT TO GO TO
THE BULLPEN EARLY, PARTICULARLY
IN APRIL AND MAY.
YOU WILL PAY THE PRICE IN JULY
AND AUGUST.
LOOKS LIKE BOTH OF THESE TEAMS
WILL PLAY MEANINGFUL GAMES.
I DON'T THINK MIKE SHILDT THAT'S
ENOUGH CREDIT FOR THE JOB HE'S
DONE.
HE HAS BEEN AN ORGANIZATIONAL
GUY FOR THE CARDINALS, GREAT
FEEL FOR HIS TEAM, WHAT HIS
PLAYERS CAN DO, PUTTING HIS
PLAYERS THAT GOOD SPOTS.
LOOKING AT TWO OF THE BEST
MANAGERS IN THE GAME TODAY.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE CHASE.
GALLEGOS PICKS UP THE STRIKEOUT
TO START OFF THE SEVENTH, FACING
THE BOTTOM THREE IN THE LINEUP.
MATT: YOU TALK ABOUT MIKE
SHILDT, I THINK THE THING THAT
REALLY STANDS OUT TO ME IS THE
RELATIONSHIPS THIS GUY HAS, AND
HIS ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE AND
BUILD RELATIONSHIPS WITH HIS
PLAYERS.
HE IS A TREMENDOUS MAN.
SCOTT: SWING AND MISS FROM
BRADLEY.
MIKE SHILDT 2019 MANAGER OF THE
YEAR.
THE ONLY CURRENT MANAGER WHO
NEVER PLAYED PRO BASEBALL, BUT A
GREAT BASEBALL MIND.
MATT: HE HAS DONE PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING IN BASEBALL.
HE HAS MANAGED.
HE'S BEEN A HITTING COACH, FIELD
COORDINATOR.
HE HAS DONE ALMOST ANYTHING YOU
COULD POSSIBLY DO INSIDE OF A
SYSTEM, SO WHEN HE GOT THE JOB
AS MANAGER, HE SEES THINGS FROM
A LOT OF DIFFERENT POINTS OF
VIEW, WHICH I THINK IS AN
ADVANTAGE.
SCOTT: HE WAS EVEN A HIGH SCHOOL
COACH IN 1994, 1995, 1996.
ONE DOWN.
URIAS.
POPPED UP.
CARPENTER FOR THE SECOND OUT.
SO, MANAGERS TO REACH THE
POSTSEASON HAVING NEVER PLAYED
IN THE MAJORS OR MINORS, THIS
LIST IS JUST THREE.
WE ARE GOING WAY BACK FOR THE
OTHER TWO, DAN.
DO YOU REMEMBER "PANTS" ROLAND?
DAN: NO IDEA, BUT I LIKE THE
LOOK AND HAT.
SCOTT: ED BARROW.
I LIKE IT.
WORLD SERIES WINNERS IN 2017 AND
2018 -- 1917 AND 1918.
THEN YOU GO FURTHER DOWN THE
LINE.
IT TOOK A SENTRY TO PRODUCE A
MANAGER WITH THAT TRACK RECORD.
MANAGER OF THE YEAR IN 2019
JOINING OTHER MANAGERS, BIG
NAMES, IN CARDINALS HISTORY.
MATT: QUITE A FEAT, A TESTAMENT
TO HIM AND ALL HE HAS DONE IN
BASEBALL AND THE ORGANIZATION
GIVING A GUY LIKE MIKE SHILDT AN
OPPORTUNITY.
GIVING AN ORGANIZATIONAL GUY,
WHO HAS DONE EVERYTHING IN THE
ORGANIZATION AND HAS EARNED IT.
HE EARNED HIS WAY UP.
HE STARTED AT THE BOTTOM AND
EARNED HIS WAY UP FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MANAGE AT THE
MAJOR LEAGUE LEVEL AND HAS DONE
A TREMENDOUS JOB.
HIS RIGHT-HAND MAN, OLIVER
MONTMARTRE, A CLOSE FRIEND OF
MINE, A STUD OF A COACH,
SOMEBODY WHO KNOWS BASEBALL, AND
I KNOW THEY ARE VERY CLOSE AND
BOUNCE IDEAS OFF OF EACH OTHER.
I THINK THEY HAVE A GREAT TANDEM
OF MANAGER AND THE REST OF THEIR
STAFF, I AM FAMILIAR WITH, AS
WELL, AND THEY DO A TREMENDOUS
JOB.
THEY SPEND A TON OF TIME
PREPARING AND MAKING SURE
PLAYERS ARE PUT IN THE BEST
POSITION TO WIN.
SCOTT: WE HAD A LOT OF FUN WITH
MIKE THIS MORNING ON OUR VIDEO
CONFERENCE CALL.
TYRONE TAYLOR LAYS OFF THAT
1-1 PITCH.
DAN: WHAT WAS INTERESTING ON THE
CALL, WE ASKED HIM HOW MUCH
ANALYTICS PLAY INTO IT.
HE SAYS THEY GIVE THEIR
INFORMATION TO THE PLAYERS, BUT
THEY DO NOT WANT THEM TO BE
OVERLOADED.
SOME PLAYERS LIKE MORE
INFORMATION THAN OTHERS.
THE KEY IS INDIVIDUALLY.
LIKE GIVE THE INFORMATION WHEN
IT IS THERE, THEY ARE RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT, AND THEIR
ANALYTIC DEPARTMENT IS KEEN ON
WHAT THEY ARE DOING, BUT IT IS
NOT THE END-ALL BE-ALL.
MIKE HAS FOUND A NICE BALANCE,
THE RIGHT BALANCE, TO MAKE HIS
PLAYERS FEEL COMFORTABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT THOUGH BUT NOT
JAM IT DOWN THEIR THROAT IF THEY
DO NOT WANT -- THAT INFO BUT NOT
DON'T WANT TO.
MATT: THAT IS A GOOD POINT.
AS A PLAYER, THERE ARE CERTAIN
INFORMATION I FIND
BENEFICIAL, BUT THERE ARE
CERTAIN INFORMATION I DO NOT
KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH IT.
BESIDES JUST KEEPING IT SIMPLE
TO WHAT WORKS FOR ME, I THINK
THERE IS A BALANCE OF FINDING
HOW TO USE THAT INFORMATION AND
BLENDING A LITTLE BIT OF OLD
SCHOOL AND NEW SCHOOL THOUGHT.
SCOTT: NICELY PLACED SLIDER BY
GALLEGOS TO LOAD UP THE COUNT
AGAINST TYRONE TAYLOR, WHO JUST
CHECKED INTO THE GAME IN RIGHT
FIELD THE LAST HAPPENING.
BALL FOUR.
DOWN A RUN IN THE SEVENTH.
AND IT STARTS AT THE TOP HERE,
FOR THE CARDINALS, JOHN MOZELIAK
HAS BEEN WITH THIS ORGANIZATION
FOR A LONG TIME, PROMOTED TO
PRESIDENT OF BASEBALL OPERATIONS
IN 2017.
HE  WAS THE SENIOR VPAND GM
NAMED IN OCTOBER 2000 7, 8
POSTSEASON APPEARANCES, SCOUTING
DIRECTOR BACK IN THE LATE
1990'S, PART OF THE DRAFTING OF
ALBERT PUJOLS AND YADI MOLINA.
THAT WORKED OUT PRETTY WELL.
THIS FRANCHISE HAS DONE A TON OF
WINNING.
12 POSTSEASON APPEARANCES FROM
2015, INCLUDING FOUR WORLD
SERIES APPEARANCES AND TWO
RINGS.
GET THE JOB DONE OUT IN THE
MIDWEST.
DAN: THEY DO, BUT I THINK A LOT
OF IT IS THE CONTINUITY WITHIN
THE ORGANIZATION.
THERE ISN'T A LOT OF CHANGE.
THEY BELIEVE IN THE SYSTEM THEY
HAVE.
THEY ARE NOT QUICK TO FIRE
MANAGERS OR GENERAL MANAGERS.
THEY BELIEVE IN THEIR PEOPLE,
THEY LET THEIR BASEBALL PEOPLE,
THERE BASEBALL OPS DO THEIR
JOBS.
THEY DON'T YOU A LOT OF
MEDDLING.
I THINK JOHN MOZELIAK KNOWS WHAT
HE KNOWS AND KNOWS WHAT HE DOES
NOT KNOW, AND DELEGATES
AUTHORITY TO PEOPLE AROUND HIM.
THAT IS WHY IT HAS WORKED.
SCOTT: HE DRAFTED KOLTEN WONG,
AS WELL, WHO FLIES OUT TO RIGHT.
CARLSON MAKES THE GRAB ANDONE ON
IN FAVOR OF THE CARDINALS.
THROUGH SEVEN.
>> TELL YOU WHAT, THESE COLORS
ARE FIRE, LITTLE BRO.
I LIKE THESE COLORS.
YES.
THEY BROUGHT THAT NEW COLOR,
LIKE OK.
EVERY TIME I PUT ON CLEATS, MY
FEET FEEL SO HEAVY.
I AM WEARING LOW TOPPER.
I WAS THINKING OF GOING OTHERS
BUT YOU CAN'T CUSTOMIZE THEM.
IT IS ALL ABOUT THE LOOK.
HEY!
OH!
NEED TO GET IN THAT CAGE NOW AND
GET SOME WORK IN.
RIGHT HERE, SIR.
LET ME CHECK ONE OUT REAL QUICK.
OH!
I'M GOING TO FIND A BARREL
PRETTY SOON.
OH YEAH.
THAT IS WHAT I WANTED.
SCOTT: NOLAN ARENADO WILL LEAD
OUT THE EIGHTH FOR ST. LOUIS.
HE HAS SHOT FOR THE M.O. BECAME
OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME TITLE.
BYRON BUXTON, DREW SMYLY HAVE
ONE SO FAR.
PICKING UP A TROPHY WITH THEIR
NAME ENGRAVED AND THE YOUTUBE
PLAY BUTTON.
VERY, VERY NICELY DONE, AND THE
PLAYERS LOVE IT.
WE CHAT WITH THEM AFTER THE
GAME, BUT IT IS ALL DECIDED BY
YOU.
POLLING WILL BE POPPING UP SOON.
YOU WILL PICK THE WINNER, AND WE
WILL TALK TO THAT PLAYER AFTER
THE GAME AS BRENT SUTER GETS
RIGHT BACK TO WORK AGAINST
ARENADO, FACING 4, 5, 6 FOR
THE CARDINALS IN THE EIGHTH.
ANOTHER KNOCK FOR ARENADO.
THREE HITS ON THE DAY.
DAN: THREE KNOCKS ON THE DAY,
THE CARDINALS SCORED EARLY IN
THE FIRST INNING.
CORBIN BURNES FINALLY WALKED A
HITTER.
FIVE INNINGS FOR CORBIN BURNES,
ONE WALK, NINE STRIKEOUTS.
NOT TOO BAD.
58 TO ONE STRIKEOUT TO WALK
RATIO ON THE YEAR.
58 STRIKEOUTS, ONE WALK FOR
CORBIN BURNES SO FAR THIS
SEASON.
SCOTT: THAT WILL PLAY.
MATT: WELL, IT WOULD NOT HURT MY
FEELINGS IF ARENADO WINS PLAYER
OF THE GAME.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO CATCH UP
WITH MY BUDDY AND TALK TO NOLAN.
YEAH, HE HAS GOT TO BE THE FRONT
RUNNER, ALTHOUGH JACK FLAHERTY'S
SIXTH SHUTOUT INNINGS IN PRETTY
GOOD, TOO.
SCOTT: THE FANS WILL DECIDE,
NOLAN ARENADO WITH THE SEASON
HIGH, THREE BASE HITS IN HIS
FOUR TRIPS TO THE PLATE.
HE IS FOLLOWED BY CARPENTER, ONE
FOR THREE TODAY.
THE LOAN RUN.
MATT: IS THAT A REAL TROPHY?
SCOTT: THAT IS A REAL TROPHY,
MATT.
I KNOW ALL ABOUT IT.
MATT: NICE.
SCOTT: IT IS GOING TO BE IN THE
HANDS OF THE WINNER, AND THEN
THEY WILL ENGRAVE THEIR NAME, A
LITTLE CUSTOM ACTION, AND SEND
IT TO THEM TO PUT IN THE TROPHY
ROOM.
IT IS VERY UNIQUE.
MATT: AWESOME.
SCOTT: A WEEKLY RITUAL HERE,
LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
CARPENTER FOULS THAT ONE OFF.
0-2 AGAINST SUTER.
J.P. MOROSI IS AT THE BALLPARK
WATCHING BRENT SUTER JUST POUR
IN PITCHES AT A RAPID RATE, J.P.
EDMAN HE DOES SCOTT --
J.P.: HE DOES, SCOTT, AND HE IS
ONE OF THE GREAT NICKNAMES IN
BASEBALL, THE RAPTOR BECAUSE OF
HIS UNIQUE DELIVERY. HERE AT
AMERICAN LEAGUE FIELD, THEY PLAY
THE THEME TO JURASSIC PARK FOR
HE TAKES THE MOUND.
THAT WAS HIS ENTRANCE MUSIC.
SUTER A GRADUATE OF HARVARD
UNIVERSITY.
HE MAJORED IN ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENCE AND PUBLIC POLICY, KNOWN
AS ONE OF THE STRONGEST
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES IN THE
BASEBALL FAMILY AND HAS HELPED
THE COMMUNITY IN MILWAUKEE AND
THE BALLPARK, TALKING ABOUT THE
VALUE OF COMPOSTING AND ORGANIC
AND LOCAL FARMS.
TRULY ONE OF THE MOST
INTERESTING PEOPLE IN THE
BASEBALL WORLD.
SCOTT: A 31ST-ROUND PICK BACK IN
2012.
IT HAS WORKED OUT FOR THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
THERE IS THE RAPTOR AT WORK.
[LAUGHTER]
THIS HE HAVE IT DOWN, DAN?
DAN: LOOKS CONVINCING TO ME.
I AM BUYING IT.
SCOTT: [LAUGHTER]
MATT: JUST KIDS PLAYING A GAME.
J.P.: IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN, HE
WAS A CINCINNATI HIGH SCHOOL
GUY, THE POWERHOUSE IN FOOTBALL.
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
SCOTT: I WILL LOOK THAT ONE UP.
DAN: BARRY LARKIN WAS ONE OF
THOSE GUYS.
SCOTT: YOU ARE CORRECT,
CINCINNATI.
SUTER MISSES.
3-2.
J.P., I KNOW YOU HAVE GOT MORE
ON SUTER.
GO FOR IT.
J.P.: YES, OF COURSE.
IN FACT, I CAN CONFIRM, DAN, HE
GRADUATED IN CINCINNATI IN HIGH
SCHOOL, SAME SCHOOL AS BARRY
LARKIN, HALL OF FAMER.
SCOTT: KEN GRIFFEY JR. AN ALUM
FROM THAT SCHOOL, AS WELL.
THAT IS FOULED BACK.
THAT SCHOOL IS STACKED WITH
BASEBALL NAMES, DAVID BELL, AS
WELL, CINCINNATI REDS MANAGER.
CARPENTER AGAINST SUTER, FIVE
FOR 15, A PAIR OF HOME RUNS.
HE HAS ARENADO AT FIRST.
FULL COUNT PITCH FROM THE
RAPTOR.
MISSED.
TWO ON FOR ST. LOUIS TO START
THE EIGHTH.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF COMMISSIONER OF
BASEBALL AND MAY NOT BE
REPRODUCED OR RETRANSMITTED IN
ANY FORM IN THE ACCOUNTS MAY NOT
BE DISSEMINATED WITHOUT
EXPRESSED WRITTEN CONSENT.
MATT: A REALLY GOOD AT-BAT BY
MATT CARPENTER RIGHT THERE.
THAT LEFTY-LEFTY MATCHUP,
GETTING FIRST AND SECOND, NOBODY
OUT SITUATION.
THAT IS A BIG AT-BAT IN THE TOP
OF THE EIGHTH AND LOOKING TO ADD
ON FOR INSURANCE RUNS.
THAT COULD BE PIVOTAL IN MAYBE
GETTING AN INSURANCE RUN OR TWO
HERE.
SCOTT: TYLER O'NEILL HAD A BIG
BAT IN THIS SERIES.
HOMEWARD YESTERDAY AND THE DAY
BEFORE.
CHECKS ON THE FIRST PITCH.
DOES NOT GO AROUND.
MATT, NOW HE HAS BRAGGING RIGHTS
AND JUST WON THE POLL,
STRONGEST, MOST "JACKED" PLAYER
IN BASEBALL.
THAT WAS THE TOUGHEST TO TAKE
DOWN.
MATT: GOOD FOR HIM.
I'M SURE HE WILL BE PROUD OF
THAT.
THAT MIGHT BE HIS ONE FAVORITE
THING ABOUT THE GAME TODAY.
SCOTT: I MENTIONED HIS DAD WAS
MR. CANADA, TOP BODYBUILDER IN
THE NATION IN 1975.
HIS FATHER, TERRY.
MATT: A PROUD FATHER MOMENT.
SCOTT: THAT IS RIGHT.
TYLER'S DAD I'M SURE IS
WATCHING.
MATT: DAN, DO YOU THINK THIS IS
WHERE THE GAME HAS CHANGED A
LOT?
DO YOU FEEL BACK IN THE DAY,
THIS WOULD BE A BUNT SITUATION?
FIRST AND SECOND, NOBODY OUT AND
A CHANCE TO ADD A RUNNER TWO
HERE IN THE EIGHTH INNING, WHERE
THIS WOULD BE MORE OF A BUNT
SITUATION AND NOWADAYS ANALYTICS
SO YOU SHOULD NOT BUNT?
I FEEL LIKE 10 YEARS AGO, THIS
MAY BE MORE OF A BUNT SITUATION.
DAN: I WAS THINKING THE SAME, A
GUY HITTING .241 ON THE YEAR AND
CAN RUN, YOU CAN GET THIS BALL
DOWN AND JUST PUT EXTRA
PRESSURE, SECOND AND THIRD.
POTENTIALLY SECOND AND THIRD,
NOBODY OUT.
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
I UNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW, THERE IS
A PART OF THE ANALYTIC COMMUNITY
THAT DOES NOT WANT TO GIVE OUTS
AWAY, BUT I TELL YOU, WE HAVE
SEEN IT MORE AND MORE, MATT.
I'M SURE YOU SEE IT AT THE
COLLEGE LEVEL, TO GET A BUNT
DOWN, YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMEONE
CATCH AND FIELDED.
WE SEE A LOT OF BALLS START OF
THE FIRST AND THIRD LINEUP.
MATT: AND YOU MAKE IT EASIER ON
THE GUY ON DECK.
BADER WOULD HAVE A CHANCE, IF HE
CAN HIT A FLY BALL, A CHANCE TO
GET AN R.B.I. AND YOU GET THAT
INSURANCE RUN.
IF HE PUNCHES HERE, ALL OF A
SUDDEN, YOU HAVE TO SCORE WITH A
HIT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE PITCHER HAS
A MUCH MORE MANAGEABLE WAY TO
GET OUT OF THE INNING.
SCOTT: SUTER TIES HIM UP FOR THE
STRIKEOUT.
A BIG ONE.
FIRST OUT OF THE EIGHTH.
DAN: KIND OF AN EMPTY AT-BAT.
HE GETS THE COUNT LEVERAGE AT
2-0 THEN BRENT SUTER COMES ALL
THE WAY BACK.
THREE CONSECUTIVE STRIKES AND
CHASES ONE OUT OF THE ZONE.
THIS IS A FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL,
ONLY 89 MILES AN HOUR, BUT HE
LULLS YOU TO SLEEP WITH THAT
FUNKY DELIVERY.
MATT: IT IS AMAZING THAT HE IS
ABLE TO PITCH UP IN THE ZONE
WITH HIS FASTBALL AT THAT
VELOCITY.
THERE HAS GOT TO BE SOME
DECEPTION THAT HE IS GETTING
AWAY WITH.
SCOTT: HARRISON BADER AND ON THE
HANDS, ROLLING TO THIRD.
THERE IS THE STEP FROM TRAVIS
SHAW.
OUT NUMBER TWO HERE IN THE
EIGHTH.
DAN: THERE IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE, A
GUY WHO DOES NOT THROW THAT HARD
AND YOU ARE WONDERING, HOW IN
THE WORLD CAN YOU JAM A GUY
THROWING 86 TO 88 MILES AN HOUR?
WHAT HAPPENS IS AS A HITTER, YOU
HAVE TO GO UP THERE AND YOU KNOW
YOU ARE NOT CHASING VELOCITY.
YOU WANT TO TRY TO TELL YOURSELF
TO STAY BACK, AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN, THAT 86 TO 88 IN ON YOUR
HANDS APPEARS TO BE 95 TO 100.
MATT: YEAH, I THINK THERE IS
SOME DECEPTION OF CROSSFIRE IN
THAT RAPTOR DELIVERY.
RAPTORS MUST HAVE HAD GOOD
CUTTERS BACK IN THE DAY WITH
SHORT ARMS AND CARVING THESE
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS UP AND
INSIDE, WHERE YOU THINK YOU
WOULD HAVE TO PITCH DOWN AND
AWAY WITH THE VELOCITIES.
SCOTT: JURASSIC PARK WAS A GREAT
BASEBALL MOVIE.
MATT: [LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: [LAUGHTER]
ALL ABOUT SPIN RATE, VELOCITY.
MATT: YEP.
HE IS PITCHING UP AND IN, DAN.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE WANTS TO LIVE
IN THERE.
HE KNOWS OUR RIGHT-HAND HITTERS
CANNOT GET TO THAT PITCH.
DAN: 80 MILE AN HOUR CUTTER.
WE HAVE SEEN GOOD CUTTERS,
CORBIN BURNES AND JACK FLAHERTY.
CORBIN BURNES IS FROM 94 TO 97
AND JACK FLAHERTY 95'S AND 96'S.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING ABOVE
88 FROM SUTER.
SCOTT: KNIZNER UP THE MIDDLE.
WONG TO PLAY, FADES AWAY, AND HE
HAS GOT HIM!
THAT IS SMOOTH.
HE  IS THE BEST IN THEBIZ AT
SECOND BASE, AND THAT IS WHY
CRAIG COUNSELL TOLD US THIS
MORNING, THEY DO NOT SHIFT AS
MUCH ANYMORE ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
DAN: THIS IS THE PLAY THAT HE IS
NOT GOING TO MAKE.
THE ARM STRENGTH, OFF BALANCE.
IF THE BREWERS COME BACK AND
WIN, YOU CAN ATTRIBUTE IT TO
THAT PLAY FROM KOLTESOME AIR ANO
END THE EIGHTH UNSCATHED FOR
BRENT SUTER AND COMPANY.
HIS TEAM TRAILS 1-0 AS WE HEAD
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH.
♪
>> WE DO COMMEMORATE.
>> SWING AND A HIGH DRIVE TO
CENTER FIELD.
GET UP, BABY, GET UP, BABY!
OH, YEAH!
GAME NUMBER SEVEN.
THIS SERIES IS TIED.
3-3 WITH A WALKOFF HOME RUN HERE
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE 11TH
INNING.
THE CARDINALS WIN IT, 10-9.
PHENOMENAL!
JUST FANTASTIC!
THIS ONE WILL GO DOWN IN THE
HISTORY OF THE ALZHEIMER'S.
UNBELIEVABLE -- HISTORY OF ALL
TIME.
UNBELIEVABLE!
TIED IT WITH A TRIPLE IN THE
BOTTOM  OF THE NINTH AND HEWINS
IT HERE IN THE 11TH.
SCOTT: STEP UP TO THE PLATE,
COMPETE ONLINE AND CRUSH FINGERS
IN MLB HOME RUN DERBY.
PLAY ON THE APP FOR FREE
TODAY.
WE ARE IN MILWAUKEE THIS
AFTERNOON.
WHAT A GAME, CORBIN BURNES AND
JACK FLAHERTY STARTING US OFF.
BURNES SETTING RECORDS NOT
WALKING ANYONE, FINALLY HIS
FIRST FREE PASS AFTER 58
STRIKEOUTS.THAT
LEADS US TO GENESIS CABRERA
PITCHING IN THE EIGHTH AGAINST
THE MILWAUKEE 2, 3, 4 HITTERS.
THE BREWERS HELD SCORELESS SO
FAR.
MILWAUKEE LEADING SEVEN ON BASE.
THEY ARE 0-9 FOR RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
ST. LOUIS WON-11 WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION, 10 LEFT ON
BASE.
LORENZO CAIN TO LEAD OUT THIS
LAST OF THE EIGHTH.
BREAKING BALL IN THERE FOR A
STRIKE.
SCOTT BRAUN, DAN PLESAC, MATT
HOLLIDAY AND J.P. MOROSI, LIVE
GLOBALLY ON YOUTUBE.
THIS IS LIVING UP TO THE
BILLING.
DAN: A LOT OF GOOD ARMS IN THE
CARDINALS BULLPEN.
THIS MAY BE THE BEST OF THE
BUNCH, GENESIS CABRERA.
HIT  BACK-TO-BACK PHILLIES
TOTALLYAN ACCIDENT LAST WEEK.
THIS GUY HAS A TREMENDOUS ARM.
WE'VE SEEN A COUPLE OF GOOD
BREAKING BALLS P HE WILL GET IT
TO 97, -- WE HAVE SEEN A COUPLE
A GOOD BREAKING BALLS PAIRED WE
HAVE SEEN IT 97, 90.
THIS GUY HAS A CHANCE TO BE WITH
JOSH HADER IS FOR THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS.
ANOTHER CHANGE OF AT 98 MILES AN
HOUR.
WE HAVE YET TO SEE THE GOOD
FASTBALL, BUT THIS GUY COULD
RUSH IT UP IN THE MID TO UPPER
90'S.
MATT: THIS IS A BIG AT-BAT HERE.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT HAND HITTER,
THE TWO LEFTIES TO FOLLOW.
IF USE ABLE TO GET CAIN, THIS
COULD BE AN EASY INNING FOR HIM.
THIS WILL BE A BIG AT-BAT.
SCOTT: LAZY FLY BALL, RIGHT
FIELD.
CARLSON CAMPS UNDER IT.
DAN: A GOOD LOOKING FASTBALL, 97
MILES AN HOUR.
THE BALL CUTS IN ON LORENZO
CAIN.
A LOT OF WEAPONS FOR THIS LEFTY.
I THINK THE MORE EXPERIENCED --
THERE IS A LOOK AT JOSH HADER.
HE IS HAVING ANOTHER MAGICAL
YEAR FOR THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
THIS CARDINALS BULLPEN I THINK
HAS BEEN, IT WAS A QUESTION
GOING INTO THE SEASON, BUT IF
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT HAS
MADE THE CARDINALS AT 22-15, THE
BULLPEN HAS BEEN LIGHTS OUT,
TRYING TO BRIDGE THE GAP TO GET
THE BALL TO ALEX REYES, WHO HAS
BEEN REMARKABLE THIS YEAR.
MATT: IT IS REALLY STARTING TO
COME TOGETHER THE LAST YEAR,
STARTING, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
CABRERA AND ALEX REYES, AS
YOUNGER GUYS THAT ARE FEELING
THE EIGHTH AND NINTH INNING, YOU
ARE STARTING TO SEE IT COMING
LAST YEAR AND MAY BE THE YEAR
BEFORE, BUT THEY HAVE REALLY
GOOD POWER ARMS WITH GALLEGOS
AND HIS SLIDER AS A WEAPON IN
THE SEVENTH OR EIGHTH, WHEREVER
YOU WANT TO THROW HIM.
IT HAS COME TOGETHER NICELY, AND
REYES AT THE END ALLOWS YOU TO
MIX AND MATCH IN THE SIXTH,
SEVENTH, AND EIGHTH.
SCOTT: THERE IS REYES.
TWO SHUTOUT INNINGS, FIVE
STRIKEOUTS TO FINISH OFF THE
GAME ON TUESDAY.
A 6-1 WIN FOR THE CARDINALS IN
11 INNINGS.
HE STRUCK OUT FIVE AND IS
WORKING THE SLIDER.
NIST WITH SIX CONSECUTIVE
SLIDERS TO STRIKE OUT BRADLEY
JUNIOR AND BILLY MCKINNEY ON
THREE PITCHES EACH.
CABRERA MISSES UP.
YOU SEE MANY RELIEVERS NOWADAYS
JUST SAY, I'M GOING TO PICK MY
TWO BEST PITCHES AND GO FOR IT.
CABRERA IS WALKING 4 -- ROCKING
4 HE USES CONSISTENTLY.
FOUR-SEAM, CHANGEUP, SINKER.
98 ON THE DOT.
DAN: THAT IS NOT FAIR FOR DANIEL
VOGELBACH.
A NASTY PITCHER.
THE DEFENSE WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
EARLY ON, AND TWO PLAYS HAVE
REALLY HELPED BRENT SUTER TO GET
OUT OF DAMAGE.
LORENZO CAIN, HOW ABOUT AN
ENDING DOUBLE INNING PLAY RIGHT
HERE AS HE GUNS DOWN TOMMY EDMAN
ON A SHALLOW FLY BALL TO CENTER
FIELD?
AND HIS LAST INNING, WONG,
TARGETED UP THE MIDDLE FOR A
BASE HIT.
TREMENDOUS PLAY.
BRENT SUTER CAUGHT A COUPLE OF
BREAKS TO KEEP THIS ONE 1-0.
SCOTT: AND NOW TRAVIS SHAW, TWO
DONE QUICKLY HERE IN THE EIGHTH.
MATT: DAN, THIS IS PROBABLY HIS
LAST BATTER, WOULDN'T YOU SAY?
IF GARCIA COMES TO THE PLATE
WITH THE RUNNER ON AND REYES
THROWS IN THE BULLPEN, I AM
GUESSING THIS WILL BE THE LAST
BATTER AND THEY WILL GO TO REYES
AGAINST A RIGHTY.
DAN: NO QUESTION.
WE ARE SEEING A YOUNG PITCHER
FINALLY STARTING TO HARNESS HIS
CONTROL ISSUES.
THAT AT-BAT THAT DANIEL
VOGELBACH WAS ABOUT AS NASTY AS
IT GETS.
WHEN HE IS ABLE TO THROW THAT
FIRST PITCH, IN PARTICULAR THE
BREAKING BALL FOR STRIKES, IT IS
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO HIT THIS 97
AND 98.
IT IS OVERPOWERING.
SCOTT: THERE IS ARENADO FLIPPING
THE SHADES ON AND MAKING THE
CATCH.
EASY WORK FORTHE EIGHTH INNING S
WILL HAVE ONE LAST CHANCE.
FIRST THE CARDINALS WITH ANOTHER
TURN FOR INSURANCE IN THE NINTH.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE!
ARENADO OUT TO DEEP LEFT FIELD,
HIS FIRST HOME RUN AGAINST HIS
FORMER TEAM.
LAUNCHED INTO THE BULLPEN.
YOU KNOW HE IS LOVING IT.
>> ON CUE, HE HITS THE HOME RUN.
GOING AROUND FIRST BASE AND
SAYS, LET'S GO.
>> CARPENTER 1-4 WITH A HOME RUN
AGAINST THIS RIGHT-HANDER.
GETS ANOTHER PITCHED TO DRIVE.
OUT TO DEEP RIGHT CENTER.
HE HAS DONE IT AGAIN!
HOW ABOUT THAT?
BACK-TO-BACK DAYS, OFF THE
BENCH, THREE RUN BOB CARPENTER.
>> MATT CARPENTER TAKES THE
STING FOR A RIDE.
>> IT IS CAIN, A DRIVE BACK TO
LEFT CENTER FIELD.
LORENZO CAIN HAS RETURNED WITH A
LEAD BAT CHAP.
WOW
>> THAT IS A RETURN.
>> HIS PRESENCE FELT BUEHRLE
TONIGHT FOR LORENZO CAIN.
-- FELT EARLY TONIGHT FOR
LORENZO CAIN.
SCOTT: COVID-19 VACCINES ARE
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE.
JOIN THE TEAM AND GET THE
VACCINE TO HELP GET US ALL GET
BACK TO DOING WHAT WE LOVE TO
GETHER.
VISIT COVID-19/RESOURCES FOR
MORE INFORMATION.
GOOGLE CLOUD HELPING THE
STATCAST TO REVEAL NEW INSIGHTS,
TAKING YOU DEEPER INTO THE GAME
THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
WE ARE IN THE NINTH IN MILWAUKEE
AT AMERICAN FAMILY FIELD.
IT IS ONE-ZERO ST. LOUIS.
EIGHT HITS SCATTERED AROUND BY
BREWERS PITCHING.
ONE RUN TO SHOW FOR IT BY THE
CARDINALS THEY'VE LEFT 10 ON
BASE.
THE BREWERS HAD NOT BEEN ABLE TO
SCRATCH A RUN ACROSS.
FIRST, PREVENTION MODE FOR
MILWAUKEE TO TRY TO GET TO THE
NINTH AND TIE THIS UP.
ANGEL PERDOMO ON THE MOUND TO
PITCH THE NINTH AGAINST THE
DANGER ST. LOUIS OFFENSE, 9,
1, 2, AND IF YOU LET ANYONE ON,
GOLDSCHMIDT AND ARENADO ARE
LURKING.
DAN: HOW ABOUT THE CASE WITH
BALLS, EIGHT AND TWO THIRDS
INNINGS -- 8.2 INNINGS, WHEN HE
THROWS STRIKES, HE IS TOUGH TO
HIT.
SCOTT: 66% FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL.
USES THE SLIDER 24%.
10% CHANGEUP.
TALL ON THE MOUND.
MISSES DOWN.
MATT: THIS IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS
ARE YOU FEEL LIKE MAYBE YOU
SHOULD TAKE A STRIKE TO START
THE INNING.
GET A CHANCE FOR THE OFF WALK,
GET SOMETHING GOING TO LOOK FOR
THE INSURANCE RUN HERE IN THE
NINTH INNING.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE DEALS WHERE
LANE THOMAS IS PROBABLY GOING TO
TAKE A STRIKE AGAINST SOMEONE
WHO STRUGGLES WITH COMMAND.
SCOTT: PINCH HITTER TAKES BALL
TWO.
KNOW JOSH HADER AVAILABLE TODAY,
BASED ON HOW MUCH HE HAS PITCHED
THIS WEEK.
AND THAT MISSES, THREE BALLS, NO
STRIKES.
NO DEVIN WILLIAMS, J.P.
FEYEREISEN, I MEAN, YOU DON'T
KNOW HOW THEY ARE FEELING.
YOU KNOW, DAN.
YOU COME TO THE BALLPARK AND
THEY MAY SAY, ARE YOU READY TO
GO?
THOSE ARE TWO GUYS YOU MAY THINK
ABOUT IN THE NINTH INNING IN A
TIGHT SPOT.
A CHANCE TO WATCH THINGS OFF,
DOWN A RUN.
DAN: THE UNFORTUNATE THING
DURING THE COURSE OF A YEAR,
SCOTT, IF YOU ARE CRAIG
COUNSELL, YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
YOU DO NOT OVERWORK THEM.
EVENTUALLY YOU HAVE TO GO TO
GUYS IN THE BULLPEN, EVEN THOUGH
YOU WILL HAVE TO PUT A GUY IN
HIS SPOT THAT YOU ARE NOT
TOTALLY COMFORTABLE WITH BECAUSE
YOU CANNOT BEAT YOUR BULLPEN UP,
YOUR BIG COURSES, PARTICULARLY
EARLY ON.
SCOTT: HE WALKS TO LEADOFF
HITTER, LANE THOMAS.
HERE COMES THE TOP OF THE ORDER,
STARTING WITH TOMMY EDMAN.
GO AHEAD, MATT.
MATT: I WAS JUST SAYING, I THINK
YOU ARE LOOKING AT DEVIN
WILLIAMS MORE OF A CLOSER TODAY.
YOU ARE PROBABLY NOT BRINGING
THEM INTO THE SITUATION, BUT IT
WILL BE INTERESTING WHAT THEY DO
AS FAR AS MAY BE BUNTING HERE
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TOMMY EDMAN
AND HIS SKILL SET.
MAYBE TAKE A PITCH AND FLASHED
THE BUNT OUT THERE AND SEE IF
YOU CAN GET THIS PITCHER
RATTLED.
SCOTT: THERE IS A STRIKE ON THE
CORNER TO EDMAN.
DEVIN WILLIAMS, TWO PITCHES
YESTERDAY.
THEY HAVE USED HIM QUITE A BIT
THIS WEEK, AS WELL.
BLUNT SAVE ON TUESDAY.
HE HAD BEEN ON A ROLL UP TO THAT
POINT.
SIX SCORELESS APPEARANCES
ENTERING THAT ONE.
EDMAN TO THE RIGHT SIDE, AND
THERE IS WONG WITH ALL THE
RANGE.
MAKES THE PLAY FOR OUT NUMBER
ONE.
LANE THOMAS MOVES HIMSELF UP TO
SECOND.
J.P., WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
J.P.: A GREAT AT-BAT BY EDMAN.
THAT HAS BEEN A THEME FOR THE
CARDINALS.
SINCE MIKE SHILDT MOVED TO HAVE
EDMAN LEADOFF AND CARLSON THE
TWO SPOT, THE CARDINALS HAVE THE
BEST RECORD IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL AT 14-5.
SCOTT: ON THE SEASON THEY ARE
22-15, FIRST PLACE IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE CENTRAL.
MILWAUKEE AT 20 IN 17 ON THE
YEAR, TWO OF THE BEST IN THE NL
CENTRAL MATCHING UP TODAY IN A
GOOD ONE.
MATT: YOU HAVE TWO CRACKS WITH
THE RUNNER IN SCORING POSITION
ON A RIGHT-HANDED HITTER AGAINST
A LEFT PITCHER.
CARLSON GOT A CHANCE TO DRIVE IN
THE RUN AGAIN WITH A SPEEDY
RUNNER AT SECOND BASE AND
LOOKING FOR THAT INSURANCE RUN.
SCOTT: SOME UP AND IN HEAT FROM
PERDOMO.
PICKS UP THE STRIKE.
1-1 TO CARLSON, WHO IS HAVING A
NICE MONTH.
MATT: MY BEST ADVICE WOULD BE
NOT TO HIT IT TO KOLTEN WONG OR
ANYWHERE NEAR HIM IF YOU ARE
TRYING TO SCORE A RUN.
SCOTT: ANOTHER BIG CUT AND A
MISS ON A PITCH UP.
PROBABLY SHOULD AVOID JACKIE
BRADLEY JR. TERRITORY AND LEFT
FIELD, TOO.
MAYBE NOT TOO CLOSE TO LORENZO
CAIN, MATT, RIGHT?
MATT: NOT A LOT OF SPOTS TO HIT
IT.
NOT A LOT OF SPOTS TO HIT IT.
I WOULD TRY FIRST BASE OR MAYBE
THIRD BASE.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD
OFFENDERS ON THE FIELD.
SCOTT: TYRONE TAYLOR HAS A
STRONG ARM, PLAYS A NICE RIGHT
FIELD.
THIS IS A TEAM SET UP WELL
DEFENSIVELY, JUST LIKE THE
CARDINALS.
HERE IS TAYLOR ENTERING THE GAME
FOR GARCIA A COUPLE OF INNINGS
BACK.
MOST OUTS ABOVE AVERAGE AMONG
OUTFIELDERS THIS SEASON.
THE BREWERS ARE RANKED SECOND.
CHRISTIAN YELICH ON THE INJURED
LIST.
HE WILL TAKE SOME SWINGS, SO
MAYBE'S IN THEM -- SOME A.B.'S
THE MINOR LEAGUES THIS WEEKEND.
THE RUNNER MOVES TO THIRD.
A STOLEN BAG FOR LANE THOMAS,
ADDING INSURANCE FOR ST. LOUIS
WITH LESS THAN TWO OUTS AND THE
CHANCE FOR SAC FLY FOR DYLAN
CARLSON.
DAN: HEADS-UP BASERUNNING.
YOU TOOK ADVANTAGE OF PER
DOMAIN,  --PERDOMO.
IT WAS VERY EASY TO BE TIMED AND
A GREAT HEADS-UP JOB.
YOU ARE ALWAYS TRYING TO PICK UP
90 FEET AND GET IT TO THIRD
BASE.
A LOT OF WAYS NOW FOR THE
CARDINALS TO TRY AND STRETCH
ACROSS ANOTHER INSURANCE RUN.
SCOTT: THREE STOLEN BASES FOR
THE CARDINALS TODAY.
CARLSON TAKES ONE IN TIGHT.
MATT: THAT IS A BIG STOLEN BASE.
IT BRINGS IN FIELD AND.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, GUYS LIKE
KOLTEN WONG DON'T HAVE THE RANGE
THEY TYPICALLY WOULD.
THAT WAS A BIG STOLEN BASE RIGHT
HERE AND GIVES THE HITTER A LOT
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO TRY AND
SCORE THAT RUN.
SCOTT: IF LORENZO CAIN WATCHES
HIS BACK AND SEES THE SAC FLY
LINE, HE IS GOING TO GO, WAIT,
DID YOU SEE WHAT I DID A FEW
INNINGS BACK?
MATT: HE IS NOT GOING TO LIKE
THAT.
SCOTT: NO.
SEVENTH INNING, GOLDSCHMIDT WITH
A FLY BALL TO CENTER.
AND JUST MONEY THROW.
SO ACCURATE FROM LORENZO CAIN
ON-THE-FLY IN STRIDE TO PREVENT
THE CARDINALS FROM PUTTING
ANOTHER RUN ACROSS.
MATT: HE DID A REALLY GOOD JOB
OF GETTING BEHIND IT AND GIVING
HIMSELF AN ANGLE THAT WAS
DIRECTLY IN LINE WITH HOME PLATE
SO THAT HE COULD MAKE THAT
ACCURATE THROW.
SCOTT: THE BREWERS ARE A TEAM
SET UP FOR RUN PREVENTION.
WE WILL SEE IF CARLSON
CHALLENGES THEIR OUTFIELDERS.
NO, HE DOES NOT.
THAT PITCH SALES AWAY.
THERE ARE TWO ON FOR THE
CARDINALS HERE IN THE NINTH.
FOR MORE CONTENT LIKE THIS,
VISIT THE BREWERS YOUTUBE PAGE,
THE BEST PLACE TO GO BEHIND THE
SCENES WITH THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS.
SUBSCRIBE SO YOU NEVER MISS A
VIDEO, VISIT
YOUTUBE.COM/BREWERS.
MATT: PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT IS GOING
TO HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
DRIVE IN A RUN IN ESTATE HIM HE
LOVES TO HIT IN.
THE CARDINALS FEEL GOOD ABOUT
HAVING GOLDSCHMIDT THE LEADING
HITTER IN THE STADIUMS HISTORY.
HE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HIT THE
BALL AND OUTFIELD.
THE PITCHER WILL TRY TO GET HIM
ON THE GROUND AND GET THE DOUBLE
PLAY.
IT  LOOKED TO ME LIKE A3-2
CHANGEUP THAT THAT MAYBE THEY
WERE SITTING UP THE DOUBLE PLAY
IN THIS SITUATION.
SCOTT: GOLDSCHMIDT HAD A GO
AHEAD TWO RUN HOME RUN IN THE
11TH INNING ON TUESDAY, AND HE
JUST SMASHES THE BASEBALL ONE OF
THE BEST HITTERS IN THIS SPORT
THE LAST DECADE.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
54 HARD-HIT BASEBALLS, FOURTH
BEST IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE.
HE PUNISHES PITCHES, ESPECIALLY
OVER THE MIDDLE OF THE PLATE.
MATT: YOU KNOW, TO ME, THE STATS
DON'T REALLY MATCHUP WITH HIS
HARD-HIT RATE YET.
AS A HITTER, THERE IS PROBABLY
FRUSTRATION.
HE HAS PROBABLY HIT A LOT OF
BALLS HARD THAT HE THOUGHT WOULD
BE HITS AND HE IS IN GETTING THE
RESULTS HE'S LOOKING AT.
AS A HITTER, YOU HAVE TO
CONTINUE PROCESSING IT OUT.
KEEP DOING THE PROCESS, HITTING
HARD AND TRUST YOU WILL
EVENTUALLY GET THE RESULTS.
SCOTT: HE TAKES THE FIRST PITCH.
APPARENTLY LOW.
AND I KNOW DAN WANTED THAT ONE.
ESPECIALLY AGAINST GOLDSCHMIDT.
ONE OUT.
RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS HERE FOR
GOLDIE.
SO MUCH DAMAGE IN THIS BALL PARK
IN THE PAST.
A CHECK TO FIRST.
BALL GETS AWAY.
IN COMES THE SECOND RUN FOR ST.
LOUIS.
LANE THOMAS SCORES.
2-0.
DAN: THAT IS A BIG RUN.
THE CARDINALS CATCH A BREAK.
PERDOMO WITH AN ERRATIC THROW TO
FIRST BASE.
YOU SEE A LOOK AT IT RIGHT HERE.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT HANDCUFFS
DANIEL VOGELBACH.
YOU CAN SEE THE SUNLIGHT AND THE
SHADE.
IT ALMOST APPEARED THAT
VOGELBACH EITHER LOST THE BALL
IN THE SEATS OF THE FANS.
IT WAS A THROW AROUND THE KNEES,
THE HIGH SHIN AREA.
MATT: IT LOOKED LIKE HE WAS
LEANING, LIKE HE MIGHT BE GOING
RIGHT THERE.
IT LOOKED LIKE CARLSON HAD AN
INTEREST TO STEAL THE BASE.
IT LOOKED LIKE MAYBE A BETTER
THROW WOULD'VE HAD A PLAY.
SCOTT: THE LEADOFF WALK, LEADS
TO A RUN, LANE THOMAS MIXED IN A
STOLEN BASE.
DAN: WATCH, LOOK AT VOGELBACH.
IT IS NOT A GREAT THROW, BUT IT
ALMOST HANDCUFFED -- IT WAS KIND
OF LIKE HE AIN'T THAT AND PULLED
IT DOWN TO THE LEFT SIDE.
--  PSYCHEYANKED -- LIKE HE
YANKED THAT AND PULLED IT DOWN
TO LEFT SIDE.
MATT: CARLSON COULD SWIPE THIRD
HERE.
HE IS SLOW TO THE PLATE.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE IS IN THE
DELIVERY.
IF HE WON UP SOME AGAIN, HE
COULD STEAL THIRD.
SCOTT: A FREE PASS FOR
GOLDSCHMIDT.
SEVEN WALKS ISSUED BY THE
BREWERS BULLPEN.
MATT: IT IS GOING TO GIVE NOLAN
ARENADO A CHANCE TO SOLIDIFY HIS
PLACE AS PLAYER OF THE GAME
RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT: HE WANTS TO TALK TO YOU,
MATT, POSTGAME.
I KNOW IT.
MATT: HE WANTS THAT TROPHY WITH
THE PLAY BUTTON ON IT.
SCOTT: YOU KNOW NOLAN ARENADO.
HE IS ONE OF THE MOST
COMPETITIVE HUMAN BEINGS ON THE
PLANET.
MATT: YEP.
AND I USED TO CRUSH HIM AND REMI
-- HIM IN RUMMY.
SCOTT: YOU WILL HAVE TO REMIND
HIM IF HE COMES THROUGH HERE FOR
THE CARDINALS.
THEY HAVE SCORED IN THE FIRST,
AND NOW HERE IN THE NINTH.
AND ONE OF THEIR BEST IS AT THE
DISH.
THEIR NEW ADDITION FROM THE
OFF-SEASON.
NOLAN ARENADO, TWO ON AND A RUN
HOME HERE FOR ST. LOUIS.
PERDOMO IS 1-0 IN THE FIRST
STRIKE.
MATT: IF HE WINS THIS TROPHY,
THE NEXT TIME I AM WITH HIM, I
THINK WE WILL MAKE THAT THE
RUMMY CHAMPIONSHIP TROPHY.
WHOEVER IS CURRENTLY WINNING
HOLDS THE TROPHY.
SCOTT: THEN WE HAVE TO GET YOUR
NAME ENGRAVED.
WE WILL GET A NEW PLATE TO PUT
OVER NOLAN'S.
MATT: TALK TO THE PEOPLE AT
YOUTUBE.
SCOTT: I KNOW A GUY TWO THAT CAN
HELP US OUT.
[LAUGHTER]
GOT SOME FRIENDS THERE.
ARENADO BEHIND, 1-2.
STEPS OUT FOR A MOMENT.
TOUGH TO FIND RUNS THIS
AFTERNOON, ESPECIALLY EARLY ON
AGAINST JACK FOR HER GUILLEN
CORBIN BURNES AFTER HE GAVE UP
THAT ONE RUN IN THE OPENING
FRAME.
-- JACK FLAHERTY AND CORBIN
BURNES AFTER HE GAVE UP THAT ONE
RUN IN THE OPENING FRAME.
THREE WALKS BY PERDOMO.
MATT: DAN, THESE GUYS CAN BE A
REALLY TOUGH AT-BAT.
A LITTLE WILDNESS TO THEM, AND
THE FACT THAT THEY DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHERE IT IS GOING, SO IT IS
HARD TO ANTICIPATE THE PATTERN.
THESE WILL BE DIFFICULT AT-BATS
FOR HITTERS.
IT IS ALMOST LIKE THAT
EFFECTIVELY WILD PITCHER, LIKE
HE MAY NOT EVEN BE AIMING INSIDE
BUT MIGHT PAINTED UP INSIDE.
DAN: LIKE THAT.
THAT IS JUST ENOUGH TO MAKE YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE IF YOU ARE ARENADO
.
PERDOMO HAS BEEN ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
HE IS HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
GETTING THE BALL INTO RIGHTIES.
WATCHES FASTBALL.HE
CUTS IT OFF.
A FOUR-SEAM HEATER THAT JUST
KEEPS TRACKING INSIDE.
CERTAINLY A YOUNG PITCHER.
NOT COMMENDING THE STRIKE ZONE.
IF HE COULD FLIP SOMETHING DOWN
AND AWAY, CURVEBALL, CHANGEUP.
MATT: AND THEN HE PAINTED UP.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES THIS A TOUGH
AT-BAT FOR A HITTER.
HE HAS REALLY GOOD STUFF, HE IS
JUST NOT COMMENDING IT VERY WELL
YET.
IT IS KIND OF AN UNSETTLING
FEELING.
SCOTT: 14 BALLS, 12 STRIKES.
FROM PERDOMO IN THIS INNING.
THREE SINGLES TODAY FOR ARENADO
AND FOUR AT-BATS.
HE SENDS ONE TO RIGHT CENTER,
BACKING UP TAYLOR, AND HE IS
THERE FOR THE CATCH, TAGGING UP
FROM SECOND.
CARLSON IS IN THERE.
RUNNERS NOW ON THE CORNERS FOR
ST. LOUIS WITH TWO GONE AND MATT
CARPENTER ABOUT TO CLIMB IN.
DAN: THIS IS A REALLY BIG OUT
FOR MILWAUKEE.IF YOU CAN
KEEP IT WITHIN GETTING A BASE
RUNNER AND ONE SWING ON THE BAT,
AND YOU GET DOWN THREE RUNS,
THAT IS A BIG DIFFERENCE WITH A
GUY LIKE ALEX REYES, WHO WE ARE
ASSUMING WILL COME AND PITCH THE
NINTH INNING, WHO HAS BEEN
LIGHTS OUT.
THIS IS A BIG OUT.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW WITH PERDOMO,
REALLY MUSTER UP TO TRY TO GET
OUT OF THIS, KEEPING IT2-0.
MATT: MAKES YOU WONDER WITH A
LEFT-HANDED HITTER IF THEY MIGHT
TRY SOMETHING ON THE BASES,
MAYBE AN EARLY BREAK OR SEE IF
THEY CAN GET THIS YOUNG PITCHER
RATTLED AND TRY TO DO SOMETHING
OF CARPENTER GETS BEHIND IN THE
COUNT.
AFTER ALREADY THROWING A BALL
PAST THE FIRST BASEMAN.
SCOTT: PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT USED TO
SWIPE BASES REGULARLY.
HE WAS ALL AROUND BASEBALL
SUPERSTAR.
THERE IS A STRIKE.
CARPENTER WITH A PAIR OF
STRIKEOUTS AND ALSO A BASE HIT
WALK.
BEHIND THAT ONE.
MATT: PER JUMBO CREATES A TOUGH
ANGLE FOR A LEFT-HANDER --
PERDOMO CREATES A TOUGH ANGLE
FOR A LEFT-HANDER.
IF HE CAN GET IT UP AND AWAY, IT
WILL BE DIFFICULT FOR MATT
CARPENTER TO STAY ON THAT PITCH.
THIS IS A TOUGH MATCH UP FOR A
LEFTY.
SCOTT: THE CARDINALS ARE DOWN A
MAN TODAY.
PAUL DEJONG NOT IN THE STARTING
LINEUP AND DID NOT SOUND LIKE HE
WAS AVAILABLE AFTER AN MRI.
SOUNDS IF WE WILL GET THE
RESULTS AFTER THE GAME, DEALING
WITH A SIDE ISSUE.
THAT ALMOST HIT CARPENTER.
NICE STOP BY NARVAEZ.
MATT: LOOKS LIKE GOLDSCHMIDT
STOLE SECOND.
SCOTT: HE DID!
GOLDIE UP TO SECOND.
MOST STOLEN BASES IN THE GAME
FOR THE CARDINAL SINCE SEPTEMBER
2019.
FOUR OF THEM TODAY, HOPING TO
CREATE ACTION, TRAFFIC ON THE
BASE PATHS.
CARPENTER TO CENTER IN THE
SUNSHINE.
CAIN, HE HAS GOT  FOR ST. LOUIS.
THEY BOOKEND THE GAME, A RUN IN
THE FIRST, A RUN IN THE NINTH,
AND YOU FIGURE ALEX REYES TIME
COMING UP.
>> NINTH INNING WITH THE RED SOX
TRAILING BY FIVE RUNS.
AND JEREMY GUTHRIE BACK ON THE
MOUND.
HERNANDEZ DROPS THE BASEBALL.
THINGS ARE CRUISING ALONG FOR
GUTHRIE.
HE HAS THROWN 91 PITCHES.
>> HE IS NOT GOING TO GIVE HIM A
CHANCE TO FINISH.
>> A LIVE PLAY BEHIND THEM AS
ORTIZ GETS IT TO DEEP LEFT
CENTER.
>> COMING ACROSS THE SCORE IS
5-1 BALTIMORE.
>> FULL COUNT, BASES LOADED.
INSIDE AND HE WALKS IN A RUN.
>> HERE IS THE PITCH.
RIGHT CENTER LEFT FIELD BASE
HIT.
>> TWO RUNS ARE IN.
>> THREE MEN ON, TWO MEN OUT AND
A 3-2 COUNT TO JULIO LUGO.
>> LUGO CHOPS IT RIGHT SIDE.
MILLAR WILL NEED HELP.
HERE COMES ANOTHER RUN, RED SOX
WIN!
BOSTON COMES ALL THE WAY BACK, A
SIX RUN NIGHT.
SCOTT: IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
MORE CONTENT LIKE THIS, VISIT
THE CARDINALS YOUTUBE PAGE, THE
BEST PLACE TO GO BEHIND THE
SCENES WITH THE CARDINALS.
SUBSCRIBE SO YOU NEVER MISS A
VIDEO.
VISIT YOUTUBE.COM/CARDINALS.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SUBSCRIBE
TO MORE STATCAST, POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD, ALEX REYES SHOWING
OFF THE SLIDER.
OPPONENTS ARE ONE FOR 21 AGAINST
THE WIPEOUT PITCH.
DAN: ONE OF THE BIG REASONS WHY
THE CARDINALS BULLPEN RIGHT NOW
IS PITCHING AS WELL AS ANY TEAM
IN THE BULLPEN, WE HAVE SEEN
GENESIS CABRERA WAS TERRIFIC,
GALLEGOS, THIS GUY RIGHT HERE IS
AS GOOD AS HE CAN BE.
LOOKING AT THE E.R.A., 0.47.
16 WALKS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIM CUT
THAT DOWN.
I STILL THINK LONG TERM, THIS
WOULD BE A GUY YOU SEEN THE
STARTING ROTATION SOMEDAY FOR
THE CARDINALS.
BIG ARM, THROWS HARD, GOOD HARD
BREAKING BALL, AND HE HAS TAKEN
TO THE BULLPEN RIGHT NOW.
WHAT ARE THE -- ONE OF THE
STRENGTHS INTO THE GAME TODAY,
THEY ARE PLAYING GREAT BASEBALL
AT 22-15.
THERE BULLPEN HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD.
SCOTT: IT SOUNDS LIKE THE PLAN
IS LONG-TERM TO PUT ALEX REYES
BACK INTO THE STARTING ROTATION.
HARD TO TAKE HIM OUT RIGHT NOW
OF THE NINTH INNING JOB AS HE
TRIES TO LOCK DOWN A SAVE FOR
ST. LOUIS AND WIN.
PINCH HITTER MANNY PINA STARTING
UP THE NIGHT FOR MILWAUKEE, DOWN
2-0.
DAN: GET A GOOD LOOK AT THAT
FASTBALL.
97 MILES AN HOUR.
HE CAN RUSH IT UP THERE, TOO.
MATT: I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT
OUT HIS SICK CLEATS.
THE RED JORDAN'S WITH THE YELLOW
BOTTOMS IS A NICE LOOK.
SCOTT: GREAT LOOK.
GOOD CALL.
GOT TO LOOK GOOD DOING IT, TOO.
MATT: OH, YEAH.
THERE THEY ARE.
WOW.
WONDER IF HE HAS BEEN IN YADI
MOLINA'S CLOSET.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE HIS
JORDAN'S.
REYES MIGHT ALREADY HAVE THE
HOOKUP.
I KNOWYADI HAS SOME THAT LOOK A
LOT LIKE THAT.
SCOTT: YADI GETTING THE DAY OFF
TODAY.
ANDREW KNIZNER THE CATCHER.
RADIUS 26 YEARS OLD -- REYES 26
YEARS OLD, LAST PITCHED TUESDAY
IN THE SERIES.
THERE IS A STRIKE.
HE FINISHED OFF THE GAME
TUESDAY, STRIKING OUT FIVE.
DID WALK THREE.
KEPT THE RUMORS OFF THE BOARD,
PICKED UP THE W.
-- CAP THE BREWERS OFF THE
BOARD, PICKED UP THE W.
SLIDER TIME?
MATT: YEAH.
DAN: JUST OVERTHREW THAT WHEN A
LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: SHORT.
MATT: THE NEXT STEP FOR HIM
WOULD BE TO BE A LITTLE MORE
EFFICIENT.
HE COULD HAVE 10 AND 12.
SCOTT: JUST MISSED.
CALLED LOW, AND MANNY PINA WORKS
A WALK AGAINST REYES TO LEADOFF
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR MILWAUKEE.
DAN: THIS IS STRIKE ALL DAY
LONG.
86 MILE AN HOUR.
IT ALMOST APPEARS SOMETIMES AS
THE UMPIRE GETS PASSED BECAUSE
THERE ISN'T ANYTHING ABOUT THIS
PITCH THAT IS NOT TO LIKE.
MATT: THAT IS ABOUT AS PERFECT A
PINCH YOU CAN MAKE.
AS A HITTER, I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
MY SHINGUARD OFTEN WALK TO
FIRST, BUT AS DEFENSE, YOU ARE
BEGGING FOR THAT ONE.
ESPECIALLY THE FIRST OUT OF THE
INNING.
A TWO RUN GAME.
SCOTT: BIG SWING AND A MISS FROM
NARVAEZ.
WORKING WITH TRAFFIC SO FAR THIS
SEASON.
FOR THE MOST PART, HE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO WORK AROUND IT.
DAN: I THINK HE WILL GET BETTER
AS THE SEASON GOES ON.
WHEN YOU ARE GETTING ACCLIMATED
TO THE BULLPEN, YOU SIT THERE,
AND THERE IS A LOT OF ANXIETY,
YOU ARE WATCHING JACK FLAHERTY
AND THE GAME DEVELOPED, AND YOU
ARE SENSING THIS COULD BE A GAME
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
POTENTIALLY PITCH IN.
IT IS SO HARD AT TIMES FOR A
YOUNGER PITCHER TO CALM YOURSELF
DOWN AND GET A LITTLE AHEAD OF
YOURSELF AND HE IS THROWING
HARD, AND IT IS A LOT HARDER
COMMENDING YOUR PITCHES OUT OF
THE BULLPEN.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE TIME YOU DO
AT THE STARTING ROTATION WHERE
YOU CAN GO TWO OR THREE HITTERS
AND FIND THE FIELD FOR THE
CURVEBALL OR THE SLIDER.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF ROOM FOR
ERROR COMING OUT OF THE BULLPEN.
SCOTT: NARVAEZ CAN SWING THE
BAT, HE DOES BUT MISSES HER
FALLS BEHIND 1-2.
-- MISSES P HE FALLS BEHIND 1-2.
MATT: IT SPEAKS TO HOW HIS
PITCHES MOVE.
IT IS HARD WITH THAT KIND OF A
SLIDER AND LIVE FASTBALL.
HIS BALL JUST REALLY MOVES A LOT
AND HIS CHANGEUP HAS A LOT OF
RUN TO IT.
IT IS AIMED FOR THE MIDDLE AND
WHEN HE TRIES TO HIT THE
CORNERS.
HE HAS GOT THE KIND OF STUFF WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WE CAN AIM
DOWN THE MIDDLE AND GET AWAY
WITH IT -- EARLIER, WHERE YOU
CAN AIM DOWN THE MIDDLE AND GET
AWAY WITH IT.
SCOTT: WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT ALEX REYES FOR A LONG
TIME.
BIG DEAL PROSPECT, HAS GONE
THROUGH ADVERSITY, INCLUDING
INJURIES.
HE HAS AHEAD OF OUR VIAS.
THAT SHE IS AHEAD OF NARVAEZ.
GOING UP AGAINST ONE OF THE BEST
HITTING CATCHERS IN BASEBALL SO
FAR THIS SEASON, ACTIVATED OFF
OF THE INJURY LIST, DEALING WITH
HAMSTRING TROUBLES.
AND THE 2-2.
VERY THE SLIDER AND STRUCK HIM
OUT.
DAN: NASTY.
HARD WHEN HE THROWS 100 MILES AN
HOUR.
YOU SEE THE ROTATION ON THIS
BALL, DOWN AND IN.
HE WANTS TO GET THAT HEAD OF THE
BAT OUT AND THE BALL DOES NOT
STOP.
A GREAT PITCH.
SCOTT: NEXT UP, JACKIE BRADLEY,
JUNIOR, MANNY PINA WALKED TO
START OFF THE NINTH.
THERE IT IS AGAIN.
MATT: NO WONDER THE LEAGUE IS
NOT DOING VERY WELL OFF THAT
PITCH.
SCOTT: ON THE MOUND FOR ST.
LOUIS, COMING TOGETHER FOR HIM
OUT OF THE BULLPEN SO FAR THIS
SEASON.
DAN: THAT IS A PROBLEM YOU RUN
INTO, MATT.
HE THROWS A LOT OF BREAKING
BALLS.
WHEN YOU THROW ONE AFTER
ANOTHER, IT IS HARD TO COMMAND
THE PITCH, AND ALL YOU TAKE IS
ONE MISTAKE AND YOU LEAD THAT
SLIDER UP IN THE ZONE.
WITH ONE SWING, JACKIE BRADLEY
COULD TIE SOMETHING UP HERE.
MATT: YEAH, YOU HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL AGAINST A LEFT-HANDED
HITTER.
YOU MIGHT DROP IT RIGHT INTO HIS
BARREL.
SCOTT: SLIDER CITY.
SHOULD HE BE USING THE FASTBALL
MORE, DAN?
ESPECIALLY FEEL IS TRYING TO
ESTABLISH HIMSELF AS A STARTER?
DAN: HE SEES A LOT OF SWINGS AND
MISSES.
IF HE CAN CONTINUE TO THROW THIS
BREAKING BALL RIGHT HERE, HE IS
GOING TO HAVE JACKIE BRADLEY HIS
BACK POCKET.
THAT IS A NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
PITCHED TO DO ANYTHING WITH.
SCOTT: THERE IS ANOTHER!
BACK TO BACK STRIKEOUTS FOR
REYES.
SLIDER CITY.
DAN: YOU ARE WATCHING THIS AT
HOME, WATCHING ON YOUTUBE, GOING
HOW IN THE WORLD CAN THE HITTERS
CONTINUE TO SWING AT THIS BALL
BREAKING DOWN ALMOST AT THE BACK
FOOT?
THE ROTATION IS SO TIGHT, IT HAS
THE APPEARANCE OF BEING A
FASTBALL, AND IT DROPS AND
DISAPPEARS.
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO READ.
HE THROWS IT SO HARD.
MATT: YOU KNOW, IT LOOKS TO ME
LIKE HE PITCHES OFF OF HIS
SLIDER.
HE COMMAND PITCHES HIS SLIDER
AND HIS FASTBALL IS MORE SHOW.AT
THIS POINT, HE HAS A BETTER FEEL
FOR THE LOCATION OF WHAT TO DO
WITH THE SLIDER, AND THE
FASTBALL IS A LITTLE MORE
ERRATIC.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS PITCHING
BACKWARDS WITH A 90 MILE AN HOUR
FASTBALL.
SCOTT: THERE IS THE FASTBALL,
CLOCKED TO CENTER FIELD.
BADER RACING IN AND DROPS FOR A
KNOCK.
TWO ON FOR MILWAUKEE HERE IN THE
NINTH.
DAN: IN SOME WAYS, HE REMINDS ME
OF A GUY WHO USED TO CLOSE
GAMES, CARLOS MARMOL, WHO SEEMED
LIKE HE WAS MUCH BETTER AT
GETTING HIS BREAKING OVER FOR
STRIKES THEN THE FASTBALL.
THIS IS ONE OF THE FEW FASTBALLS
SEE HAS THROWN, SCOTT.
MAYBE THIS IS WHY HE THROWS THE
SLIDER EXCLUSIVELY.
MATT: YEAH, IT IS MIDDLE-MIDDLE,
MIDDLE, FASTBALL HITTER.
WE HAVE SEEN THEM STRUGGLE ALL
DAY WITH THE SLIDER FROM JACK
FLAHERTY.
RIGHT THERE, WE GET A FIRST
PITCH FASTBALL.
HE WAS PROBABLY THROW TO SEE IT
AFTER ALL THE BREAKING BALLS
LEADING UP TO THIS AT-BAT.
SCOTT: WE WILL SEE IF HE GOES
BACK TO THE SLIDE PIECE.
UP AGAINST TYRONE TAYLOR, TWO ON
FOR MILWAUKEE.
MATT: I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE SOME SLIDERS.
SCOTT: HE DID THIS THE OTHER
DAY, MATT.
HE SAID AT THE END OF THE GAME,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
SIX SLIDERS IN A ROW, GOOD
AFTERNOON, GOOD MORNING, GOOD
AFTERNOON, AND GOOD NIGHT.
THAT IS THE PHRASE.
STRUCK OUT THE LAST TWO.
MATT: THEY SAY YOU WANT TO GET
BEAT WITH YOUR BEST PITCH.
HIS BEST PITCHES OBVIOUSLY THE
SLIDER.
IT IS NICE TO HAVE THAT 98 MILE
AN HOUR IN YOUR POCKET WHEN YOU
NEED IT.
SCOTT: THAT WAS THE HEATER.
TAYLOR HAS BEEN PICKING UP MORE
PLAYING TIME SINCE YELICH WENT
BACK ON THE INJURY LIST.
NOW DOWN TO THEIR FINAL STRIKE.
MATT: WHAT DO YOU THINK HERE,
DAN?
HE CAN GO ANYWHERE HE WANTS,
SLIDER DOWN AND AWAY OR FASTBALL
UP IN THE ZONE.
HE HAS A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
WEAPONS TO USE.
DAN: MY GUT TELLS ME HE WILL GO
TO THE HARD BREAKING BALL DOWN
AND AWAY.
THAT IS HIS BREAD AND BUTTER,
LITTLE BLANKET PITCH.
HE IS COMFORTABLE THROWING IT,
HE WILL THROW IT 3, 4 TIMES IN A
ROW.
I WILL BE SURPRISED IF THERE IS
ANOTHER FASTBALL IN THE
SEQUENCE.
SCOTT: WILL IT LAND IN THE ZONE?
IT
DOES NOT HAVE TO FOR HIM.
TAYLOR WAS THE WINNER ON
MOTHER'S DAY.
MATT: THIS IS WHERE HE HAS
SHAKEN OFF KINSLER.
HE IS HAVING A HARD TIME ON THE
SAME PAGE, WHERE IF YADI WAS
CATCHING ON, HE WOULD BE SIMPLE.
SCOTT: TAYLOR PITCHES THROUGH,
REYES STRIKES OUT THE SIDE, GAME
OVER.
SLIDER, THE PITCH DOZIER FOR THE
CLOSER FOR THE CARDINALS, AND
THEY PICK UP THE W AND WIN THIS
SERIES, A 2-0 FINAL.
ST. LOUIS UPS THE RECORD TO
23-15 ON THE YEAR AS MILWAUKEE
DROPS TO 20-18.
OUR POLL QUESTION TO FINISH OFF
THE DAY, YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME PICK ONE, FROM JACK
FLAHERTY, ARENADO AND EDMAN.
WE WILL REVEAL THE WINNER AND A
BIT.
IT IS TIME FOR THE POSTGAME
SHOW, 30 MINUTES, ALL ABOUT THE
BREWERS AND THE CARDINALS RIGHT
NOW.
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK, LIVE
ON YOUTUBE, POST GOING PRESENTED
BY SCOTT BRAUN, J.P. MOROSI,
MATT HOLLIDAY, DAN PLESAC.
ALEX REYES SHUTS THE DOOR, AND
THE CARDINALS WIN MATT: YOU
CANNOT ALWAYS PREDICT WHAT THEY
WILL LOOK, BUT IF YOU SAID 2-0,
PITCHER'S DUEL, TOUGH TO GET
RUNS, SOMEONE FINDS A WAY TO
SCORE HERE AND THERE, AND THE
BULLPEN COMES INTO CLOSE IT OUT,
I THINK THAT IS WHAT YOU WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT COMING IN, AND THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
DAN: WE HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT
HISTORY THIS AFTERNOON, CORBIN
BURNES HAD NOT WALKED A HITTER
ALL SEASON.
FIVE POWERHOUSE HITTING'S
ON THE YEAR, NOT A BAD STRIKEOUT
TO WALK RATIO.
58 STRIKEOUTS FOR CORBIN BURNES
AND ONE WALK, AND UNFORTUNATELY
GIVES OUT A RUN IN THE FIRST
INNING WITH A STOLEN BASE AND
ARENADO DRIVE HIM HOME.
TOUGH LUCK LOST FOR CORBIN
BURNES WHO DESERVED A BETTER
FATE.
SCOTT: WE MENTIONED AT ONE POINT
DURING THE GAME, CHRISTIAN
YELICH IS OUT AND HASN'T PLAYED
MUCH IN THE PAST MONTH AND A
HALF.
HE HAS A BACK ISSUE AND WILL BE
PLAYING IN THE GAMES TO PICK UP
SOME AT-BATS AND CB CAN GET BACK
ON THE FIELD AS SOON AS NEXT
WEEK.
HELLO, SCOTT BRAUN, DAN PLESAC,
MATT HOLLIDAY CHIMING IN FROM
OKLAHOMA.
IT IS YELICH AND THOSE MAY BE
THEIR TWO BEST NATURAL HITTERS.
THEY ARE BOTH MISSING RIGHT NOW
AND IT SHOWS.
MATT: YEAH, I THINK THEIR
OFFENSE, AS THE NUMBERS SHOW,
HAS BEEN DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
SCORE.
LIKE YOU TALKED ABOUT,I WOULD HE
AND FOUR HITTERS, WHEN THOSE
GUYS ARE NOT PRODUCING,
SOMETIMES IT IS HARD TO SCORE.
THEY HAVE TO GET THOSE VETERAN
GUYS HOT, LORENZO CAIN IS GOING
TO HAVE TO GET HOT, JACKIE
BRADLEY.
THEY HAVE TO GET YELICH HEALTHY.
FIND A WAY TO GET SOME OFFENSE
AT FIRST BASE.
THEY NEED OFFENSE.
THE PITCHING WILL KEEP THEM IN
GAMES.
THEY CAN TREAD WATER WITH THE
BULLPENNING TILL THEY GET SOME
OFFENSE GOING.
YOU WOULD HATE TO WASTE SOME OF
THESE GREAT STARTS.
>> THE CARDINALS HAVE THE BEST
RECORD IN THE NL CENTRAL.
JACK FLAHERTY WAS AWESOME.
HE IS WITH US RIGHT NOW ON THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
CONGRATS ON THE W.
HOW WOULD YOU EVALUATE WHAT YOU
DID?
>> IT HELPS WHEN YOU GET A LEAD
AGAINST A GUY LIKE BURNS.
HE HAS BEEN UNBELIEVABLE.
FROM THERE, IT IS ABOUT
PRESERVING THAT.
YOU WANT TO GET THOSE GUYS BACK
IN, PUT UP A GOOD ONE.
FROM THERE, EXECUTE WHEN YOU
NEED TO.
THEY DID A GOOD JOB KEEPING THE
UNDER CONTROL.
THERE'S A LOT OF POINTS THEY HAD
RUNNERS ON.
YOU'VE JUST GOT TO EXECUTE.
DAN: IN THE SECOND INNING, ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU WENT FROM 92,
95, SO THAT VELO IS THERE WHEN
YOU WANT IT, I AM GUESSING.
>> THAT HAS BEEN WORKED ON ABOUT
MANAGING THE GAME, HOW IT GOES.
FEELING WHEN TO GO TO THAT AND
WHEN I MIGHT BE ABLE TO SIT
AROUND 93 OR 94.
THERE'S POINTS WHERE YOU'VE GOT
TO BRING IT OUT.
MATT: GOOD TO SEE YOU.
LOVE WATCHING YOU PITCH.
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR FASTBALL.
50% FASTBALL.
TALKING ABOUT IT ON THE
BROADCAST, DO YOU FEEL LIKE IT
IS THE EXTENSION YOU GET OUT IN
FRONT THAT ALLOWS YOU TO THROW
MANY FASTBALLS?
IT LOOKS TO ME IT CUTS A LITTLE
BIT WHEN YOU GO TO THE FIRST
BASE SIDE OF THE FIELD.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU
CONSCIOUSLY DO?
IS THAT A NATURAL?
>> YEAH, I THINK IT NATURALLY
DOES THAT.
SOMETIMES IT CUTS WHEN I GO TO
THAT SIDE.
THE BIGGEST THING IS TRYING TO
BE ABLE TO LOCATE IT.
THERE'S TIMES YOU GET AWAY WITH
SOME OVER THE MIDDLE.
THE BETTER JOB I CAN DO LOCATING
IT AND KEEPING THE BALL DOWN,
THAT IS WHERE GOOD THINGS HAPPEN
WHEN THE BALL IS AROUND THE
KNEES.
SCOTT: TODAY WAS A SPECIAL DAY.
A GLOBAL AUDIENCE WATCHING YOU
PITCH ON YOUTUBE.
2-0.
THERE IS A NEW TRADITION IN
2021.
SOME BIG NAMES TAKING HOME THE
TROPHY.
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
THE TROPHY IS YOURS.
WE HAVE A COPY IN YOUR HANDS
COMING UP IN A MOMENT.
WE WILL PUT YOUR NAME ON IT AS
WELL.
THIS IS BRAND-NEW.
54% OF FANS VOTED FOR YOU.
HOW DOES IT FEEL?
IS IT HEAVY?
>> IT IS HEAVY.
I GUESS THIS IS COOL.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN TURN THIS INTO
A WORLD SERIES TROPHY.
SCOTT: THAT WOULD BE NICE.
MATT: I KNOW HOLLYWOOD WAS
WANTING THIS.
I KNOW YOU WANTED NOLAN TO GET
THIS.
I COULD HEAR YOU TALK ABOUT IT.
NAH, IT'S ALL GOOD.
>> GIVE IT TO NOLAN AS A TROPHY.
MATT: I WILL LET HIM KNOW.
DAN: YOUR BULLPEN HAS BEEN
IMPRESSIVE.
DO YOU FEEL YOUR BULLPEN WILL BE
ABLE TO HOLD IT DOWN?
IT HAS BEEN THE STRENGTH.
>> THOSE GUYS ARE LIGHTS OUT.
YOU BRING IN GIO, THOSE GUYS
HAVE BEEN LIGHTS OUT.
EVEN EARLY ON IN THE SERIES,
EVERYBODY WE BROUGHT OUT HAS
BEEN LIGHTS OUT.
WHEN WE COME OUT, WE FEEL GOOD
TURNING THE BALL OVER TO THOSE
GUYS WITH A LEAD.
SCOTT: WHAT ABOUT THE RUN
SUPPORT?
IT IS NOT SOMETHING YOU CONTROL.
TODAY WAS TWO RUNS ON THE BOARD.
HOW NICE IS IT FOR YOU, WE TALK
ABOUT THIS, TO PITCH WITH A
LEAD.
DOES IT CHANGE HOW YOU WERE
WORKING?
>> PITCHING WITH A LEAD WAS
SOMETHING I DID NOT DO A GOOD
JOB OF EARLY ON.
I'VE DONE A BETTER JOB OF
MENTALLY STAYING ON THE ATTACK
AND DOING THE LITTLE THINGS.
WHEN THE OFFENSE GIVES YOU A
LEAD, YOU'VE JUST GOT TO
CONTINUE TO ATTACK AND USE IT.
USE THE BIG PART OF THE PLATE.
MATT: YOU TALK ABOUT SOME OF
YOUR HARDEST PITCHES LATE IN THE
GAME, HOW MUCH DO YOU ATTRIBUTE
TO YOUR WEIGHT PROGRAM AND WHAT
YOU DO BETWEEN STARTS AND HOW
MUCH TIME AND EFFORT YOU PUT IN
AND WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND THE
WEIGHT ROOM IN THE TRAINING
ROOM?
TALK TO THE FANS ABOUT WHAT IT
TAKES TO GET READY.
YOU DON'T JUST SHOW UP AND
PITCH.
>> NOTHING WOULD BE POSSIBLE ON
START DAY WITHOUT THE DAYS IN
BETWEEN.
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT.
HE TAKES THOSE DAYS, BUT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, BEING ABLE
TO CARRY VELO INTO THE INNINGS
AND AS YOU GET AROUND 100
PITCHES, WE'VE HAD GUYS GO 100,
120.
CERTAIN DAYS ARE GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT.
BUT BEING ABLE TO MAINTAIN THAT
VELO GOES BACK TO THOSE DAYS IN
THE OFF-SEASON.
IT GOES BACK TO THOSE DAYS IN
BETWEEN OF THE CONSTANT WORK
YOU'VE GOT TO DO TO GET READY
FOR THE FIFTH DAY.
THINGS DON'T HAPPEN WITHOUT
THOSE DAYS IN BETWEEN.
SCOTT: KEEP IT UP.
YOU EARNED A LITTLE EXTRA
SOMETHING.
CONGRATS ON BEING THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
YOU CAN SHOW IT OFF.
THERE IS THE PLAY BUTTON.
YOU LIKE IT?
>> RIGHT ON TOP.
SCOTT: WE APPRECIATE IT.
GOOD LUCK THE REST OF THE WAY.
>> THANK YOU.
MATT: JACK FLAHERTY WAS GREAT.
THE LAST SEVEN STARTS, 7-0.
43 INNINGS.
ONE HOME RUN ALLOWED.
DAN: HE'S PITCHING WELL.
I KNOW WINS ARE POOH-POOHED.
HE IS WELL ON HIS WAY TO WINNING
20 GAMES.
SCOTT: LOOK AT HIM GO FOR A
CARDINALS TEAM THAT LEADS THE NL
CENTRAL.
JUST 15 DOWN ON THE YEAR.
THEY WIN THE SERIES IN
MILWAUKEE.
MUCH MORE COVERAGE COMING YOUR
WAY ON THE POSTGAME SHOW
2-0 IS YOUR FINAL ON A THURSDAY
AFTERNOON.
>> I THINK THE BIGGEST THING IS,
YOU ARE TALKING TO GUYS WHO HAVE
BEEN PLAYING FOR A LONG TIME.
THE FACT THEY ARE OPEN TO
EXPRESSING THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH, IT
DOES NOT GET BETTER THAN THAT.
THE BEST THING I CAN DO IS ASK
QUESTIONS AND SOAK UP AS MUCH AS
I CAN.
HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS ME IN THE
FUTURE.
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE POST GAME
SHOW PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
BEAUTIFUL TRADITIONAL NATIONAL
LEAGUE CONTEST TODAY.
THIS IS HOW IT WENT DOWN.
>> THERE HE IS, THE MAN OF THE
HOUR.
NO WALKS.
49 STRIKEOUTS.
SCOTT: BIG NUMBERS IN THE FIRST
INNING.
FACING A 3-2 COUNT.
CORBIN BURNES LIKES TO HANDLE
HIS BUSINESS WITH THREE BALL
COUNTS.
HE STAYS IN THE ZONE.
DAN: IT SHOWS YOU HOW MUCH
CONFIDENCE HE HAS IN THE PITCH.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO HE WAS
BASICALLY A FOUR SEAM FASTBALL
GUY.
HE IS NOT AFRAID TO RUN DEEP
COUNTS.
SCOTT: AND HE CHASES 97.
THAT DIPS DOWN.
IT IS THE FIRST OUT OF THE DAY.
DAN: THE STREAK IS ALIVE.
SCOTT: THAT IS GOING TO BREAK
THE ICE FOR THE CARDINALS.
NOLAN ARENADO MAKES IT 1-0.
TWO HITS AND ONE RUN FOR ST.
LOUIS.
HERE COMES MATT CARPENTER.
3-11 A COUPLE OF HOMERS.
THAT ONE IS LIFTED TO SHALLOW
CENTER.
RACING AGAIN.
GOING TO BE TOUGH.
IT DROPS.
ARENADO IS GOING TO ROUND THIRD.
HERE COMES THE THROW.
IT IS IN TIME.
ARENADO THROWS AT HOME.
JACK FLAHERTY, CERTAIN PLAYERS
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC, IT
AFFECTED JACK FLAHERTY.
>> 1-3 FOR THE SERIES.
HE HAS WALKED TWICE AND STRUCK
OUT.
>> THAT IS A GREAT PLAY BY PAUL
GOLDSCHMIDT.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN WITH
FLAHERTY.
>> CORBIN BURNES, HERE IT IS.
STRIKE HIM OUT SWINGING.
BURNS WITH STRIKEOUT NUMBER TWO
IN THE GAME.
THE BATTER IS GOING TO BE
HARRISON BADER.
>> HE SETS A NEW RECORD.
52 STRIKEOUTS.
NO WALKS.
THE MOST K'S TO START A SEASON.
HE TOPS KENLEY JANSEN'S RECORD
OF 51 FROM 2017.
THERE YOU ARE.
HE BROKE YOUR RECORD AS A
STARTER IN 2013.
>> FLAHERTY GOING TO-12 THIS
YEAR.
>> HERE HE COMES AGAIN.
STRIKE HIM OUT SWINGING.
AND HE STRIKES OUT THE SIDE WITH
A BASE HIT.
SCOTT: GOOD BATTLE FOR KNIZNER.
HE LOSES OUT ON IT TO CORBIN
BURNES.
STRIKEOUT NUMBER EIGHT OF THE
AFTERNOON.
>> JACK FLAHERTY COMING UP.
SCOTT: MOST STRIKEOUTS BETWEEN
WALKS.
GERRIT COLE HAS THE NUMBER AT 56
IN A ROW.
HE PITCHED YESTERDAY.
BURNES PASSES HIM FOR NOW.
AND HE PUTS AWAY FLAHERTY.
>> TOMMY EDMAN 1-2.
>> HE STARTED THE FIRST WITH A
SINGLE.
THE ONLY MAN TO SCORE TODAY.
HE IS ON BOARD AGAIN.
REACHES AND THE STREAK HAS COME
TO A CLOSE.
CORBIN BURNES HAS ISSUED A FREE
PASS FOR THE FIRST TIME THIS
SEASON.
>> LOOKS LIKE HIS CONCENTRATION
HAS INCREASED.
HIS EXECUTION IS EVEN SHARPER.
SCOTT: GOES FISHING FOR OUT
NUMBER ONE.
VOGELBACH AT SECOND.
>> CABRERA WARMING UP.
JACKIE BRADLEY JR. IN THE
ON-DECK CIRCLE.
SCOTT: BADER BACKING UP.
HE'S GOT SOME ROOM.
>> HE IS FEELING CONFIDENT IN
THIS AT-BAT.
HIS SIGHTLINES ARE GOOD.
HE'S FEELING GOOD ABOUT HIS
SITUATION.
SCOTT: THERE IS YOUR CHANCE.
LORENZO CAIN, TOSSES HOME, ADMIN
RACES IN.
THE THROW IS MONEY.
THEY GOT HIM.
>> WHAT A THROW.
SCOTT: PITCHING, DEFENSE AND IN
THE NINTH INNING, A LITTLE BIT
OF ALEX REYES.
THAT SLIDER IS NASTY.
DAN: ONE AFTER ANOTHER.
WHAT A WAY TO END IT.
ANOTHER NASTY BREAKING BALL.
FLY BALL TO CENTER FIELD.
BASE HIT.
BREW CREW THINK THEY HAVE
SOMETHING GOING NOW.
WHAT REYES HAS DONE IS SLAM THE
DOOR.
NOT ONE OF HIS BEST SLIDERS.
HE GETS ANOTHER SWING AND A
MISS.
SCOTT: ONE EARNED RUN IN 20
INNINGS.
ALEX REYES GETTING THE JOB DONE.
THE CARDINALS 2, THE BREWERS
NOTHING.
BEAUTIFUL TRADITIONAL NATIONAL
LEAGUE CONTEST ACCORDING TO
FIREBALL REVIEW AND THE LIVE
CHAT.
MORE ON JACK FLAHERTY WITH THE
HELP OF STATCAST 3D POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD.
SIX STRIKEOUTS, 12 IN PLAY.
18 RECORDED.
SIX SHUTOUT INNINGS.
DAN: YOU LOOK AT THE HEAT, DOWN
IN THE STRIKE ZONE A LOT.
THE MANAGER TOLD US HE'S ONE OF
THOSE GUYS DOWN IN THE ZONE.
CORBIN BURNES, MORE CUTTERS.
FLAHERTY MORE DOWN IN THE ZONE.
WHEN HE NEEDED EXTRA VELO, HE
WAS ABLE TO FIND IT.
SCOTT: DID IT HAVE THAT CLASSIC
FEEL YOU LOVE?
MATT: WE TALK ABOUT PITCHING AND
DEFENSE AND WE KNEW COMING IN
BOTH STARTERS WERE GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT TO SCORE ON,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE SHADOWS
TAKING OVER.
THE ROOF BEING OPEN, THAT MIGHT
HAVE AFFECTED TWO OR THREE BALLS
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN HOME RUNS.
GOOD PITCHING AND THE CARDINALS,
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR.
TURN THE BALL OVER TO GALLEGOS.
FINISH IT WITH REYES.
HE'S BEEN UNHITTABLE.
PRETTY MUCH PRESCRIPTIVE WHAT
THE CARDINALS WERE LOOKING FOR.
GETTING THE SERIES WIN AND THEY
MOVED TO SAN DIEGO.
SCOTT: THAT WAS FUN FOR US AND
J.P. MOROSI AT THE BALLPARK,
FEELING THE SUN AND WIND.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
J.P.: FIRST, IT WAS A PLEASURE
TO WORK WITH YOU.
WHAT A GREAT GAME BETWEEN THE
TOP TEAMS IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE
CENTRAL.
TO HEAR THE OVATION FOR BURNES
WHEN HE SET THE RECORD AND
ANOTHER ROUND OF APPLAUSE AFTER
THE RECORD STOPPED AT 58 WAS
GREAT TO BE BACK AT THE BALLPARK
AND HEAR THE SOUNDTRACK THAT HAS
DRAWN US ALL TO THE GREAT GAME
OF BASEBALL.
HOW GRATEFUL I FIELD TO HAVE
BEEN HERE TODAY AND HEAR THOSE
GREAT OVATIONS FROM THE HOME
CROWD.
THE CARDINALS NOW, WE REFERENCE
TO THIS, THEY ARE 15-5 SINCE
EDMUND AND CARLSON HAVE BEEN ONE
INTO.
YOU THINK ABOUT THOSE TABLE
SETTER'S AND SWITCH HITTERS.
AHEAD OF NOLAN ARENADO AND PAUL
GOLDSCHMIDT, THEY WILL HAVE PAUL
DEJONG BACK AT SOME POINT.
THIS IS A VERY DEEP LINEUP FOR
THE CARDINALS.
YOU SEE THE VERY -- OVERALL LINE
OF NOW, ST. LOUIS HAS THE EDGE
OVER THE BREWERS.
THE BREWERS HAVE SCORED SEVEN
RUNS IN THEIR LAST FOUR GAMES.
CREDIT TO THE PITCHING, THEY WON
TWO OF THEM.
THEY HAVE TO CONTINUE WITH
OUTINGS LIKE THIS FROM BURNES
AND PERALTA.
THEY HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO WIN
WITH THE ROTATION WITH THE
BATTING ORDER HAVING THE LOWEST
BATTING AVERAGE IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE.
AS YOU REFERENCED, HOPING TO SEE
A RETURN FROM CHRISTIAN YELICH.
THOSE GAMES VERY HIGHLY REGARDED
AND WATCHED BY THE BASEBALL
WORLD, HOW HE LOOKS THIS
WEEKEND.
WE HAVE TO A TAKE A LOOK AROUND
THE MAJOR LEAGUES AS WELL WITH
OUR GAME OF THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE KEY
HEADLINES.
THIS IS KNOWN AS THE EIGHTH
START OF THE YEAR FOR ZACH
PLESAC.
LOGAN GILBERT'S DEBUT.
ALL KINDS OF THINGS IN SEATTLE.
SOROKA HAS A SETBACK.
EXPLORATORY SURGERY.
THE OAKLAND ATHLETICS ANNOUNCED
THEY WILL BE EXPLORING POSSIBLE
RELOCATION OPTIONS.
IT IS NOT IMMINENT.
THE ANNOUNCEMENT COMING THE
CURRENT COLISEUM SITE WILL NO
LONGER BE THE LONG-TERM HOME OF
THE A'S.
IT IS EITHER DOWNTOWN OAKLAND OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
I REFERENCED THE ZACH PLESAC
START, HOW ABOUT THIS, WE HAVE A
TRAVEL BASEBALL TEAM OUT IN
WISCONSIN.
HIS YOUNGER BROTHER, 16 MILES
FROM WHERE I AM STANDING RIGHT
NOW.
PLAYS ON THE SAME TRAVEL TEAM AS
CRAIG COUNSELL'S SON.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
THE SAME TEAM, CRAIG COUNSELL'S
SON, 16 MILES AWAY, ALL ROADS
LEAD TO THIS GREAT PLACE WHERE
DAN PLESAC PITCHED FOR THE
BREWERS.
SCOTT: NEWS YOU CAN ONLY GET
RIGHT HERE ON
WHAT A DAY.
2-0 OVER THE BREWERS.
WE WILL WRAP IT UP ON THE
POSTGAME SHOW IN A MOMENT.
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> YES.
>> HIT HIGH AND DEEP.
THIS IS HEADED TO THE WATER.
GONE.
ALMOST GOT HIT BY IT.
>> THAT IS A LONG SHOT.
>> SWUNG ON.
SUGIURA DRIFTING OUT.
HE MAKES THE CATCH.
HE WAS RIGHT IN FRONT OF HIM.
MAYBE THREE FEET IN FRONT OF
HIM.
HE KNEW HE WAS NOWHERE NEAR IT.
VERY SOFT HIGH FIVE.
>> TOMMY PURCHASED A NET.
NOW THE TEAM HAS BECOME AN
ADDICT INTO PICKLE BALL.
JUST TO HAVE FUN.
MAYBE SOME PHYSICAL EXERCISE.
THAT IS WHAT MIKE NAPOLI SAID.
>> PUNCHES THAT ONE DOWN THE
LINE.
WHAT A PLAY.
THAT IS LISA CROSS.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK PRESENTED BY STATE
FARM.
HANGING OUT WITH YOU AFTER THE
CARDINALS TOP THE BREWERS.
LOOK AT THE SCHEDULE WE ARE
LAYING OUT THROUGH JULY 9 ON
YOUTUBE.
THE GIANTS MATCHUP WITH THE REDS
AND THE PHILLIES AND MARLINS THE
WEEK AFTER.
THE METS AND DIAMONDBACKS,
DODGERS AND PIRATES.
THE A'S HOT OUT WEST ARE GOING
TO BE IN TEXAS AGAINST THE
RANGERS.
THE MARINERS'S MATCHUP WITH THE
BLUE JAYS.
THE COUNTRY OF CANADA GETTING
SOME ACTION ON YOUTUBE.
JULY 9, THE REDS AGAIN MATCHING
UP WITH THIS SQUAD WE TALKED
ABOUT, THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS,
SHUT OUT 2-0 AS WE WRAP THINGS
UP ON THE POSTGAME SHOW.
SCOTT BRAUN AND DAN PLESAC, MATT
HOLLIDAY, A GREAT SCHEDULE AS WE
FLASH BACK FOR A MOMENT.
MATT HOLLIDAY, SEPTEMBER 19,
PAINT THE PITCHER FOR US.
MATT: THAT WAS MY SECOND AT-BAT.
THE FIRST ONE HE HIT ME IN THE
TOP OF MY BACK.
IT NEVER WORKS WHEN YOU TRIED TO
HIT A HOME RUN.
IT ACTUALLY WORKED THAT TIME.
I WAS TRYING TO HIT IT AS FAR AS
I POSSIBLY COULD.
SCOTT: ESTIMATED 500 FEET.
BENNY NO, YOUTUBE CREATOR, SAYS
HE AND HIS DAD ONCE DROPPED A
HOLLIDAY HOME RUN IN THE
POSTSEASON.
THAT'S THINGS.
MAYBE MATT WILL SET YOU UP WITH
A FRESH BASEBALL.
AS FAR AS THE HOME RUN DISTANCE,
ABOUT 500 FEET.
THAT IS MORE LIKE IT.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
THAT IS THE GOOD STUFF IN YOUR
ROCKIES DAYS.
MATT: I WAS GOING TO SAY, I WAS
GOING TO REFERENCE THAT ONE.
AGAIN, I DID NOT THINK THERE WAS
PROOF.
I'M SURPRISED YOU FOUND THE
VIDEO.
NICE JOB.
THAT WAS A GOOD HOME RUN.
MATT CAIN HAD HIT ME IN THE
BACK.
I WAS KIND OF MAD.
I THOUGHT HE DID IT ON PURPOSE.
I THOUGHT I REALLY WANT TO HIT
ONE AS FAR AS I CAN.
IT ACTUALLY WORKED.
SCOTT: THAT IS GOOD.
WE FIND EVERYTHING HERE.
DAN: I GAVE UP ONE OF THOSE.
I KNOW WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO
THROW ONE OF THOSE.
SCOTT: THAT IS A CLASSIC.
WHEN WE MIC UP PLAYERS, WE GET
GREAT CONTACT -- CONTENT.
HERE ARE THE WORDS OF KOLTEN
WONG.
>> MIC CHECK.
CHECK 1, 2, 3.
A GREAT TIME TO START.
I JUST WOKE UP.
GOSH DANG IT.
SUP BROTHER.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
FOUR.
I'M MIC UP.
IT'S A NICE DAY IN MILWAUKEE.
WARM 65.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I USED TO PLAY
AT 9:00 IN THE MORNING.
WIDE AWAKE AND READY TO GO.
12:40, MAN.
YOUTUBE, I'M GOING TO LET YOU
KNOW, THIS GAME IS ON YOU.
IF I HAVE A GOOD GAME, IT IS ON
YOU.
YOU ARE THE BIGGEST 13-YEAR-OLD
I HAVE SEEN.
I LIKE THE JERSEY.
VERY NICE MEETING YOU.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
ARE YOU BACK TODAY?
LET'S GO.
COME ON, BABY.
LET'S DO IT.
WIRED.
YOU DON'T SAY ANYTHING GOOD
ANYWAY, BRO.
♪ GO LOW
GO LOW ♪ ♪
>> THAT IS A YOUTUBE ORIGINAL.
I HOPE YOU GOT THAT.
I TURNED 30 THIS YEAR.
MY GOD I AM HURTING.
38 OLD.
LET'S PLAY BACK ON HIM.
HE'S GOING TO TRY TO SHOOT IT
THIS WAY IF HE GETS THE CHANCE.
WRONG PITCH.
THOUGHT YOU HAD THAT STRIKE.
GOOD PITCH.
THERE'S A LOT OF DUDES WITH
THEIR SHIRTS OFF.
KIND OF WEIRD.
SCOTT: THE GRAND FINALE FROM
KOLTEN WONG.
THE CARDINALS THE BEST, 23-15.
THE BREWERS IN THE SECOND SPOT.
SO MUCH CONTENT TO CHOOSE FROM
FROM KOLTEN WONG INCLUDING THAT
LITTLE SONG FROM BRENT SUTER IN
THE DUGOUT.
DAN: THAT IS GOOD.
YOU GET TO GO INSIDE THE DUGOUT
AND SEE WHAT GOES ON.
HERE THE CONVERSATION AND THE
LINGO.
SCOTT: IS THAT WHAT WAS GOING ON
DURING THE BASEBALL CAREER?
MATT: I DON'T REMEMBER THE
MUSIC.
ANY OF THE BANKING OF THE MUSIC.
THERE'S DEFINITELY SOME KID-LIKE
BEHAVIOR THAT GOES ON.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP IT LIGHT.
YOU ARE TOGETHER A LOT.
YOU ARE GRINDING.
THERE'S A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
INVOLVED.
YOU NEED THOSE GUYS THAT CAN
BRING A SENSE OF HUMOR AND BRING
THE FUN EVERY DAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF KID LIKE
SHENANIGANS.
SCOTT: FIRST GAME BROADCAST.
DID YOU HAVE FUN?
MATT: IT WAS GREAT.
YOU GUYS ARE PROS.
I APPRECIATE YOU LETTING ME COME
ON.
SCOTT: WE LOVED HAVING YOU.
GOOD LUCK THE REST OF THE SEASON
WITH THE COACHING STAFF AT
OKLAHOMA STATE.
WE WILL CHAT AGAIN SOON.
MATT: THANKS.
SCOTT: MATT HOLLIDAY AND DAN
PLESAC WITH US ALONG WITH J.P.
MOROSI.
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE BACK NEXT WEEK.
ANOTHER NL CENTRAL MEMBER, THE
REDS HOSTING THE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS.
COVERAGE STARTS WITH THE PREGAME
SHOW AT NOON.
WE WILL TALK AGAIN THEN.
FOR DAN PLESAC AND THE
SUPERHUMAN STRENGTH OF MATT
HOLLIDAY, MR. MIDWEST J.P.
MOROSI AND I AM SCOTT BRAUN
LOGGING OUT FOR NOW.
SEE YOU NEXT TIME ON YOUTUBE.